what do you do when the sun turns wrong
when light which once represented life
joy and warmth becomes a symbol of death
and destruction do you hide inside
shutter the windows keep out the light
by any means necessary do you Retreat
underground where the sun's Rays cannot
penetrate burrowing into the dark in the
cold do you simply give yourself to it
accepting that there is no escaping
something so vast so far reaching as
sunlight itself and allow yourself to be
lost in the end of all things we've
covered this possibility before
scp-001 when day breaks or SD Locke's
proposal it's difficult to know what any
given person might do in such harrowing
circumstances after all we have always
learned to love the light and fear the
darkness it turns our very understanding
of reality upside down to have that
Paradigm shifted the dark becoming
safety and the light becoming death the
source of all life on Earth of all
warmth transforming in an instant from
the Sun as we know it to an apollyon
class SCP that melts all living
organisms that cross into its gaze but
what about a being that has always
feared the light something that
prioritizes Solitude and never ever
wants to be seen how might it live out
those darkened days today we're taking a
look at what happens when Daybreak meets
a familiar face even if a constantly
hidden one
scp-096
scp-096 or the shy guy is something of a
celebrity around here it is a humanoid
creature with long distended arms pale
skin and a jaw that can open four times
wider than an ordinary humans there is
only one thing above all else that this
entity desires for no one to see its
face when someone views its face it
flies into an uncontrollable rage and
seems to have no other option but to
destroy the person who has seen it so it
is unlikely that a creature so intent on
Solitude would be in much Danger from
the transformed sun in fact it might
even be a positive thing and for some
time it was with so many human beings
gone reduced to gelatinous masses with
no desire but to Slither around in the
ghoulish sunlight and merge with one
another there were fewer people to
observe his face than ever he could stay
inside and know with almost complete
certainty that no one would come to
bother him no one was coming to look at
him and there were no more visitors
researchers poking and prodding that
might sneak a look at his face and so he
stayed there in the room that had served
as his containment unit before the world
turned upside down the masses of Flesh
that once were humans did not concern
him as they never looked at his face all
he did was stay in his room and never go
outside the outside frightened him
terribly though he was not concerned
with the deadly sunlight or the
possibility of it melting him as it had
so many others he was much more afraid
that someone some unlikely Survivor
clinging to their original life might
look at him that they might see his face
that was simply too distressing to risk
he would much rather stay alone in his
old cell weeping softly in the shadows
one day though we couldn't say how many
days after the end of things it had been
he was weeping alone in his former cell
the days blurred together spent the same
way and time had lost much of its
meaning through the echoing sound of his
sobs and the sloshing sounds of the
creatures outside a woman's voice cut
through it was faint but he could make
out what she was saying she was calling
out for help asking if anyone had any
food or fresh water the sound was
getting louder closer accompanied by the
disconcerting thump of her footsteps she
was coming down the hall as much as it
could be called a hall anymore she was
coming towards his room to disrupt his
miserable peace he heard her steps cross
the threshold of his room and her voice
broke into a terrified scream no doubt
at the unexpected sight of a pale naked
creature weeping in the corner of what
she expected to be an empty room
startled by the first loud sound he'd
heard in a long time in a world that had
mostly been silent since the initial
outpouring of agonized Screams had faded
into the soft slap of Flesh and slime on
the ground he turned around he shouldn't
ordinarily he wouldn't but he couldn't
stop himself there he saw a woman wide
eyes filled with tears face streaked
with dirt a small child next to her
holding her hand and clinging to her leg
just as he saw the woman she saw him she
saw saw his face anger boiled over
inside of him and he let out a scream
wild Primal and filled with inhuman rage
she could not be looking at him seeing
his face he couldn't let her the woman
ran with a child in tow panicked by the
wild Roar in the sight of him standing
up right before her the anger faded as
she left his sight making her way down
the hall into the stairs but then he
remembered she had seen his face he
could not let her leave it was time to
do something he never thought he'd have
to do again hunt his heightened senses
picked up the sound of muffled footsteps
coming up through the floor below him
she was downstairs just beneath the
floor where he was standing his
instincts kicked in and his body moved
almost of its own accord he lifted his
long long arms above his head and drove
his hands down into the floor it was
weakened by the RAV images of the
elements and time and crumbled under his
unnatural strength he dug his claws into
the plaster tearing it apart and
cracking it into pieces he pushed his
claws in deeper and deeper until he
could feel them breaking through the
other side he pulled the floor apart
until the hole was wide enough to fit
through then dropped down to the room
below he spotted the woman's back
fleeing through the door just as he
landed she was getting away he tore
after her ripping through concrete and
steel destroying everything in his path
in a Mad Dash for the object of his rage
he had to catch her she could not be
allowed to leave she looked over her
shoulder at him her face a mask of pure
Terror she knew just as he knew that
there was no Escape in sight in his
single-minded obsession and her
desperation to escape from him neither
of them noticed that she had run so far
and so carelessly that she was now
outside the building she he had crossed
from the Shadows into the harsh light of
the Sun the woman's eyes widened in Grim
understanding of her fate he could only
watch helplessly as her body began to
succumb to the vicious Rays almost
instantly she began to melt as it was
closest to the Sun her head was the
first to go her nose drooped like hot
wax dripping as it went until it slumped
off her face and landed on the ground
with a sickening Splash her eyes were
next popping out of their sockets and
hanging loose and Limp on her cheeks and
dangling from sinewy strands she tried
in vain to stuff them back into place
but they squished in her hands like over
ripe fruit she attempted to run into the
comparative safety of the ruined
building but her feet were already
beginning to spread out onto the street
melting into a sticky red smear on the
pavement her legs crumbled beneath her
and she collapsed to the ground her face
leaving a trail of gelatinous Flesh as
it landed she tried uselessly to drag
herself along the ground back into the
darkness but her arms were melting into
the dirt mixing with it into a horrible
red mud she let out a last scream of
Agony but the sound turned to a thick
gurgle as her lips fused together and
her mouth melted into nothingness he
watched it all sobbing and roaring in
frustration she was gone and he would
never get the satisfaction of ending her
The Infernal son had stolen her from him
now she was nothing but a wet Shadow
like the rest of the humans had become
long ago he heard the sound of a soft
SOB behind him a tiny human voice he
turned looking for the source there was
the little girl he had almost forgotten
about her she was calling out for her
mother and crying and she was looking
right at him right at his face he waited
for the anger to overtake him but
instead there was nothing why wasn't he
angry she was looking at his face so why
then he realized her eyes were on him
but she did not see him she was blind
she approached the creature her arms
outstretched following the sound of his
crying she touched his hand with her own
tiny fingers so small and fragile and
asked Mommy then he felt something he
had never felt before tenderness care a
desire to protect this tiny innocent
being it was the first time he had ever
felt warm ever felt anything but sadness
anger or fear overcome with his softness
he wrapped his arms around the child and
hugged her clothes she hugged him back
tightly and the room went quiet as they
both stopped crying from that day on
they became a family of sorts they lived
together and he took care of her she
didn't know what he looked like and had
no idea he might something to fear to
her he was safety he was home for the
first time in his long awful life he
felt like a Human Instead of a monster
he would scavenge food for her bring her
fresh water lay down stolen blankets and
pillows so she would have a soft place
to rest he even found her a ratty worn
teddy bear amongst the rubble and gave
it to her as a gift she clutched it to
her chest and thanked him and for once
his tears were those of joy in this
cursed World they had found something
like happiness in one another he knew he
would protect her no matter what then
one day everything changed the creature
and the little girl were playing in the
abandoned sight making up little games
together when he took a break to look
out at the window and monitor their
surroundings outside the evil Red Sun
waited when he turned back the little
girl was gone one of the shadowy
creatures once human was imitating voice
to lure her away he could hear it in the
distance and her tiny footsteps
following it he chased after her the
only thing he had ever loved and saw her
just as she stepped out into the light
she screamed as one of her arms began to
melt in the light and he knew what he
had to do he grabbed her and pulled her
back inside using his body to Shield her
from the horrible Rays as he wept over
her his tears stopped her body from
melting any further but his body
continued to fall apart it was too late
for him he ran as far as he could once
he transformed he did not want to end up
hurting the girl he ran until his legs
melted away and he could not run anymore
he had reached the shoreline and stared
out at the ocean unable to move anymore
he screamed a final time in agony in
heartbreak in mourning for the happiness
he had finally found and now would lose
but least he knew as his eyes melted
away and he was nearly gone that the
girl would be safe and then he was gone
and the world was quiet think back to
your childhood and ask yourself what was
the most pain you've ever felt while
growing up as we develop our
understanding of pain evolves according
to our different experiences the older
we get the injuries we suffered as
children like a scraped knee or a bee
sting rarely cause us the same level of
distress as they used to of course when
you are young and unfamiliar with
sensations of pain what you really need
in that moment straight after you've
fallen off your bike or tripped playing
soccer is someone to pick you back up
and give your sore spot a kiss perhaps
you even need a bowl of warm soup to
comfort you luckily for you
scp-348 is exactly that while many of
the anomalies held in containment by the
SCP Foundation have earned the Euclid or
inFAMOUS ketter class designate Nations
scp-348 is one of the few considered to
be safe both in the sense it poses no
containment risk and in that it wouldn't
hurt a fly it is neither an ancient
Eldritch Abomination From Another
Dimension spreading its influence in our
world through memetic stimuli nor is it
a recording of a basketball game in
which all the players and Spectators are
trapped inside it isn't an
indestructible limb generating reptile
or a towering winged being wielding a
flaming sword and guarding the entrance
to the Garden of Eden to put it simply
scp-348 is a bowl a white ceramic Bowl
the kind you would find almost anywhere
in the world it may even look
indistinguishable from the one in your
kitchen cabinet of course scp-348 is
hardly as ordinary as it outwardly
appears to be and it certainly isn't the
only inanimate object that the
foundation keeps safely stored away the
key thing that differentiates scp-348
from most other anomalies is how genuine
really harmless it is its anomalous
properties do not cause injury to any
individual that interacts with it nor
does this bull have any adverse effects
on the world around it
scp-348 cannot bend or reshape reality
it does not cause the person eating from
it to have premonitions of their own
death and using it certainly does not
manifest a contract making entity at the
opposite side of the table so what makes
this bowl in any way anomalous what
about it categorizes it as an SCP and
not just a harmless piece of fine
Crockery well why don't we start with
how scp-348 was first discovered some
time ago the SCP Foundation was made
aware of rumors surrounding the child
living in an unknown part of the world
according to the intelligence gathered
by the foundation this child seemed to
possess some sort of healing ability or
at least this is what rumors suggested
upon further investigation the source of
these so-called remarkable recovery
abilities wasn't the child but appeared
to come from a small small ceramic pole
which we now know as scp-348 this is not
to say that the bowl has any inherently
Supernatural healing properties and it
doesn't impart any regenerative power to
those that eat from it either it does
heal in a certain sense but not in the
way you're probably imagining when the
SCP Foundation recovered scp-348 there
were no markings on it indicating where
the bowl came from or who it was
manufactured by the only visually
distinct details worthy of note were
flowery patterns that appeared to be
hand-painted around both the inside and
outside of scp-348 the ceramic surface
also bore the Chinese letters shangshini
which translates to the phrase thinking
of you the child that first discovered
it found the ceramic Bowl in the Attic
of their home the child's parents were
both full-time workers and seemed to be
somewhat neglectful of their child
although they refused to comment on this
but according to the findings of the SCP
Foundation the child had come to rely on
scp-348 deciding to further investigate
the anomalous properties of scp-348 the
foundation began testing it given that
the child who first discovered the bowl
had relied upon it tests involve
Foundation researchers presenting
certain children to scp-348 and
observing the results so was this bowl
haunted perhaps harboring some malicious
Spirit or entity that sought to corrupt
these children maybe even healing them
in order to somehow use them as a vessel
to break into our world no and while may
have not healed in any overt or expected
way it did heal in at least a
metaphorical sense if presented with an
injured child supporting any form of
minor ailments such as a cut or a runny
nose
scp-348 fills with warm soup and yes
that's right we said soup what kind you
may ask well that seems to vary
sometimes it is tomato soup other times
it might be chicken noodle soup while
the ingredients you used in the soups
are often different there are notable
consistencies to how scp-348 heals if
anyone between the ages of 4 years old
and 18 years old sits down in front of
the blue flowered Bowl then scp-348 will
fill with soup numerous young test
subjects brought in by the foundation to
eat from this particular bowl of soup
have reported that they enjoyed their
meal usually finishing the entire Bowl
when permitted to by research staff many
of the injured children that were tested
have stated that the soup they eat from
scp-348 reminds them of their parents
cooking these children have expressed
contentment and feelings of comfort
after acquiring their various cuts and
bruises some even claim that even though
they were in a room all alone they
didn't feel lonely when they were eating
the soup and all the anomalous
properties don't end after a child
finishes the soup usually although not
always the bowl will leave the child a
message often some brief words of
reassurance or Comfort these messes just
materialize on the inside rim of the
bowl and seemed to be specifically
tailored to the subject that has just
eaten the words will not only be written
in the child's first language but are
often linked to the child's home life or
relationship with their parents messages
that appear on scp-348 usually fade over
time normally disappearing after a few
hours or when the bull refills with more
soup one test of scp-348 saw a little
girl age 8 and suffering from a sore
throat brought before the bowl according
to a background screening made by
research Personnel the girl lived with
her biological parents and apparently
had a good relationship with both her
mother and her father when scp-348
filled with superher the girl took
almost half an hour to finish eating and
afterwards reported that she felt her
sore throat get better as she aimed by
the end of the meal this test subject
remarked that she felt completely normal
in this instance no message appeared
within the bowl another child was
brought in to continue the testing of
scp-348 this time a boy of 10. unlike
the previous test this boy was not on
good terms with his parents and often
argued with them at the time of testing
the boy had sustained several minor
bruises the result of a small accident
that occurred while the boy had been out
riding his bike much like the little
girl this subject ate the soup that
scp-348 presented him with this time
though the bull offered a message to the
boy the lettering found on the ceramic
surface of scp-348 Simply Red don't
forget to brush messages also appeared
when an 11 year old boy with a slight
cold ate soup from the bowl this child
had been adopted by a foster family and
after eating from scp-348 he saw the
message I'm glad you're happy appear
another young test subject a boy aged
six had a similar experience in this
instance the child had several scrapes
and scratches from playing with his
friends his parents had divorced and he
he was living with his mother at the
time of testing this time scp-348's
message to this boy read I'm sorry son a
seven-year-old girl suffering from a
cough was brought in before scp-348 she
had lost her father to a traffic
accident sometime before testing
commenced and received the message I
love you after finishing her soup
further testing conducted by the
foundation revealed that anyone over the
age of 18 years who attempted to eat
soup from scp-348 experienced things
slightly differently unlike the children
older subjects mostly displayed a
disinterest in finishing their meal a
common complaint among those over 18 was
that the soup was missing something
however in a few isolated cases testing
scp-348 on older candidates still
revealed messages although the words
seemed to be faded not the clear
hand-painted blue that appeared when the
children had finished their soup one
woman aged 30 who was suffering from a
headache sat down in front of scp3 348
much like it had done before the bowl
filled with soup and the woman ate as
with some of the younger subjects a key
aspect of This Woman's background seemed
to be what triggered the message to
appear specifically she admitted to
being on bad terms with her mother and
father the woman explained that she had
opted to live on her own isolating
herself from her family in fact she even
described having rejected an offer her
father made to her many years earlier
refusing some Career Training that he
was willing to give in order to help her
secure a job when she finished the soup
one word appeared in the bowl why
another woman who was 40 years old was
also brought in for the scp-348 testing
much like the previous subject she had
moved away from home and became
estranged from her parents over the
years but unlike the previous test this
woman had taken it upon herself to not
only send money to her parents but also
arranged senior care for both as well
prior to testing her father had died
peacefully of natural causes after spend
ending his last days in the care that
this woman had paid for as the woman ate
the soup from the bowl she remarked
about its apparently bitter taste but
also described her meal as fulfilling
after she had finished the words thank
you appeared with an
scp-348 one other adult subject that
produced a noticeable result from
scp-348 was a 40 year old male the
results of this test appeared to be the
most distinctly different from any
previous adult or Child by now
researchers working for the SCP
Foundation had determined that familial
history seemed to play an important role
in the outcome of any interaction with
scp-348 and this individual was
certainly different to most the man in
question had murdered his father roughly
a year before the testing took place he
began the test with scp-348 while
Afflicted with aches in his back after
one Taste of the soup that appeared in
the Bowl before him the murderer was
immediately repulsed he complained about
the taste refusing to eat any more from
scp-348 shortly after the man began to
experience severe stomach pain the
potentially poisonous soup was disposed
of but scp-348 immediately filled with
salt water which took three hours to
disappear from the bowl despite
conducting numerous tests with subjects
of all ages and ailments the SCP
Foundation researchers have so far been
unable to determine the origins of the
messages that sometimes appear in
scp-348 some have theorized because of
the family histories of some children
and adults tested that the words somehow
come from the father of whoever eats the
soup since even when a subject's father
is alive or present in their life the
message seems to convey feelings that
their father has or would have other
researchers claim that this is just the
purpose of scp-348 to provide Comfort to
small children dealing with pain both
inside and out after all is in providing
Comfort one a good bowl of soup
anomalous or not is best app they'd
spend hours making the costume the two
young boys let's call them Johnny and
Max had always been on the creative side
sometimes they got teased for it at
school but they didn't care as long as
they had each other they could handle
anything they were best friends maybe
one day they'd build great things
together out of concrete and steel but
for now they worked with cardboard prior
projects had included building a rocket
out of cardboard in Johnny's backyard
like the kind that put a man on the moon
they'd also made a box Fort like no
other more a box Castle really the kind
that would stand for a hundred years as
long as it didn't rain of course but all
that felt like nothing compared to the
tunnel monster to these two young
friends it was a thing of beauty a fully
articulated cardboard monster costume
meticulously cobbled together from boxes
masking tape cardboard tubes for arms
and legs and a little twine to bring it
all together Frankenstein Dracula Freddy
Krueger those Silver Screen phonies were
nothing compared to the tunnel monster
they even cut out eye holes in the head
and Drew the scariest snarling mouth
that they could write below the making
was over and now they were ready to play
Johnny and Max took the costume down to
one of their favorite places in town the
abandoned Rector construction site to
many would seem like a strange and
dangerous place for two young children
to play but for Johnny and Max it was
perfect after all they were the age
where they had more imagination than
sense Max would be the one wearing the
costume Johnny helped him put it on
piece by piece using extra masking tape
and Twine where necessary to fasten all
the pieces together little by little Max
became the tunnel monster the
transformation was complete and it was
finally time for the games to begin
Johnny ran wielding a stick as a
defensive weapon while Max gave Chase he
could feel his own hot breath within the
cardboard mask it was oddly exhilarating
he gave a monstrous Roar and charged
after his friend chasing him into the
child-sized pipes of An Unfinished water
drainage system it was more fun than
anything they could have imagined Max
really got into his role he lunged
forwards grabbing Johnny with his
cardboard gauntlets and tried to drag
him back into the tunnel all while
giving low guttural growls Johnny
laughed and swatted at Max with his
stick like a night-wielding a sword they
ran and crawled through the tunnels the
best of friends having the best of times
making the kind of memories that would
last forever and in that sense they were
right something they made that day would
echo on forever but it wouldn't be
something they would look back upon
fondly if they weren't so busy running
through the tunnels Max and Johnny might
have noticed that something was amiss
they might have seen that even though it
was only 3 pm on a Summer's Day the sky
was beginning to darken it may not have
saved them but it might have given them
time to prepare for what was coming Max
was still chasing Johnny down a pipe
still fully in character as the tunnel
monster his arms extended to grab his
fleeing friend while Johnny tripped Max
stopped to help him up but something was
wrong when Max helped Johnny stand up
Johnny instinctually pushed him away as
though it wasn't actually his friend
anymore Max stumbled backwards in shock
and horror he could feel something
changing beneath the cardboard he
suddenly was in pain this terrible pain
like it was being pulled apart and put
back together he started to scream it
was a horrible sound like nails on a
chalkboard Johnny had to hold his ears
as the screaming got louder and louder
but Max couldn't stop he was hurting too
much to stop Johnny was crying he didn't
know what was happening only that his
friend was in terrible pain and that
there was seemingly nothing he could do
to stop it even Max didn't know much
more than that but he thought it might
have something to do with the suit it
felt like it was full of fire ants
crawling and biting it felt like his
body was full of fire ants he needed to
take the suit off before it got any
worse but he couldn't the suit wouldn't
come off he reached for the cardboard
mask and tried to tug it off his head
but it wouldn't budge he felt like he
was tugging at the skin of his own face
he could suddenly feel everything that
brushed against the cardboard like it
was connected to his nerve endings the
fear and the Panic got worse and he kept
screaming it was a deafening ear
splitting screen he didn't know it but
anything electrical within a 200 meter
radius was dying TVs shut off radios
fizzled out cars stopped running nobody
who didn't work for the SCP Foundation
would ever know why it wasn't even 3 30
PM but the sky above looked black and
Max was afraid but all he could do was
cling to the familiar he lunged forwards
and grabbed Johnny pulling him into his
trembling Embrace is he still Max now no
he doesn't think so anymore he's
something else entirely has he held his
friend Max tried to dig his fingers into
the mask and tear it off they pierced
through the cardboard tearing holes into
it it was agonizing but the masks stayed
put there was no Escape he closed his
eyes just for a moment maybe it was a
bad dream maybe he could make it
disappear but it didn't disappear only
he did Max was no more there was only
the tunnel monster when Johnny woke up
he was disoriented and afraid he was in
complete darkness but he could feel the
old metal of a rusty railroad track
beneath his feet he didn't remember how
he got there and he didn't remember Max
either not his face or even his name but
that's all right Max didn't remember him
either when the terrified Johnny
eventually found his way out of the old
railway tunnel he'd somehow found
himself in he was rescued by emergency
services and treated for dehydration
because of the incredibly strange
circumstances of his disappearance and
reappearance over 4 000 kilometers away
it was only natural for the SCP
Foundation to check in but seeing as
Johnny had no memory of where he was or
who he was with prior to his mysterious
teleportation all they ever did was
investigate the tunnel he'd appear in of
course they didn't find a thing the case
was closed shortly afterwards written
off as a kind of one-off spatial anomaly
Johnny was given amnesic treatment and
reintegrated back into his normal life
he would never remember his encounter
with the tunnel monster but many would
for decades and decades to come there
would be stories and Scattered witness
accounts from all kinds of people
maintenance workers doing electrical
repairs on subway tunnels sewer workers
cleaning up block packages in pipes Road
workers fixing the asphalt and
underpasses the challenge with being an
SCP Foundation field agent is often
separating the genuine leads from the
urban legends and spooky stories but the
details here were all too similar and
specific after all it would be such a
strange thing to make up a moldy old
pile of cardboard boxes getting up and
running towards you but stranger still
these incidents and encounters were
occurring all over the United States
with the only commonalities being that
all of them happened in tunnels or
tunnel-like structures the foundation
didn't know if they were dealing with
one entity or many another peculiar
Factor they observed was that sometimes
people who had encounters with the
tunnel monster then themselves appear in
tunnels extremely far away from the ones
in which they first encountered it as
far as the foundation was aware besides
transporting them vast distances it
never actually harmed any of its Victor
but according to one Boston sewer worker
Gus segrelia when the tunnel monster
laid its cardboard hand on him he felt
the most profound sense of paranoia and
Dread he described it as feeling like a
thousand eyes in the dark watching you
die then he blinked and he woke up in an
Arizona Viaduct roughly six hours later
everyone who reported a similar
experience with the tunnel monster was
detained debriefed and given amnestics
by the foundation eventually they
gathered enough data on prior encounters
to accurately predict the next tunnel
that the tunnel monster would manifest
inside a new mobile task force was
formed to secure the creature MTF new
four also known as the box cutters what
they didn't expect was that when they
finally engaged the Beast was that it
was no larger than a human child it
wasn't some huge tunnel dwelling
nightmare even after all these decades
the tunnel monster was little more than
a frightened lonely little boy he
growled attempt and failing to come off
as intimidating to these hardcore MTF
members and referred to himself as the
tunnel monster when they didn't react
with fear and surprise like the others
he became subdued they were able to
peacefully apprehend him and take him
back to site 54 for testing and
containment preliminary x-rays found
that the cardboard costume hadn't just
fused with the boy it had completely
transformed him on the inside he was
filled with crude cardboard copies of
all the major internal organs with his
blood vessels and nerve endings made out
of colored pieces of string they
couldn't find any information on who the
boy was if he had ever been a boy at all
and he was given the designation
scp-3663 in order to find out more one
of the leading researchers on the
scp-3663 case researcher Doyle decided
to conduct an interview with the tunnel
monster it had been the only interview
with the creature to date due to the
emotional distress it caused the
creature when asked about out its
identity it replied with only the tunnel
monster when asked why it attacked and
teleported people to different locations
the creature replied the tunnel monster
captures people that's me I'm the tunnel
monster I capture people and take them
into the tunnels where I live in the
tunnels the pipes I'm the tunnel monster
has the interview progressed the tunnel
monster became increasingly upset until
it began weeping through its cardboard
face finally culminating with its crying
out between sobs please I don't want to
play anymore
scp-3663 only feels comfortable in
tunnels and will teleport away in
distress if confined anywhere else as
such its containment chamber is
technically the maintenance tunnels
underneath site 54 Where it seems to
have made a home for itself occasionally
if it experiences fear damage or stress
it may Dem manifest and appear in
tunnels elsewhere at that point the box
cutters are deployed to collect 36 60 E3
once again and bring him back to site
54. so far there has only been one major
Containment Breach with
scp-3663 but it was a little more deadly
than you might expect for a boy-sized
creature made of cardboard the tunnel
monster escaped from the site-54 tunnels
and began wailing in pain it went
positively berserk attacking surrounding
staff and trashing parts of the facility
anyone who heard the whales of the
tunnel monster reported becoming
extremely psychologically disturbed by
them during this four hour Rampage the
monster also tried multiple times to
destroy itself with various implements
but was unsuccessful after
scp-3663 was recontained two deceased
members of personnel were recovered from
the scene autopsies showed the cause of
death was a buildup of paper residue and
wood pulp in all of their major blood
vessels as well as sinuses ear tubes and
the majority of the digestive and
respiratory systems a number of other
staff members were found to have been
affected to a lesser degree but are
expected to make full recoveries what
triggered this explosive and deadly
Outburst not even the tunnel monster
itself knew the answer to this question
but we do at exactly the same time a 79
year old man passed away from natural
causes after what seemed like a
thoroughly unremarkable life that man's
name was Johnny a man is sitting in a
chair inside a containment cell at the
SCP Foundation the man is dressed
normally and he isn't trying to escape
or attack the researchers who are
observing him the only thing that makes
this man different from you or I is that
he ages right in front of us going from
a teenager to an old man in a matter of
minutes at first glance
scp-1007 looks very normal just a corpse
lying in a standard coffin well the
corpse of an old man in a coffin being
kept locked up in a containment chamber
is normal when compared to some of the
other strange anomalies that that are
found in the SCP foundation's archives
inside the coffin with
scp-1007 is a small Metal Key and this
is quite literally the key to seeing
what makes this anomaly so special on
scp-1007's back between his shoulder
blades is a small Keyhole x-ray scans of
1007 have shown that the keyhole is just
an empty socket it's unconnected to
anything there's no internal Clockwork
mechanisms or other Machinery that
should be able to be activated by a key
when the metal key that is kept in
scp-1007's coffin classified as
scp-1007-1 is inserted into the keyhole
on 1007's back in turn something truly
incredible happens as the key is turned
scp-1007 undergoes a change unlike
anything the SCP Foundation has seen
before with each turn of the key the
subject's physical age is reversed by
one full year Foundation researchers are
able to watch 1007 age in Reverse in
real time even any Decay that had set in
on the corpse is completely reversed and
disappears as the key is wound in one
zero zero seven gets younger and younger
as the key is turned 1007 will continue
to DH physically compacting and
shrinking down until it appears to have
the form of a newborn human child it's
unknown where the physical mass of
1007's body goes to since this should
defy the laws of physics but those laws
we assume to be a Bedrock of our
universe's reality are often more of a
suggestion when it comes to anomalies
the SCP Foundation deals with Once
scp-1007 reaches the newborn baby stage
it will suddenly reactivate coming to
life immediately regardless of how long
it has been dead and lying in its coffin
once 1007 is brought back to life he
will go through the entire human life
cycle within a 75 minute period
experiencing what looks to be
approximately one year of normal human
growth and development for every minute
that passes that means that in the
course of about 16 minutes researchers
will see
scp-1007 change from a crying infant to
a fully grown teenager as you can
imagine the subject has reported feeling
excruciating pain during these first few
minutes as his bones rapidly lengthen
and expand and his muscles develop and
change shape dramatically
scp-1007 is able to watch with his young
eyes as his bones move and set
themselves into place lengthening and
widening in seconds during growth spurts
that normally take months or years after
about five minutes provided his legs
have grown to the same length at the
same time he's usually able to prop
himself up and stand at around 10
minutes the pain really starts the bones
crack and ache as they grow at their
fastest for the whole cycle hair will
also grow on his face and body and he
can't help but feel some amount of Shame
and embarrassment at what's happening to
him in front of the foundation
researchers who are taking copious notes
by 20 minutes he can hardly think due to
the pain at this point he usually lies
down and curls into a ball whispering to
himself that it will all be over soon
that the pain won't last forever after
another 10 minutes he's right the pain
is almost stopped completely by the
30-minute mark But now as wrinkles and
stretch marks start to set in a
different kind of pain reveals itself as
scp-1007 realizes that he must watch
himself die 40 minutes in and he starts
to reflect on his past the life he was
forced to lead as a kind of Sideshow
freak more on that later though the
physical Decay happens faster now warts
and moles and other marks of age
appearing on his skin after 50 minutes
he is aware that over half of his life
has passed and he is reaching the end
his hair starts to fall out as do his
teeth which he's never actually been
able to use as he's never tasted food as
the 60-minute mark comes and goes he
begins to feel grateful for the coming
end with the escape from Pain and the
rest it would bring his body has become
very wrinkled by this point and is
covered with age spots his eyes begin to
Cloud severely limiting his ability to
see and his hearing gets weaker and
weaker until he can't comprehend
anything the researchers say at 75
minutes it's all over
scp-1007's body expires and he dies once
again
he will remain as a corpse until the
metal key is inserted into his back and
the whole process starts once again just
as there appears to be no explanation
for where the mass of
scp-1007's body goes as the key is wound
during the reversal process so too is
there no explanation for where the
energy needed for his rapid growth comes
from this process should violate the
first law of thermodynamics and
Foundation researchers are very curious
about the underlying process the one
constant that remains on
scp-1007's body is a small tattoo on his
right calf where the words Mr life and
Mr death from Little misters by Dr
wondertainment appear
this matches up with entry number 11 on
document
scp-909 which lists a total of 20 little
misters
scp-1007 was recovered by task force Tau
6 during a raid on a mansion in
California along with several other
anomalous creatures and objects
the owner of the Mansion claimed that he
acquired
scp-1007 at an auction hosted by
Marshall Carter and dark Limited
Marshall Carter and dark limited is a
club based in London England that is
famed for collecting and selling what it
would describe as rare and obscure
objects unfortunately this often
includes various anomalies that should
be under the care of the SCP Foundation
and the club's mission to provide its
members with exclusive expensive and
rare experiences means that they're
often in conflict with the foundation
and they have even been responsible for
several containment breaches
Marshall Carter and dark limited
continues to be a very secretive
organization and the name of the
director and a list of its members have
so far been very difficult to obtain at
the auction they hosted where scp-1007
was offered for sale there were
apparently along with Mr life and death
at least four other misters for sale
though the identity of the other buyers
and which little misters they may have
purchased is still under investigation
the fact that
scp-1007 has the name Mr life and Mr
death seems to imply that he may have
originally been part of a set though
this counterpart little Mister has yet
to be recovered or even identified in
interviews with
scp-1007 he has given his own personal
theory that he embodies both names and
the designation is a reference to the
way he alternates between life and death
however the possibility Still Remains
though that he may have a twin of sorts
and the foundation continues to
investigate its possible identity and
location
scp-1007's brief 75-minute life followed
by a death that lasts until he is
rewound by a special key means that he
is easily contained and has been
classified as safe he is only to be
activated during routine testing and
After experiencing death he is to be
placed back into his coffin along with
the key in keeping with current
regulations for all anomalies that have
been designated as misters
scp-1007 is to be contained in Hall 8 of
site 13 for additional observation and
study
[Music]
some of the anomalies the SCP Foundation
deals with are dangerous with the most
powerful able to end all life and even
reality as we know it others pose no
threat at all and seem content to Simply
exist still others are something else
entirely
scp-49999 is a humanoid entity though
its appearance seems to fluctuate
between manifestations with the only
unchanging detail being that it always
is dressed in dark Formal Wear
originally thought by many to be an
urban legend local Tales of scp-4999 are
what initially tipped the foundation off
to its existence and further Research
indicates that there are accounts that
may be referring to the appearances of
49.99 throughout recorded history
strangest of all though is the
consistency with which it appears or
rather the consistent situations and
types of people it appears to from the
data available it seems that
scp-4999 only appears to people in a
very specific type of need as you'll see
in the case of a subject named Alex
hiriford and the Fateful Knight he
experienced the road was slippery and
Alex was driving too fast he knew this
of course but it's a different matter
altogether to know a thing and to and to
care about it rain hammered on the front
windshield the weak headlights of his
2005 Honda Civic barely punching into
the thick black knight ahead of him
winding through the Mountainside the
road was mostly empty saved for the very
occasional twin beams of light blazing
past him due to his high speed it was
hard to hear the honking of angry horns
over the heavy pounding of the rain then
it happened in a way Alex knew it was
inevitable his tread worn Wheels finally
lost contact with the ground thick layer
of rain water between them and asphalt
betraying his speeding Vehicles grip on
the road and sending it careening out of
control he had expected fear but instead
felt nothing really a slight sense of
anticipation like wincing right before a
punch lands in that childhood game of
hitting each other on the arm it wasn't
that the world had slowed down but
perhaps his brain was simply working at
a much greater velocity now recognizing
its own impending death his speed of
thought seemed magnified to the point of
slowing his perception down he heard of
soldiers in war zones experiencing the
same phenomenon as they felt sure that
in the next few seconds they'd be dead
Alex Wonder would he smash into a tree
go off a Cliff's Edge you could hardly
see the forest or the terrain Beyond in
the thick rain in the dark of the
mountain though he traveled this road a
million times before he had no idea
where he actually was tonight he
supposed it wouldn't really matter which
it was as usual his thoughts turned to
her or rather they had simply run their
course and return to the one place they
always did it wasn't like there were
many other people to think about in
Alex's mostly empty life there was and
always had been since the moment he'd
met her mostly just her but even Alex's
heightened State of Mind couldn't delay
the inevitable for long it would be a
cliff after all Alex thought curiously
catching a glimpse of town lights far
away and below the correspond 180
degrees out into empty air Then Came
Crashing Down with a horror Roar of
shattered glass and tearing metal as it
tumbled down the hillside even over the
torrential downpour the noise of Alex's
crash was significant had anyone been
around to hear it finally after over a
hundred feet down a steep incline the
car smashed into a single thick oak tree
bringing the disaster to an end as if On
Cue the rain began to let up slowly at
first then all of a sudden in that
peculiar way that Northwest torrential
downpours tend to do as if the sky had
at last finished emptying itself all at
once inside the shattered vehicle Alex
was incredibly alive at least for the
time being the airbag deployment had
spared his face the worst of it and the
sturdy aluminum frame of the vehicle had
given its all in protecting Alex's body
from the downhill crash but even
post-modern vehicle engineering had its
limits his breath came in slow ragged
gasps difficult at first but gradually
steady not an Improvement in his
condition but rather his body dedicating
the rapidly dwindling resources at its
disposal into keeping vital functions
going as long as possible opening his
eyes Alex was surprised to find himself
right side up less surprised to look
down at the shattered mess his Limbs and
lower body had become gradually Alex's
thoughts clear his sense of self
returning after the bone jarring dropped
down the Steep incline and sudden stop
at the end looking to his right he could
see the trunk of the tree that had
stopped his out-of-control tumble
despite himself Alex laugh a weak
gurgling chuckle so it was the cliff and
a tree after all he focused on breathing
letting the waves of pain wash over him
until his brain eventually canceled them
out by injecting his broken body with
adrenaline and chemicals everything was
quiet and still after the crash and the
rain but to his surprise he could hear
something it was faint at first just a
soft crunch of footsteps on grab but the
sound grew louder and louder until at
last it came to a stop outside Alex's
window with every ounce of effort Alex
turned his head towards the sound a
rescuer now impossible nobody was up on
this mountain and nobody could possibly
have reached him here so quickly even if
there had been he supposed he should
have been surprised yet almost from the
moment that his eyes fell on the tall
handsome figure with the Casual yet
fashionably cut black suit Alex accepted
him for what he was there was no shock
no confusion for the second time tonight
just a calm sense of acceptance the man
probably somewhere in his mid-30s leaned
down to peer in through the window he
said nothing as he casually observed the
extent of Alex's injuries satisfied he
laid a hand on Alex's shoulder the grip
was firm but not painfully so just
strong enough to communicate I am here
with you things will be all right after
a slight squeeze the figure reached
inside his jacket and produced a pack of
cigarettes packing the tobacco with
swift Taps against his palm before
removing two cigarettes and offering one
to Alex Alex nodded his head a very
small motion that exploded pain across
his shattered body now thank you but
that stuff will kill you Alex smiled the
man paused for a moment the ghost of a
smile showing on his face for just a
moment before disappearing returning the
offered cigarette the man took his own
and lit it giving Alex a good look at
his face in the light of his cigarette
lighter Alex had been right the man
appeared to be somewhere in his mid to
late 30s handsome but not cover model so
just pleasing to the eyes he sported
short hair carefully combed and
perfectly knee completely unaffected by
the slight drizzle that still fell the
more Alex looked at him though the less
he could remember about the man's exact
features wasn't that they changed in any
way but rather that he simply couldn't
hold on to any details for more than a
few seconds I'm dying aren't I the
figure didn't speak nor did it not or
make any form of verbal or bodily
communication he simply looked and Alex
understood Alex had never been
particularly religious or spiritual but
in that look he understood that there
was a world Beyond and
will very quickly be entering into it
was as if for the first time in his life
he was able to probe that world reality
peeling away just enough to Glimpse what
was beyond twisting paths through planes
of Shadow and light both shuffling
figures along each and at the very
center of it all a light now a feeling
love pulsing forth like the Beating
Heart of it all the saints had their
Angels the wicked their demons but
everyone else in between the two they
had him a guide someone to watch over
them on their final Journey Alex coughed
it was ending soon the man took a drag
from his cigarette and removed the
handkerchief from another hidden Pocket
carefully dabbing away the blood around
Alex's chin then returned to his silent
smoking his vision was beginning to dim
around the edges the noises of the
forest growing more and more distant
Alex knew it wouldn't be long now but he
had just one final thing to do as he
always knew they would his thoughts
returned to her here at the end once
more he turned his head towards the
passenger side sea pain exploding across
his body with the motion there just on
the far edge of the seat as his phone
having miraculously survived the crash
it was no good though even if he'd been
able to move his shattered right arm he
could never reach it with his fading
strength the smoking man took one final
pull of his cigarette putting it out on
the side of the vehicle and pocketing
the stump then he reached through the
broken driver's side window Alex
catching a slight whiff of cigarette
smoke blended with an unrecognizable but
Pleasant cologne the man reached across
Alex and grabbed the phone pulling back
and looking down at Alex's shattered
right hand after a moment he reached
down once more and put the phone in
Alex's left hand thank you the words
were barely a whisper he had to
concentrate now willing the pressing
Darkness to part just long enough for
one final task the man once more placed
his hand reassuring Lee on Alex's
shoulder and the Darkness parted
slightly just enough for what Alex
needed to do he worked the phone
awkwardly with his left hand gritting
his teeth through the pain of broken
fingers opening a new message he
scrolled down his contacts G H I J
finally K he found her name at last then
began typing out a message I still think
about you every time it rains he moved
his thumb to press send but that's when
Alex's body failed him at last the phone
tumbling out of his cross but the man
was there to catch it moving blindly
fast he snatched the falling phone up
and held it carefully to Alex's eyes
before pressing send he held the phone
there for Alex to see through his fading
Vision until at last message sent
confirmed successful delivery the rain
began once more temperamental as it
always is in the Pacific Northwest fat
heavy raindrops fell on the scene of a
terrible
the victims seemingly having died on
impact on his lap though lay his phone
and somewhere far away and Far Below
this dark Mountainside a message
notification chirped on a distant phone
scp-4999 manifests to only one person at
a time and only when they are alone all
subjects to date have been in the final
stages of a terminal illness suffering
from a life-threatening injury or
otherwise on their deathbed it also
appears that all subjects have
personalities and lives that could be
described as non-descript insignificant
or otherwise unremarkable no testing of
scp-49999 has been authorized by the
foundation due to both the difficulty in
predicting where it will appear as well
as the fact that observation seems to
prevent the anomaly from appearing there
are also ethical concerns since many in
the foundation feel that
scp-49999 is providing an important
service to humanity even if it is only
for those on the margins of society and
it is debated whether this should be one
anomalous creature that is allowed to
continue its existence and its work
without interference it goes without
saying that the SCP Foundation archives
are filled with some terrifying monsters
even the deadliest creatures can in
theory be defeated or at least soundly
avoided after all they're just flesh and
blood or in some cases metal or concrete
but what if reality as you know it one
day just broke or worse you were
transported to a reality so frightening
and alien to our own that death seemed
like the only Escape but you couldn't
even give yourself that this brings us
to today's topic the terrifying
alternate reality of
scp-3001 the foundation is no stranger
to freaky alternate Dimensions but what
was experienced by joint lead researcher
Dr Robert Scranton at site 120 is a
truly unique nightmare co-managed by his
wife Dr Anna Lang site 120 is a facility
largely designated for Research into
scps with dangerous reality warping
capabilities in order to mitigate future
containment breaches reality warpers are
among some of the more perplexing and
dangerous scps from the pocket Dimension
creating scp-106 to the SCP creating Dr
wondertainment and everything in between
Scranton and Lang's goal to further
study such entities was an admirable one
if a little over ambitious and on
January 2nd 2000 during the testing of a
new technology created by the
foundation's leading power couple
disaster finally struck
Scranton and Lang had already been the
brains behind one of the foundation's
most valuable tools in the fight against
reality bending scps the Scranton
reality anchors their follow-up the Lang
Scranton stabilizer or LSS likely would
have been an even more advanced variant
of their earlier invention and should
have been a huge success for the team
but things didn't turn out that way Dr
Scranton and several other researchers
were gathered in reality lab a
performing routine tests on the LSS
prototypes while other technicians ran
Diagnostics tests Scranton stood at the
control panel the blinking red light
above the console confirming that
everything was going according to plan
but as anyone who's Fallen victim to one
of the foundation's many anomalies will
tell you just because you've done
everything correctly doesn't mean you're
safe Scranton began operating the
machine not knowing that something was
rumbling up towards him from below
without warning a sudden unexpected
burst of seismic activity rocked the
entire base researchers grabbed on to
whatever was closest as the world shook
around them in this Panic Dr Scranton
clung to the LSS control panel as the
seismic blast fried the circuits and
kicked it into overdrive
there was a blast of magnificent
blinding light and when the rumbling
stopped Not only was the doctor gone he
had been erased from reality as we know
it the earthquake had caused a deadly
malfunction in the machine meant to
stabilize reality and instead tore a
rift in it dragging the unfortunate
doctor and the control panel into
Oblivion
his wife Dr Lang and the many
researchers who idolized him were
devastated by his unexpected demise at
the hand of what should have been his
crowning achievement the one silver
lining was that this reality ripping
event had almost definitely eliminated
the doctor quickly and painlessly as far
as the foundation and his loved ones
were concerned Scranton's death had been
immediate and complete a luxury afforded
to few Foundation employees who die
anomalous deaths but sadly that isn't
how Dr Scranton's story or the story of
scp-3001 ends no this is where it all
begins how do we know all this in the
hellish new place where Scranton had
been transported the control panel from
the LSS that he'd been clinging to for
dear life had been transported with him
and continued to record audio data from
this anomalous location not that Dr
Scranton realized it not at first anyway
as far as he knew he'd suddenly been
transported into a pitch black location
no sights no sounds no sound
true nothingness at first the doctor was
confused one second he was testing out
his new technology and the next he was
quite literally nowhere in spite of his
current situation the doctor was still
an intelligent and rational man he took
a moment to compose himself hoping that
in time his eyes would adjust to the new
Darkness around him but that moment
never came
the darkness remained perfectly absolute
much like the darkness in another
reality-defying SCP the deadly endless
staircase known as scp-087 the dark
seemed thick almost like you could touch
it the doctor not wanting to give
himself to Despair and die in this
impossible place and with no other
options seemingly available began
walking either he'd find his way out or
the foundation would find him no need to
panic
it may have altered the doctor's
temperament if he knew that the
foundation already assumed he was dead
and that no search party was going to
come looking for him
still logic dictates that if a person
walks for long enough they're bound to
find something the problem Scranton was
about to face was that
scp-3001 doesn't run by any kind of
conventional logic he walked and walked
and walked but he didn't seem to get any
nearer to or farther from anything but
how could he even know after all in
total darkness there aren't any
landmarks to assist in navigation the
doctor walked and paced and screamed for
days on end but he made no progress he
was alone in an empty world he had no
choice though so he kept walking and
walking and walking for 11 days during
that time he felt his hunger and thirst
grow he was in terrible pain from a mix
of starvation and dehydration but the
release of death didn't seem to come for
him he was going to have to learn the
rules of this new place the hard way and
it grimly dawned on Dr Scranton dying in
this place might not even be the worst
possible outcome he paced and repeated
facts to himself hoping to ground
himself in the moment and avoid the
Panic that could so easily set in name
Robert Scranton age 39 birthday
September 19 1961 favorite color blue
favorite song Living on a Prayer wife
Anna little by little the words seem to
turn to nonsense in his mouth as the
terror grew just as he felt like he was
about to lose his mind he noticed
something a small Oasis in the endless
darkness of scp-3001 the glowing red
light on the LSS control panel where had
it come from and how was it still
recording the doctor had no idea but he
was grateful for any kind of familiarity
in this strange Darkness around him
perhaps the LSS could be the key to
saving him or at least figuring out what
on Earth was going on here whatever the
case there was no denying that having
the panel here was better than nothing
at least when it was found if it was
ever found then people would know what
had happened to him as the days passed
and he continued to mysteriously survive
Dr Scranton deduced that one didn't need
food or water to survive continually in
scp-3001 the location had an anomalous
effect on its inhabitants
as the days passed and turned to weeks
of wandering in the darkness Dr Scranton
further deduced that he was no longer in
his home Dimension this was an entirely
separate pocket Dimension much like the
one possessed by scp-106 but featureless
a perfect self-contained void
now dimly illuminated by the red light
of the panel Dr Scranton explored
further into the void around him he
traveled for months on end the pain of
his deficiencies growing by the day but
found he was getting nowhere
All Things Considered he wasn't even
sure he was moving or whether reality
and darkness were swirling around him
like a thick liquid rather than walking
on a single flat surface he was moving
in all directions across a
three-dimensional plane the space-time
Continuum appeared to be entirely broken
here where movement is more defined by
the conscious intention to move than any
real geographical repositioning Dr
Scranton knew that this place broke
every single one of cajel's laws of
reality parameters and from his years
working with a plethora of reality
warpers in sight 120 he had a theory for
why this pocket Dimension was so strange
it had an extraordinarily weak Hume
field before we get back to Dr
Scranton's semi-living nightmare we need
a quick primer on Hume Theory and why
having a weak Hume field is such a
problem a Hume is a unit of measurement
for the strength and amount of reality
in a given location or being in an area
with an incredibly low Hume field
relative to our world such as scp-3001
Universe breaches and anomalous
incidents rise significantly at the time
is being trapped there
scp-3001 had the lowest number of Humes
in any recorded environment making it a
phenomenally anomalous Zone it was for
this reason that starvation and
dehydration never took hold of him
despite causing him great pain and the
worst by far was Yet to Come Dr Scranton
wasn't trapped in this dimension for
weeks or even months he was trapped in
the darkness for years and it took a
nightmarish toll on his body and mind
the small flashing red light on his LSS
control panel became his only friend and
as the years Drew on he would hold
entire conversations with his only
source of Illumination he knew that his
days were numbered if he didn't escape
the dimension within around three years
the Hume field would defuse further and
he would be left in a truly horrific
state but based on how little Headway
he'd made in the time he'd been there he
didn't feel optimistic he kept speaking
into the recorder if only to break the
silence and prevent him from going
completely insane but even that would
only hold it off for so long alone and
talking to himself endlessly in the
darkness Dr Scranton could feel his mind
slipping as the confines of the pocket
Dimension constricted and his body began
to change the low Hume field slowly
diffused his physical matter destroying
the physical Integrity of his body but
never being merciful enough to actually
let him die in his haunting audio logs
the doctor described his hands as
diffusing and thinning out like spider
webs over time there was less and less
of him and what was left wasn't entirely
human as Scranton's Hume level lowered
to equalize with that of scp-3001 the
lines between his body and the LSS
control console began to blur in a
Twisted marriage of warped flesh and
machine the Lang Scranton stabilizer was
anything but stable before his mind and
body became something else entirely the
doctor still had the presence of mind to
finally realize how he'd come to be in
this terrible place
the LSS had opened a wormhole known as a
Class C broken entry into a paradoxical
pocket Dimension between layers of
reality and taken him through it he'd
slipped through a crack in reality into
absolute darkness and now he was stuck
with a fate far worse than death how do
we know any of this much like the event
in the first place it's a total accident
testing Superior reality bending
technology almost six years after The
Disappearance caused the sudden Return
of the missing LSS to site-120's reality
labs
the only trace of Dr Scranton that it
brought back with it was the blood and
viscera that coded the console much to
the abject horror of his still-grieving
wife Dr Anna Lang to this day Dr
Scranton formerly one of the
foundation's brightest Minds remains
trapped in the nightmare of
scp-3001. his current condition whether
the doctor is still alive after 20 years
of being warped by the low Hume field of
3001's dark and confines is still
unknown but for the doctor's own sake we
hope he's been dead for quite some time
because few things on Earth are as
horrifying as the alternative in the
office of SCP Foundation researcher
yoshihiro takanaka there sits a small
containment capsule filled with Ash all
that's left of a neutralized
scp-1762 these ashes don't pose any harm
they won't bite burn or assume control
of your mind but few can hear the sad
story of scp-1762
and not be haunted by its tragic and
mysterious tale it weighs heavily on the
hearts and minds of all who came into
contact with it during its ultimately
brief time in the foundation's hands and
to think it all started with a simple
little box with an even simpler message
here be dragons the box to look at it
was really nothing special a simple
cardboard box 32 centimeters by 20
centimeters by 26 centimeters spray
painted silver inside and out
short message scrawled across the lid in
Black permanent marker it appeared on
the doorstep of foundation agent Scott
Thomas who after determining it wasn't a
bomb Anthrax or a deadlier kind of
anomaly turned it into his superiors
that's when it became yoshihiro
takanaka's Little Pet Project SAFE class
scps are rare treats for any overworked
Foundation scientists the Box itself
known as
scp-1762-1 is certainly important but
what's really interesting is what
resides within the Box
if you'd open the box yourself you'd
find that it's empty however when the
Box chooses to open itself it's an
entirely different story The Box would
sometimes open and emit great plumes of
thick black smoke that would quickly
dissipate around 20 seconds after this
an
scp-1762-2 would emerge from the
darkness of the box
[Music]
1762-2 is the collective names given to
all the beings that exit 1762-1 which
are as you may have guessed dragons
eastern western big small and presenting
in a rainbow of colors these dragons
appear to be living origami sculptures
made from Kami paper and have been known
to fly together in large groups and
interact playfully with nearby humans
these little paper dragons would then
swoop around their containment chamber
delighting all who were fortunate enough
to see them for up to three hours at
which point smoke would begin pulling
out of the box once more and the dragons
would return home they'd fly through the
smoke disappearing past the rim of the
box and then the lid would close once
more the dates on which the box would
open were seemingly random and
indeterminable and didn't appear to work
by any kind of external logic and what's
more the box would sometimes act as a
hub of communication between this world
and another known simply as fantasy
messages written or carved into various
materials would appear on the lid of the
Box mostly after instances of 1762-2
emerging this communication though would
always be one way attempts to pass
messages back through the box never
resulted in success the foundation staff
could only be observers of the Strange
World of fantasy never active
participants so why is this particular
SCP considered so tragic we're going to
answer that question right now but just
know that what is learned cannot be
unlearned as much as you might wish you
could forget if you're ready then it's
time to learn about a period of time
that lasted just under a year during
which a strange and sad series of events
took place now known as the Jabberwocky
event an event that took hereby dragons
from safe to neutralize you've seen that
scp-1762 would communicate with
Foundation staff via written messages
after each instance of the box opening
the very first message the Box gave up
after arriving at the sight red you have
found us thank you it has been so long
since we last saw each other friends the
piece has been upheld the Giants and
Behemoth have kept their word and have
not caused any trouble since you last
came and gave the order we missed your
company
how has your family been do you know how
to work your room you're welcome to
visit anytime later it gave another
message expressing confusion and concern
on behalf of fantasy's inhabitants
it's strange to see how much your world
has changed it is even stranger to see
how we now appear in this place in
fantasy we are much bigger or maybe
you've grown taller fantasy is still the
same we hope you can visit us like you
used to though our room is as Grand as
ever it appears yours has shrunken we do
not understand the rooms were supposed
to be maintained as was our agreement
please restore the belief things got
worse during the next stage of the event
the Box opened and only 20 Paper Dragons
exited this time though they did not fly
and instead walked slowly across the
ground this was the message that
accompanied this sorry parade of dragons
friends we apologize for a few numbers
we have had to remain in fantasy for
quite some time the others are growing
patient we are trying to keep the peace
but please for all of our happiness
repair the room quickly we know you are
trying your family is the most
imaginative of us all naturally
Foundation scientists were concerned
they weren't sure what exactly the
messages were referring to or how they
could possibly help the inhabitants of
fantasy of course things only got worse
only 10 dragons appeared the next time
along with a few balls of crumpled up
construction paper That Shook violently
before stopping all movement entirely
this message accompanied it the Giants
were foolish your room was not ready to
accept them yet
we're sorry friends we hope that we can
still see you but time is growing short
for our happiness and sadly this message
spoke the truth
as the next time the Box opened only
five dragons exited
they were carrying the following message
and flew straight back into the box
after depositing It On The Ground
dungeons are rising fantasy is becoming
darker we the serpents and the hybrids
are furiously trying to hold them back
but the Giants and elves wish to strike
and make an entrance they say that your
family has grown stupid and ignorant
we hope this is untrue it would send us
all greatly to know that you have
forgotten it seemed clear that fantasy
was speeding towards some kind of
terrible conflict and it was perhaps too
late to do anything about it the next
attempt at communication came from a
single dragon with a crumpled wounded
body
collapsed to the ground and appeared to
die its body unfolding into a small
piece of paper that brore a single
heartbreaking message
[ __ ] goodbye friends but two hours
after this message was delivered
something happened the lid opened again
only this time the Box let out a huge
jet of white hot flame reaching
temperatures of 1700 degrees Celsius the
terrified and Confused researchers heard
roaring and the sounds of an intense
battle from within the darkness of the
Box many of the observing staff found
themselves overcome with emotion afraid
that they were perhaps witnessing the
death of fantasy play out in front of
them an even hardened Foundation
researchers and guards were moved by the
event
at 8pm that night the Box ejected a huge
quality of paper the majority of it was
either torn burnt shredded or crumpled
into balls and all instances of 1762-2
were announced deceased upon official
examination it seemed that fantasy's
Bloody War truly was taking its toll and
even the forces of the foundation one of
the most powerful and resourceful groups
the world has ever known
powerless to do anything to help all
they could do was sit wait and see what
the result would be of this
paper-crafted war the Box continued to
open and close sporadically over the
next six weeks as the war raged on it
would often emit more spouts of deadly
fire and vomit out more piles of ruined
paper the researchers noticed that each
time it released less and less paper
even more disturbing matter resembling
muscle and tissue was ejected from the
box with increased frequency it was
clear that whatever was left of fantasy
was in great Peril and the researchers
were desperate to know what was going on
but the box would remain closed and
inactive for the next seven months
when the Box did finally become active
once more it wasn't in a way that the
researchers were familiar with the Box
opened but not a single Dragon accident
not even a crumbled piece of paper came
out instead researchers found what
appeared to be an ancient and desiccated
Scroll of parchment the words written on
it were smudged and some were stained
with blood it made clear that things had
fallen further into darkness than they
had ever before the message read are you
still out there friends we miss you
dearly fantasy is no longer safe
our Haven your beautiful creation
is gone the Giants are dead the centaurs
are dead the birds have fled we are
going to bury your room we cannot risk
hurting you this is our goodbye maybe
one day your family can build another
room
this may be a hollow hope but we will
cherish this thought an hour later the
Box began to convulse violently and let
out more plumes of thick black smoke for
a moment the researchers entertain the
hope that it might be the return of the
dragons
the no such luck the Vox began to Sag
tear and collapse as though it was on
fire on the inside parts of the Box
began to char and small holes were
burned through the silver paint perhaps
the status of all the words here be
Dragons Were burned from the box
not long after one more message appeared
Inside the Box it was a Papyrus scroll
depicting a hand-drawn image of a
beautiful mountainous landscape with
huge trees and waterfalls in the
distance a dragon appears to fly away
for the last time a message written on
the back read as follows
Master says that we won't see you again
we are sad so are the remaining others
we once filled each other's heads with
dreams and goals it is so sad that we
cannot share them any longer Master says
we have to go he says that he will make
us a new fantasy he says you cannot be a
part of it we are sad we love you we
will not forget you we are scared will
you forget us
when this document was removed streams
of salt water began to leak from the box
healing its burn scars a few minutes
later the box was returned to its
original state save for one big
difference the tech scrawled on the lid
no longer red here be dragons now it
said here were dragons the Jabberwocky
event was over the box now neutralized
with sit in yoshihiro takanaka's office
for commemorative purposes never to
release another message
or so we thought in 2015
scp-1762 spoke to us one more time the
Box Shook and began emitting great
plumes of purple smoke before it fell to
the ground there it ejected two objects
a purple Crystal later identified as an
amethyst and a large leather-bound book
The Box continued emitting smoke for
another 40 minutes before finally
disintegrating upon further inspection
there was a single message carved into
the amethyst
one last time then what about the book
consider the greatest fear of the
inhabitants of fantasy that they would
one day be forgotten forgotten and left
behind by us the book was sent to help
prevent that it's an extensive catalog
of the creatures of fantasy their
strange and wonderful ways and their
strange and wonderful world even if
they're gone they won't be forgotten and
perhaps one day we'll tell you those
stories too
but that's a tale for another day Joseph
and Frank were two lifelong squatchers
no that isn't an insult that's a
self-given title for bigfoot enthusiasts
who are willing to head out into the
woods and search for the legendary
Sasquatch first hand while most Watchers
will go their whole lives without ever
encountering one Joseph and Frank were
about to get lucky they just didn't know
what kind of luck during a journey
through the forests of the Pacific
Northwest Frank spotted something moving
in the distance a huge ape-like creature
with grayish fur and human-like
movements Frank thought he was finally
laying eyes on the mighty Bigfoot after
Decades of searching what he didn't know
was that he just made a deadly mistake
he had looked directly at scp-1000 and
there would be terrible consequences
Frank was excited he just achieved the
life goal of any squatcher he tapped
Joseph on the shoulder and directed him
to look in the direction of the creature
Joseph followed Frank's Direction and
stared into the distance when his eyes
finally came into focus on the ape Beast
he froze his brain just short-circuited
one second he was about to encounter the
Holy Grail of his Hobby and the next he
was literally brain dead Joseph
collapsed in the distance the ape-like
creature disappeared back into the woods
not that Frank even noticed he was too
busy trying to wake Joseph but it was no
use Joseph was gone and Frank had no
idea why the headlines read Bigfoot
killed my friend most people either
ignored it or laughed it off just a
couple of cranks goofing off in a forest
and one of them had dropped dead who
cares well one organization cared the
SCP Foundation mobile task force Zeta
1000 the foundation's specialized
scp-1000 detail were alerted to the
reports they sprang into action tracking
down and detaining Frank for questioning
they process a million Looney Bigfoot
lovers every year and usually find
nothing but the death of Frank's friend
made it all too clear they hadn't
encountered a Bigfoot but a real genuine
example of scp-1000
scp-1000 rarely ranks among the scariest
or most dangerous scps but
underestimating the creature is a
terrible mistake because just looking at
it gives you a two percent chance of
dropping dead on the spot Frank despite
losing his friend was one of the lucky
ones the foundation debriefed him before
administering amnestics and making sure
that he'd never Venture back into those
mysterious forests in the Pacific
Northwest region director Jones the site
director charged with the management of
scp-1000 populations was given the
information on this latest case of an
scp-1000 related fatality it was a story
he heard many times before for director
Jones they all seem to bleed into one
another so what exactly is scp-1000 and
how did it leave poor Joseph dead in the
woods scp-1000 is a whole species of
large hominid ape-like creatures they're
largely nocturnal but sightings of the
creature during the day aren't unheard
of they're omnivorous mostly seeming to
consume plants and insects and their fur
is usually gray brown brown black red or
occasionally White
the creatures have large eyes capable of
impressive Vision nestled underneath a
pronounced neanderthal-like brow another
defining feature is the ridge of bone on
the forehead much like that of a gorilla
that is present in both sexes according
to Foundation studies the creatures
exhibit a level of Intelligence on par
with that of the common chimpanzee but
nowhere near that of us humans what they
lack in intelligence though they make up
for in size the adults can be as large
as 10 feet tall and weigh up to 600
pounds despite their great size and
impressive strength the creatures are
neither aggressive nor territorial in
fact they seem to instinctively avoid
humans mostly residing deep in the force
of the American Pacific Northwest and in
the Himalayan Alps there have been
sightings of scp-1000 on every continent
though the foundation has taken pains to
exterminate all scp-1000 populations
situated near human population centers
to prevent a potential disaster
considering the two percent chance of
instantaneous death upon visual contact
that brings us to to our second question
what is it that makes these seemingly
harmless creatures so dangerous sadly
for both these unfortunate creatures and
US humans the danger is beyond the
control of scp-1000
according to Foundation research
scp-1000 likely evolved alongside us
Homo sapiens until a tragedy occurred
between 10 and 15 000 years ago a
mysterious Extinction event eliminated
the vast majority of their species
leaving only one to five percent alive
in the aftermath what happened it's
believed that around this time scp-1000
contracted what the foundation refers to
as an anomalous pseudo-disease meet
scp-1000 F1 a disease that is passed
along at the genetic level and is so
durable that it persists in the species
to this day the tiny fraction of the
population that are immune to its
effects managed to survive but the
majority who aren't immune die shortly
after birth this is why the overall
population remains relatively low to
this day it's a disease that only
appears to affect hominids including
humans chimpanzees bonobos and
non-immune instances of scp-1000 any
hominid that lays eyes on a carrier of
the disease has a two percent chance of
experiencing immediate brain death while
a two percent chance of instant death
may not seem all that threatening at
least when compared to some other
nightmare-inducing scps the truly scary
part is that the percentage is
cumulative in other words the longer one
observes a carrier of scp-1000f1 the
higher that percentage Rises the greater
your chance of experiencing an Abrupt
death according to Foundation studies
the percentage Rises by around one
percent every 20 minutes and the
percentage also varies between specimens
with some exhibiting a terrifyingly high
death chance of 90 upon viewing this
death chance continues to occur in dead
specimens if they carry the anomalous
pseudovirus while alive though
thankfully the risk doesn't appear to
apply to small fur or tissue samples the
foundation's true concern actually goes
far beyond scp-1000 themselves because
of the species close relation to Homo
sapiens there's a worry that
scp-1000f1 could transmit to humans
causing our own species to meet a
similar or faith if humans did indeed
become carriers of
scp-1000f1 it's extremely likely that
Humanity would undergo an unprecedented
Extinction event with billions across
the globe dropping dead as brain death
sets in on mass while full extermination
of the entire species has been deemed
unlikely this existential threat they
pose to humanity more than justifies the
occasional culling of scp-1000
populations
that was a lot to take in right first
the creature we thought was Bigfoot was
actually a new species of SCP out in the
wild and second these creatures could
end human life as we know it if they
made it into a population Center but
what you're about to hear next a dark
secret only available to people with
level 3 SCP Foundation clearance is the
most shocking scp-1000 fact of all are
you ready the true secret of scp-1000 is
that what you've just heard is a lie
there is no anomalous pseudo disease and
scp-1000 poses no pathogenic threat to
humanity whatsoever who would spread
such a thing the SCP Foundation of
course strictly speaking the foundation
has disseminated two direct lies about
the nature of scp-1000 the first is that
of the disease which does not exist nor
has it ever existed the second lie is
about the creature's intelligence level
they're far smarter than the average
Chimp in fact they're every bit as
intelligent as human beings these were
all lies formulated by director Jones
and the foundation as was the very
existence of the Bigfoot myth the
foundation has been spreading
information that makes the very concept
of the Sasquatch out to be a joke for
decades all to discredit and further
push the very concept of scp-1000 into
the Shadows
but why the foundation is no stranger to
coming up with cover stories but why
would they put intentional lies into
their own files to anyone below a level
3 clearance well that all comes down to
the horrifying truth behind the origins
of today's
scp-1000 population the creatures were
first brought to the attention of the
foundation by Outcast members of the
Serpent's hand an organization dedicated
to Defying the foundation's activities
these members known as The Children Of
The Sun told them the secret history of
scp-1000 while at First Foundation
Personnel like director Jones didn't
want to believe what they were hearing
they soon came to terms with the
horrifying truth humans and scp-1000 did
evolve alongside each other with humans
occupying the day and scp-1000 the night
however while humans were still basic
hunter-gatherers scp-1000 were
undergoing vast intellectual and
societal development they were able to
create tools weapons agriculture stable
settlements domesticated animals and
event eventually even fully developed
cities it was like nothing the world had
ever seen and wouldn't see for thousands
of years to come their numbers swelled
into the tens of billions as they
created culture and Technology hitherto
unimagined including weapons of
devastating power meanwhile Humanity was
pushed to the brink of Destruction by
their competitors rapid and seemingly
Unstoppable growth it looked as though
the human species had lost the
evolutionary arms race and would have to
bow out but according to the Children Of
The Sun a trickster Forest God smiled
upon humanity and gave them the power to
use scp-1000's weapons and Technology
against them seventy percent of
scp-1000's population were wiped out in
a single horrific day known to the
Children Of The Sun as the day of the
flowers as every flower supposedly
bloomed that day during the massacre
Humanity destroyed the entire
civilization and with the same
technology they stole from these
unfortunate creatures the vengeful
humans drove the Apes mad their higher
consciousnesses were blocked out
reducing them back into the states of
mere animals once the massacre was done
and everything that was built had been
destroyed we the human race used the
scp-1000 weapons to wipe any memory of
the atrocity from our own minds the
advanced civilization of scp-1000 had
been wiped from history humans returned
to their plotting path of evolution none
the wiser for thousands of years all the
way up until today this time remained a
mystery to us so again why did the
foundation lie to us what did they have
to gain by convincing us all that it was
dangerous to even look at these
creatures while as the frequency of
sightings and the attempts of
communication increased people like
director Jones became aware of a
frightening possibility what if the
pendulum was swinging back what if the
Apes were regaining their lost in
intelligence and worse still harbored
feelings of Revenge for what we did to
their species thousands of years ago
the mere possibility that they could do
to us what we once did to them is a
chance that the foundation simply cannot
take and thus limiting contact between
humans and scp-1000 at all costs is an
absolute must however in spite of the
foundation's fears one intercepted
message from the Apes suggests that
their paranoia may be misplaced this
message translated from an attempt at
communicating with Foundation Personnel
reads simply as follows we forgive you
given choice for now not forever let us
back in it's enough to make you wonder
what species the foundation should
really be keeping tabs on here after all
when it comes to netting out violence
and death Humanity has a track record to
rival the worst creatures in the
foundation containment cells and few
examples illustrate that better than the
tragic case of
scp-1000 there's no doubt that the SCP
Foundation has come across some
dangerous anomalies over the years if
you had to guess what would you say is
the most dangerous SCP they have in
containment a lot of people might
immediately think of
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile and
perhaps they might be right after all
we're talking about a gigantic lizard
that can regenerate almost all forms of
damage and harbors a burning hatred for
any and all other forms of life then
there's the various Eldritch entities
the foundation has come into contact
with beings that could easily rewrite
all of reality out of pure anger or just
to torment us for their own Amusement
but the most dangerous SCP might well be
something completely unassuming instead
of a zombie producing plague doctor or
an actual plague of flesh-eating zombies
imagine if there was just a man one
seemingly ordinary human man nothing
about him that looks unusual no mimetic
or anomalous superpower and yet one look
at him tells you that he's the most
dangerous man you've ever seen someone
who should be locked up forever for all
the horrible things he's done welcome to
the story of Frasier melbrook the most
dangerous person also known as
scp-3017 to anyone that knew him Frasier
was just an ordinary man although at 25
years of age he had not exactly lived a
Charmed Life people would look at him
and could almost tell there was
something unsavory about Frasier's
character it was as if one glance could
somehow tell you that he was trouble it
was this unshakable feeling that he gave
people that led to Frazier melbrook
being arrested and arrested and arrested
some more over the course of his adult
life he was placed under arrest a total
of 23 times Frazier was suspected of
having committed a number of different
crimes ranging from robbery and assault
all the way up to accusations of murder
interestingly he was never formally
indicted for any of judge crimes meaning
he was only ever arrested and held as a
suspect but never once was he confirmed
to have been guilty there was never any
evidence nothing to prove Beyond
reasonable doubt that Frasier was in
fact a criminal instead every arrest
boiled down to the way he made people in
his presence feel unfortunately even
though he was never proven to be guilty
or even capable of committing the crimes
he was accused of Frazier Mel Brooks
multiple arrests garnered him a notable
criminal record and soon drew the
attention of the SCP Foundation when he
was transferred into Foundation
containment and designated as scp-3017
it was believed that Frasier had some
form of connection to a number of groups
of Interest these are various
organizations that the foundation
monitors viewing them as causes for
concern and sometimes outright threats
this list includes the Church of the
broken God a cult of religious zealots
that worship an entity that that
combines a number of scps as well as the
global occult Coalition a gunhow
organization policing the Paranormal
that shares an uneasy history with the
foundation however no member of staff
could explain exactly why they thought
Frasier melbrook had any connection to
these groups there was no evidence that
he was but still they had a hunch and so
testing began hours upon hours of
rigorous interviews and experimentation
trying to understand what it was that
made people want to keep this seemingly
ordinary man locked up after extensive
research was conducted by Foundation
Personnel they were able to determine
why
scp-3017 had been arrested so many times
before and what had drawn the foundation
to him in the first place Frasier
melbrook was suffering from a Cognito
Hazard this was a condition that did not
so much have a direct adverse effect on
him but rather influenced those around
him anyone that stood close enough to
scp-3017 or made an attempt to engage
him directly in conversation even those
that just looked at him all reacted the
same way Frazier gave people the
overwhelming belief that he needed to be
placed in custody even if he'd not sat
or done anything to give them a reason
to anyone that looked at spoke to or
even stood near him became spontaneously
aware that scp-3017 was some sort of
dangerous criminal the Cognito Hazard
didn't give people knowledge of his
exact crimes it more just made them
believe that Frasier had a violent
disposition and that he needed to be
locked away any person staying within
the vicinity of scp-3017 for an hour or
longer would experience further effects
of Frasier's Cognito Hazard Beyond just
knowing there is something untowards
about him those who spent extended time
around scp-3017 would actively try to
restrain him and then after an hour they
would exhibit violent Behavior towards
him they would start obsessively trying
to ensure that he was incarcerated
almost like the thought of him being
free was so horrifying that they
couldn't help but try to arrest him
themselves luckily these effects of
longer exposure to Frasier were not
permanent and often the subject's
Tendencies to try to restrain him could
be cured through amnestics the effects
of Frasier Mel Brooks Cognito hazardous
conditions seemed to change relative to
the amount of time he remained
incarcerated after continuous exposure
to scp-37 team the effects of his
Cognito Hazard would appear to fade
meaning that those who had previously
been compelled to incarcerate him would
later become indifferent or even release
him freely this caused a problem for the
foundation and raised a very important
question how do you contain someone that
you later feel the urge to set free the
answer was designated as
scp-3017-1 a list of individuals with a
connection to Fraser melbrook all all of
whom had seemingly become immune to the
outward effects of his condition not one
of these people could be convinced that
Frasier was a violent criminal that
everyone else saw among the list of
names were Fraser's parents Vivian and
Beck along with his siblings grandmother
former classmates and romantic partners
and his fiancee Nadia but you might be
wondering how did the SCP Foundation use
nothing more than a list of names to
keep scp-3017 caged by threatening them
of course researchers who interviewed
Frasier found that they could greatly
decrease the secondary effect of his
condition making them far less compelled
to free him all it took was them to tell
Frasier that his family friends fiance
would be captured tortured or even
killed if he tried to escape containment
according to the foundation this didn't
stop Frasier from trying to escape
though his file states that he actively
made several attempts to breach
Containment all of which failed the
truth however was that just about any
move that Frasier made was
misinterpreted as an attempted Escape in
one instance while trying just to use
the bathroom
scp-3017 was tackled and restrained by a
foundation guard you see Frazier knew
that just like with his previous arrests
he'd done nothing to deserve being
locked up and interrogated by the SCP
Foundation but to the eyes of everyone
around him he was a dangerous threat the
researchers and guards treated him like
a monster because as far as they saw he
was one by manipulating information
about the current health of his loved
ones like telling him his grandmother
had developed lung cancer the foundation
kept Frazier under lock and key hearing
threats against his friends and family
or bad news about their current state
quickly put an end to
scp-3017's attempts at Escape even
though he was frustrated with the
foundation he was without hope and had
little choice in the matter so Frazier
did his best to comply with his captors
and offer the SCP Foundation information
on groups of Interest he thought they
wanted to hear even though he had no
affiliation with any of them by bringing
Frazier's fiancee Nadia into containment
and showing him a live video feed of the
her foundation researcher Dr Kiran hoped
to coax a wealth of valuable information
out of scp-3017 afraid for his partner's
life Frazier did his best to answer
their questions and Nadia was later
freed and given amnestics to forget the
incident but Foundation researcher
Ryland was quick to realize that the
information Dr Kiran had extracted from
scp-317 didn't seem to add up Frasier of
course had no knowledge about any groups
of interest and had to improvise to
protect his fiancee researcher Ryland
picked up on this remarking that
scp-3017's information could not be
considered reliable but she was unsure
if Frasier was hiding something or
simply didn't know anything during
another interrogation Frazier's brother
a former classmate and two former
romantic Partners were brought into the
foundation and sedated in an adjacent
room Frazier was threatened by Dr Kiran
with a handgun and made sure to answer
for their questions every time he did it
the doctor threatened to shoot one of
Fraser's loved ones it was after this
incident that researcher Ryland once
again reassessed the information given
by scp-3017 finally she came to realize
that there was no evidence of Frasier's
criminal history nor was there anything
tying him to groups of Interest
everything that the foundation had
thought of him was just a result of
scp-317's condition and he genuinely had
none of the information they'd been
seeking he was only answering their
questions to protect the lives of people
he cared for realizing the huge ethical
mistake the foundation had made
essentially psychologically torturing
Frazier for information he simply didn't
have researcher Ryland begged her
superiors that scp-3017 be released the
request was denied and instead Rylan was
contained believed to be a new instance
of
scp-3017-1 with the help of security
officer Rudolph Cartier who had guarded
Frazier Rylan escaped her own cell pair
of them triggered a containment alarm in
the ensuing confusion Rylan and cardiad
freed scp-3017 from his incarceration
and she and Frasier escaped the
containment facility where officer
cardiad was captured and contained by
security Personnel Rylan brought Frasier
to what she thought was safety of his
family's home but neither of them
expected to see what awaited them the
house had been burned to the ground with
almost all Frazier's family inside his
parents siblings grandmother fiance and
even neighbor had all perished in a fire
that had engulfed the one place in the
world that Frasier hadn't been held
against his will it is still unclear if
the fire was intentionally started by a
member of the SCP Foundation to drive as
cp3017 back into containment or had
merely been an unfortunate accident
but notably Dr Kiran had been strangely
absent during scp-3017 and ryland's
escape from the foundation overwhelmed
with grief and despair Frasier was last
seen on a bridge not far from his
childhood home and researcher Ryland was
recaptured without resistance by
Foundation Personnel near the same spot
with scp-3017 gone along with his
Cognito hazardous effects both her and
security officer cardiad were reinstated
back to full employment with the
foundation the foundation then
reclassified as cp3017 is neutralized
quietly avoiding the truth of their
mistake all records of his supposed
criminal activity and links to anomalous
groups were stricken from the record as
unsubstantiated he had been innocent all
along just a man who had never done
anything he was accused of and didn't
deserve to be locked away the SCP
Foundation had tortured Frasier asking
him questions he didn't have the answers
to using the love he and for those
closest to him as a way to try and goat
him into giving the foundation what they
wanted and in the end may have been
responsible for multiple innocent people
being murdered perhaps it was easier for
them to stamp neutralize on his file
than to actually face up what they'd
done to him the foundation has spent at
least a century containing anomalies and
monsters but the hardest monsters to
contain are often the ones that emerge
within us and nothing better illustrates
that than the foundation's Monstrous
treatment of
scp-317 on the 13th of October 1989 the
town of Danner Wisconsin was shaken by a
seismic event unlike anything they'd
ever experienced this might have been
written off as an earthquake Where not
for one disturbing Factor the ground
shaking event was accompanied by a huge
Spike of radioactivity with the strange
phenomenon happening a month before the
Berlin Wall was torn down during a
period of the Cold War that has
historians call the year of Crisis it's
easy to understand why the people of
Danner immediately assumed the worst but
the huge eruption they felt wasn't the
result of a nuclear bomb going off the
SCP Foundation was alerted to the event
in Danner when they picked up a series
of radio Transmissions coming from just
outside the town when they arrived they
found something incredible like
something out of a sci-fi movie standing
at the quake's epicenter was a creature
that looked to be from another world
standing two meters tall and weighing
almost 300 kilograms the being was green
and brown in color with a bulky humanoid
body its head was a different story
though and resembled a gigantic housefly
with a proboscis and huge stereoscopic
eyes surprisingly the strange creature
did not immediately go on a rampage
instead the being designated
scp-2273 appeared to be exhausted
injured and extremely malnourished it
offered no no resistance at all to the
foundation containment team and it was
taken to site 17 without conflict while
the SCP Foundation is no stranger to
visitors from other worlds there was
something especially unusual about the
supposed alien Invader the doctors who
examined the creature and treated its
injuries found an appendage that seemed
to function as an organic radio
transmitter and large open wounds on its
shoulder blades and forearms where
further appendages had been ripped off
additionally while its insect-like
exoskeleton was mostly a uniform green
and brown pattern the creature's upper
arms and torso were dotted with a
variety of scars and markings that on
closer inspection looked like military
badges was this some kind of wounded
Intergalactic soldier who had been
stranded on Earth if it was then how
were the organic badges on this aliens
exoskeleton a near perfect match to
military badges worn by soldiers in the
Soviet Union even if they did reference
a unit that didn't officially exist
within the Soviet Army the scientists
were sure this alien wasn't an alien at
all underneath its exoskeleton was a
non-anomalous human being if that was
true then this was even more terrifying
than an extraterrestrial visitor the
scientists were sure that the USSR had
developed a new kind of organic armor
and this anomaly showing up in Wisconsin
was the result of a test on U.S soil
that had gone wrong if that was the case
then there was no telling how many more
of these exoskeletons were out there and
would need to be contained the
foundation had to act quickly and find
out more while
scp-2273 was recovering they called in
Dr Friedrich an on-site psychologist who
could speak several languages including
Russian Dr Friedrich would be tasked
with interrogating the SCP on his
Origins and the nature of the suit the
interview was conducted via AM radio
from a separate observation chamber as
the biological transmitter seemed to be
scp-22 73's only method of communication
the interview began with Dr Friedrich
speaking to
scp-2273 in Russian only for 2273 to
respond that Dr friedrich's accent was
atrocious and requesting he used German
instead
scp-2273 who according to the organic
military patches on his body was named
Major Alexi bellatrov initially resisted
being interviewed he believed that he
was a prisoner of war being held by the
American Military according to him he
had been in the middle of battle and
that the Americans had killed his men
and left him for dead in the wilderness
nothing that Dr Friedrich told him that
there was no war or that the foundation
was not affiliated with the U.S
government could convince him otherwise
and he refused to talk further before a
second interview was conducted velotrov
was given an old copy of the level 1
researcher General debrief as a way of
helping him further understand the
nature of the foundation and his
containment belatrave was more
Cooperative after that though the
realization that he would most likely be
kept in containment for the rest of his
life caused him great distress and he
was unwilling to speak to Dr Friedrich
for another three days Dr Friedrich
didn't give up though and when bellatov
finally opened up to the doctor he began
to tell him more and more bellatrop told
the doctor that when he was a child
Russia was hit by an American nuclear
warhead and that the Soviet Union
immediately retaliated the resulting
nuclear conflict which balotrov called
the war to end the world caused massive
Devastation and left most of the planet
dangerously irradiated that is why he
had the exoskeleton it was to Shield him
from the radiation and allow him to
survive above ground unfortunately
velotrov knew very little about how the
suit was made or how it worked saying
that it was built by the engineers and
that it grew naturally over a period of
several years but bellatrov hadn't made
the decision himself it was his parents
who had volunteered him as a test
subject for the exoskeleton suit program
when he was still young hoping it would
give him a better chance at survival the
process of bonding the exoskeleton to
the human body was extremely painful but
according to balatrov its advantages far
outweighed the pain the suit not only
helped him survive in a nuclear
Wasteland but made him a better Soldier
the suit allowed him to lift and carry
up to 1200 kilograms gave him
stereoscopic vision and the organic
radio transmitter allowed him to
communicate with other soldiers across
long distances as well as listen in on
encrypted enemy Transmissions the wounds
on his shoulders and arms where it
looked like appendages had been ripped
down were where his weapons and Supply
packs had previously been mounted
velotrov had been stationed with his men
in the area he was discovered when they
were attacked by American soldiers the
soldiers had ripped off bellatrop's
weapons and Supply pack and did the same
to all his men as well they were all
shocked with belatrop being Bear for the
moment only because the Americans had
identified him as the commanding officer
suddenly there was a bright flash of
light and the American soldiers vanished
not only that but the landscape changed
where there had been a post-nuclear
wasteland before now there were lush
green trees injured and disoriented
belatrop began sending distress signals
only to have those signals intercepted
by the SCP Foundation the most
interesting part of belatron's story as
far as the foundation was concerned came
during his fourth interview when Dr
Friedrich asked him about the engineers
who had designed the exoskeleton suit in
belladrov's own words they weren't truly
known to man until the years of the
Great War and the revolution the French
found them in buried cities where the
Western allies were digging their
trenches eventually they were made to
build weapons for the war by both sides
by his description these Engineers
didn't sound human but they were by no
means unknown to the SC EP Foundation
bellatrov described the engineers as
humanoid nocturnal covered in fur and
possessing technology and intelligence
far beyond that of any human those
familiar with the foundation's history
might already know the engineers by
their Foundation designation of
scp-1000 or their more commonly known
name Bigfoot a quick rundown
scp-1000 are a species of intelligent
humanoid primates that lived alongside
Humanity in highly advanced cities until
their own technology was turned against
them not only were there cities wiped
off the face of the Earth but 70 of
their population was slaughtered and the
survivors were driven mad to the point
that their mental faculties were no
higher than those of a chimpanzee or
gorilla the SCP Foundation is tasked
with keeping them away from Human
contact in fear of what the creatures
would be able to do to humanity if they
ever regained their memories and full
mental function and rumors have been
spread about them possessing deadly
anomalous properties but evidently the
destruction of the scp-1000 species
never occurred in bellatrop's universe
or if it did it wasn't nearly as
complete in that timeline Humanity
regained contact with scp-1000 after
discovering their underground cities
sometime during World War one after this
discovery both Allied and Axis Powers
began recruiting them to build weapons
and their weapons played a role in both
the Russian Revolution and the second
world war it was because of these
technological advantages that the Cold
War escalated into what would become the
war to end all wars both sides were
armed with not only nuclear warheads but
highly Advanced radiation-proof
exoskeleton armor that allowed the
conflict to continue even after the
total Destruction of the planet while
the humans fought above ground life
continued as normal for scp-1000 in
their underground cities as velotrov
noted they never wore the armor
themselves as they had no need to
venture above ground only soldiers wear
armor and this is not their War
bellatrov continued to adjust to life in
containment and sitting for regular
interviews with Dr Friedrich he was
given the rations provided for humanoid
anomalies but in much larger quantities
as the suit required him to eat around 8
000 calories a day to keep it
functioning bellatrov also began taking
advantage of his ability to access the
foundation's library he would often read
or listen to classical music
particularly by the Russian composer
Tchaikovsky he seemed especially fond of
reading The Time Machine by H.G Wells no
surprise given he was able to directly
relate to the experience of living
through an apocalypse and being
transported to a strange timeline with
no way to return home but with little
else to occupy his time bellatrov began
to display symptoms consistent with
post-traumatic stress disorder reporting
in his now regular interviews with Dr
Friedrich that he was constantly
reliving memories of the battles he'd
fought and the lives he had taken in
combat the suit was making the problems
worse too it seemed it was as if he
could never forget as one of its
features was an ability to store and
replay memories this feature was
intended as a strategic Aid that would
allow commanding officers to more
effectively gather and process
information about their surroundings but
outside of combat this only served to
force balatrov into reliving his most
painful memories again and again every
night as he tried to sleep he would see
the faces of his men their weapons torn
from their exoskeletons laying in the
dirt after being gunned down by the
enemy like many veterans bellatrov was
being hit all at once with the harsh
realities of War now that his brain
wasn't solely focused on keeping him
alive it had time to process all the
horrors he'd experienced he told Dr
Friedrich I trained alongside these men
for years before they put us back on the
surface since we were all young children
we brothers and I gave them the order to
surrender and got them killed I should
have died with them while the story of
scp-2273 ends here the story of Alexi
bellatrov
scp-2273-1 continues in 2018 bellatrobe
was allowed passage to volugrad Russia
as part of an anomaly reintegration
program while he was unable to secure
employment within the Russian government
as he had hoped he eventually was taken
in by a monastery and continued to write
letters to Dr Friedrich until
friedrich's eventual death from
lymphoma-related complications there's
plenty more on the monastery the anomaly
reintegration program and what happened
to Major belatrav when he returned to
Russia but that will have to be a story
for another day the SCP Foundation is an
organization that polices the abnormal
in all its forms whether it's a
multi-dimensional chaos God a big scaly
monster or a very effective coffee
machine the foundation takes appointed
interest in pretty much anything outside
the norm so you're probably wondering
what would they want with Mr Smith a man
who was about as normal and average as
could be Mr Smith was a 47 year old
African-American construction worker
with a wife and daughter he lived a
modest but contented life he had a close
circle of friends a happy family and was
well liked among his co-workers but Mr
Smith had no idea about the anomalous
nightmare barreling down the tracks
towards him Mr Smith wasn't just about
to have his life destroyed by an anomaly
he was about to become one it seemed
like a normal day at work on the
construction site when he received a
phone call it was the police informing
him that his wife and young daughter had
been involved in a terrible car accident
while this is anyone's worst nightmare
it was only the start of the horrifying
things that were about to happen to poor
poor Mr Smith that night when Mr Smith
went to sleep he fell victim to a
strange phenomenon he started to
disappear while it would be easy to
write off as the result of mental
illness like a kind of stressed-induced
mental breakdown Mr Smith wasn't the
only one who noticed or rather didn't
notice his co-workers would slowly begin
to forget details about him even obvious
things that you could glean from simply
looking at a person like clothes height
or skin color it seemed that little by
little ever since his family died Mr
Smith was becoming an unperson this led
to increasing levels of fear paranoia
and distress as people whom he'd thought
of as his closest friends could barely
recognize him anymore thankfully Mr
Smith wasn't just going to slip into
non-existence without a fight he
realized early on that his new
conditions seemed to abide by certain
rules the effects got worse in the night
when he was alone but seemed to lessen
somewhat during the day when he was
interacting with people it seemed that
he disappeared just that little bit more
whenever he wasn't being interacted with
and perhaps he hadn't developed this
condition upon the death of his wife and
child maybe he'd had it for a while but
it was the constant presence of his
family that kept the effects from
worsening but now that he'd properly
identified the problem Mr Smith could
begin devising some solutions if nobody
else was there to interact with him at
night he'd keep his position in reality
stable by interacting with himself Mr
Smith would repeat his own name to
himself regularly reaffirming his
existence to himself he'd often check
his own pulse to feel the rhythm of his
heartbeat he'd write detailed
descriptions of himself either on his
own body or a surrounding surface and in
one particular stroke of Genius he
devised a method of recording his own
voice talking to himself and playing it
back while he was asleep to Stave off
reality Decay during the day while at
work or just existing socially in the
world you do everything he could to
constantly interact with people that way
they could keep reaffirming his presence
and therefore continuing his existence
the symptoms of Mr Smith's condition are
somewhat similar to a rare mental
illness known as the kotar delusion in
which a patient believes they are dead
dying or don't even exist except in Mr
Smith's unfortunate case the delusion
was becoming a reality and this was a
reality that Mr Smith could only hold
off for so long little by little the
coping mechanisms he'd built to manage
his new life began to collapse people in
his inner circle truly began to forget
him his company no longer recognized him
as an employee to the people who barely
knew him he was little more than a ghost
a kind of palpable absence this was the
point when the SCP Foundation finally
got involved they swooped in and
apprehended Mr Smith redesignating him
as SCP
1467 it was one of the rare occasions
that the foundation didn't need to apply
any amnestic treatment to bystanders
because due to the nature of Mr Smith's
anomalous activity almost everyone who
knew him was already in the process of
forgetting him when the foundation
interviewed a man that Mr Smith referred
to as a close friend he couldn't even
recall Mr Smith's basic physical traits
with any reliability because of Mr
Smith's condition the foundation had
real difficulty verifying elements of
his backstory Mr Smith told the
foundation researchers everything about
himself about his family and his life
before but field agents were stumped
whenever they tried to follow up on the
information first there were issues with
the existence and fate of his supposed
wife and child no records were ever
found of either of these people existing
and there was no existing documentation
to prove that Mr Smith was ever married
the foundation also looked into the
deaths of Mrs Smith and her child there
were no records of a car crash in the
area that Mr Smith directed them to but
that's not all there were also no death
records nor any Graves ever found the
construction company that Mr Smith
claimed to work for had no records of
his employment they couldn't find any of
Mr Smith's supposed extended family
either the only proof that he had ever
existed was his physical body locked in
a foundation humanoid containment cell
and Mr Smith's own words if you think
this sounds like a living nightmare then
Mr Smith would wholeheartedly agree with
you the effects of his anomalous nature
traumatized Mr Smith he was diagnosed by
Foundation therapists as suffering from
bipolar depression as well as chronic
sleep deprivation though if you
disappeared a little more every time you
slept you'd probably lose a lot of sleep
too the unpredictable nature of Mr
Smith's anomalous trades could have
equally unpredictable effects on the
nature of of his containment so he was
classified as Euclid Mr Smith is one of
the few anomalies that is referred to by
his real name at least to his face when
referred to as
scp-1467 Mr Smith enters a state of rage
and panic and this mistake has caused
several injuries for foundation
Personnel during attempts to restrain
him after using his SCP number around
him Mr Smith is contained in a foam
padded cell to prevent self-destructive
Behavior along with three audio
recording devices though these were
installed at his own request in order to
continue his habit of recording his own
voice to play back to himself while
asleep this served the dual purpose of
not only mitigating his fading from
reality but also keeping him calm and
docile during containment and these
devices are kept in good working order
in order to avoid creating hostility
between Mr Smith and foundation's staff
while it may seem that the anomalous
effects of Mr Smith purely serve to
create a personal hell for him and him
alone the foundation wasn't so sure the
fact no records could be found of his
wife daughter or extended family was
concerning it raised one frightening
question are the effects of Mr Smith's
condition contagious if so he could be
putting a lot of people in grave danger
Foundation scientists headed by senior
researcher Dr Thorne devised a series of
experiments to better understand Mr
Smith's mysterious condition there were
22 experiments in total but things began
to get interesting at around experiment
16. for this experiment Mr Smith was
forcibly restrained and brought into a
research chamber with research
assistants Rainier and Dieter they were
told to Simply observe Mr Smith without
interacting with him and record what
happened in the process while Dr Thorne
supervised at 10 minutes and 12 seconds
the researchers were unable to recognize
the subject as Mr Smith at 14 minutes
and 32 seconds there were able to
recognize the clothes of Mr Smith less
than 10 minutes later they were unable
to identify his Reigns five minutes
after that they couldn't identify what
Mr Smith was currently doing ten minutes
later they couldn't even identify how Mr
Smith was sitting at almost 40 minutes
the research assistants weren't able to
identify anything of Mr Smith save for
the fact that there was some kind of
humanoid creature in the room at this
point research assistant deodor started
a recording instructing Mr Smith to
describe himself on record as this
happened Smith returned to a describable
State curled up in a fetal position on
the floor there was no sign of the
restraints or the chair in which Smith
had been placed subsequent tests showed
similar results with minor variations in
timing just by being in physical contact
with Mr Smith the chair and the
restraints had literally faded out of
existence evidence was really pointing
towards Mr Smith's anomalous effects
being potential detrimental to the
people and objects around him but the
experiments continued they had to know
more before there was nothing left to
know the next series of experiments were
performed with d-classes and led Dr
Thorne and his team of researchers to a
number of frightening conclusions two
d-classes locked in with Mr Smith as he
slipped out of existence began
experiencing extreme states of Terror
and distress even when they could no
longer see him they could still feel the
presence of an entity in the room when
the 2D classes tried to escape one of
them was almost mistaken for Mr Smith
himself he too was now starting to slip
out of existence both d-classes were
summarily terminated and Dr Thorne began
to wonder whether Mr Smith's condition
was contagious or if he was instead
somehow able to lash out at others in
his vicinity in a more localized fashion
only two other experiments were ever
performed on Mr Smith before further
experimentation into his case was
permanently suspended in the first a
non-violent d-class was placed in Mr
Smith's cell and ordered to ignore him
Mr Smith didn't take this well he began
attacking the d-class who fought back
breaking Mr Smith's nose ironically this
physical attack was actually beneficial
to Mr Smith as the violence helped
ground him in reality and secured his
existence just that little bit more in
the final experiment Mr Smith was given
a cellmate a female d-class who was
allowed to acknowledge Him the two
appeared to become close and their time
helped Stave off Mr Smith's fading just
a little bit longer it's unknown if she
contracted his fading condition or
somehow was able to escape but one day
while Mr Smith slept she simply
disappeared Mr Smith fell into a state
of almost catatonic silence soon after
he began to speak again only to repeat I
don't want to go again and again and
again experiments concluded for good not
long after because of his delicate
mental state Mr Smith is allowed a visit
from a therapist every week and before
any future experiments are performed on
Mr Smith researchers are required to
seek permission from his active
therapist because of his effects on the
minds of people aware of him Foundation
protocol is to terminate Mr Smith
immediately if he ever breaches
containment the site director has also
appended a memo to Smith's file
instructing Personnel to refer to Mr
Smith as
scp-1467 whenever he's out of earshot
doing otherwise will incur severe
punishments records on Mr Smith are
backed up in six separate copies and
stored in different locations in hopes
that this will prevent the information
from decaying like Mr Smith's existence
Mr Smith's story is one of pain tragedy
and existential horror there's no
shortage of scps that can cause XK Class
end of the world scenarios but sometimes
the terror of these anomalies pales in
comparison to scps that can bring one
person's World crashing down around them
according to all the SCP Foundation
studies it's likely that Mr Smith will
disappear sometime soon regardless of
their intervention hour one there is
only one news story on every website
newspaper and TV screen the flowers are
blooming everywhere all across the globe
every country every land mass the bitter
cold of the Antarctic gives way to a
glowing rainbow of petals the Sahara
Desert and Death Valley become beacons
of thriving Technicolor plant life the
highest mountains the lowest valleys the
darkest caves the flowers even burst
free from the concrete of cities as if
reminding us that really it was never
our world we were only borrowing it and
today our lease is up this is
scp-001 object class unnecessary it was
foretold by Tales from other dimensions
a distant future coming down the tracks
towards us and today the train has
reached the station nobody's reporting
on how the economy or the stock market
is doing today no point celebrity
scandals have faded away into
nothingness greedy businessmen lying
politicians brutal tyrants none of them
are making the headlines today the very
last headlines the world gone beautiful
and what a shame it takes the end of it
all to make us realize what really
matters to us that's right you're
looking at the end of the world but it's
okay don't panic take a deep breath in
and out it was bound to happen
eventually so no point worrying now even
the foundation knows that this just
isn't something they can stop so instead
of asking things like how can we prevent
this or do we have any final Tricks Up
Our Sleeve let's ask a different
question entirely what would you do if
you knew that you only had 24 hours
until all life on Earth ends think hard
after all even if you never live to see
the flowers bloom a final day will still
come for you just as it does for us all
hour six a d-class sits alone in the
cell when he sees the flowers growing
out of the ground normally he'd assumed
that this meant he was in some kind of
foundation experiment but not today
everyone on Earth had an innate sense
that the time is now a kind of gallows
calm spreads out over everyone and
everything it's over and that's okay we
all knew it was going to happen
eventually right he Sighs and gives a
slight smile those flowers sure are
beautiful that's when he hears footsteps
outside his this cell approaching a key
slides into his cell door and opens
there stands Dr gears holding a bottle
of wine and two glasses anyone who knows
him might think he's been replaced by
some kind of shape-shifting anomaly or
had his mind taken over by a powerful
Cognito Hazard but no it's him the
famously called Dr Charles Ogden gears
Dr gear says come on it's a lovely day
out there it'd be a terrible waste to
spend the whole thing cooped up in here
it'd feel like a trick on any day but
this the d-class nods and follows the
doctor out the normally oh so stoic
Foundation senior researcher pours
himself in the d-class each a glass of
wine and asks What's Your Name by the
way I don't think I ever checked the
d-class replies that his name is Harold
the two smile and shout as they exit the
now empty d-class containment Wing
everyone else is outside already
researchers guards administrative staff
and d-classes all rubbing elbows and
enjoying the beautiful sun on their last
day together Elsewhere on site a flock
of scp-514 is released just as identical
flocks are being released from every
containment site all over the world
they've prepared it all for this very
day
scp-514 is a special breed of homing
pigeons created by the Mana charitable
Foundation which have the power to
suppress aggression for those within
their field of anomalous influence and
now millions of them are flying all over
the world after all there's no point
fighting on a day like this there is no
future left to secure people always told
them there would forever be hope until
the flowers bloomed no situation was
ever truly over until the World Went
beautiful but in the absence of Hope
there was something even more inviting
total absolute calm the site-19
Personnel sit together and watch the
flowers bloom hour 12 all militaries
call a global ceasefire soldiers from
opposing sides hug and shake hands in
Flowery fields that once seemed choked
by death and blood borders fade bitter
rivalries turn to dust Korea unifies all
is quiet in the Middle East gangsters
and drug cartels drop their weapons and
return home to their families and
friends as flocks of scp-514 Fly Above
what good is all the blood money in the
world on a day like this wardens walk
cell to cell through all the world's
prisons granting people their freedom
again sometimes after lifetimes of not
having it they taste the Aragon feel the
sun on their face they close their eyes
drink it in and walk among the flowers
free men locations of Marshall Carter
and dark limited close their doors and
shudder their Windows worldwide for the
first time in as long as any of them can
remember they turn their signs to closed
they've earned a day off everyone has
the chaos Insurgency rolls up their
plans and burns them they drop their
weapons and throw away their tactical
gear as they do so they can't help but
question themselves what was it all for
in the end what was any of it for all
the fighting and bloodshed and death we
did a day after day only to do it again
the next day what silly reasons we
killed and died for what silly reasons
indeed the global cult Coalition
dismisses its staff thanking them for
their service and telling them to go
spend their last hours with the ones
they love like the foundation they
accept that this is the one true Final
End no ritual to stop no monster to
fight no evil extra dimensional entity
to thwart just go outside and smell the
flowers while you still can the
Serpent's hand are similar they decide
after decades fighting a losing battle
they'll spend their last day in The
Wanderers library reading some of their
favorite volumes all these 1 wonderful
stories now left for other Earths to
read their own stories would be counted
among them in the end and they take
great comfort in that in a sense
everyone will live forever in the pages
of the books in The Wanderers Library
Hermann Fuller's circus of the
disquieting releases all of its Freaks
and clowns from their Twisted grasp to
go and live out whatever small dreams
and Tiny Pleasures they could find over
their last hours they have no Foundation
of fear anymore nobody Minds their
strange appearances and odd behaviors
why would anyone waste such a beautiful
day judging others on the last day on
Earth there's nothing left to prove
sarcasists dropped their ancient
flesh-bound tomes and acolytes of the
broken God put down their gilded blades
on the slopes of Siberia the jungles of
Peru and the most isolated beaches of
Mexico Twisted flesh finally touched
living metal in the spirit of husbandry
their Eternal war is at its own in the
face of the blooming World they didn't
seem so different after all the Agents
of the doctor wondertainment Corporation
predictably chose to spend their last
hour sitting around and playing with
toys together time well spent if you ask
us in a highly secretive location
perhaps the most heavily secured place
in the entire world the 13 members of
the legendary o5 Council decide to just
sit and talk anyone who knows anything
about this secretive cabal can tell you
the o5 council has spent a considerable
portion of their very very long lives
trying to figure out ways to dodge and
cheat death but now facing a death they
can't Dodge the same calm washing over
the rest of the world has finally
reached them too all they can really
think this time is well played reaper
well played as they chat about the kind
of a name casual things that they
haven't had time to discuss in years
05-3 suggests inviting the Ethics
Committee over to join nobody disagrees
hour 16. it isn't just the D classes all
Sapient and non-aggressive scps have
been released from containment free to
spend the last of their time as they
wish tens of thousands of anomalous
individuals are released from
containment sites all over the globe
it'd be the greatest victory that the
Serpent's hand could ever ask for if
they weren't all too busy reading to
notice
scp-105 Iris Thompson finally returns to
her parents the foundation had fed them
the lie that their daughter had died
many years before but as Iris had a
tendency to do she was ready to work a
miracle her parents Embrace her with
open arms they'll spend their last hours
together catching up on what's happened
since they parted ways and making up for
lost time they couldn't be happier
scp-1867 Lord Blackwood the Fantastical
sea snail is delivered into a warm Rock
pool near the site where he was being
contained there he might finally have
one more Grand Adventure before all is
said and done though afterward he may
not have the time to tell anyone about
it a terrible shame really because
nobody spins a yarn like Lord Blackwood
the non-aggressive little misters Run
free Mr Fish eagerly returns to his
native Boston Massachusetts where he
enjoys one more Lobster sandwich before
the end of the world Mr headless decides
to go hat shopping because he wants to
look good for the apocalypse Mr lost
finally settles down for the afternoon
deciding that just this once he's earned
himself a rest
scp-2800 Cactus men returns to Edinburgh
to spend his last days picking up litter
and helping old ladies cross the street
scp-3663 the tunnel monster walks the
streets of his hometown searching for an
old friend hoping to reunite before it
all ends
scp-073 Kane decides to take a walk
outside for the first time in thousands
of years he can can't help but Smile as
the bright colorful life beneath his
feet is growing faster than his presence
can kill it what a truly beautiful day
knowing that there's no longer time for
Cults to form and bother him
scp-2662 Cthulhu decides to take a break
from his intense Minecraft session and
go take a walk outside it feels so good
to have the sun on his tentacles once
more and to feel the lush green grass
under his suction cups he shakes his
head thinking once again about the
irritating Cults that had been pestering
him for decades what kind of idiot would
want him to destroy a world like this
scp-343 also known as God size and looks
over all his creation for what he knows
to be the last time his mouth curls into
a smile as he thinks well we had a
pretty good run still in a Cell
scp-049 the plague doctor puts his feet
up and decides to relax the pestilence
will soon be taken care care of on some
animalistic level below thought below
even Instinct
scp-096 feels grateful that no gaze will
ever fall upon it again somewhere
fizzling in a vat of acid within a
highly secure containment chamber
scp-682 is feeling for the first time in
its hellish existence a sense of
profound relief the pain the hate the
rage the constant termination attempts
it all be over soon hour 23 people
Gather in the streets they laugh and
dance and sing as the moon shines fat
and white far above deep in their hearts
they quietly contemplate the end of all
of this but why worry why spoil the fun
there's no future left to worry about
strangers become as close as family in
the end human or otherwise anomalous or
non-anomalous chaos Insurgency agents
have last suppers with ex-serpants hands
and GOC operatives there is no hate left
no violence No Malice no cruelty the
greatest tragedy in all of this is that
it took the ultimate end to bring it out
in people but why worry why worry
seconds pass then minutes the world
buzzes it hums trillions of creatures
doing everything they'd wanted even
though it won't last in the face of the
true end the world has never been more
alive hour 24 silence forever and ever
and ever good night we'll end this video
the way it began by putting a question
to you how would you spend your last 24
hours on Earth let us know down in the
comments because it'll happen to all of
us eventually what is your favorite word
think about it for a moment think real
hard write it down in the comments
posted for everyone else to see how many
letters does it have how many syllables
say it aloud how does it sound how does
it feel on your tongue really really
think about it now make sure you keep
that word in mind it's important and
we'll come back to it later for now it's
time to talk about
scp-3449 look there's really nothing any
special about this one it wasn't even
important enough to be mentioned with
the other info hazards it's not an evil
talking toaster that's for sure
scp-3449 appears to just be a standard
spiral notebook not book it's supposed
to be notebook right anyway it's just a
standard spiral notebook with a dark
blue cover it's safe class and it's
stored in the standard
standard containment Locker in site 19.
there aren't any other containment
requires but testing is currently
underway to determined
um I think it's meant to be determined
long-term containment requirements this
is a mess anyway this item and its
anomalous power is actually considered
so inconsequential that researchers have
explored the possibility of putting it
on the anomalous items log a place where
items too useless to warn to full file
ends up geez how do you misspell up that
badly it's two letters supposed to be
two letters how did you work Z into that
they aren't even close to each other on
keyboard man anyway the notebook
contains mostly blank pages some are
torn and only six contain actual writing
but due to the formatting of the ridding
the text consisting mainly of diary
entries is almost unreadable this is due
to synactical errors random
capitalization and rampant imp this
spellings great You misspelled
misspelling
how cute apparently all attempts to
correct these misspellings fail or even
lead to additional misspellings this
anomalous effect extends to anyone
attempting to write yep that was spelled
r-i-g-h-t anyone attempting to write
about
scp-3449 including the script for this
video apparently there are no further
notable Anonymous properties tests are
ongoing though those with any inquiries
about testing scp-3449 should contact
lead researcher Nick Lowe gerdinell The
Notebook which was misspelled even worse
this time impressive was first recovered
by MTF Epsilon 6 also known as The
Village idiots after a series of info
hazardous and Cognito hazardous
phenomenon were discovered in the
Pittsburgh Metroid area The Source
seemed to be a storage unit filled with
anomalous items and scp-3449 was a mogus
I think that's meant to be among them
the storage unit was registered to a man
by the name of Edward salzbro currently
designated as porpoise of Interest 4335
that's the end of that thanks for
watching the video folks now go check
out oh wait there's more phenomenal
let's keep going apparently that version
of the file was an older one let's check
the next one and see if that's any more
useful oh oh oh my it appears that the
updates here are actually quite
extensive okay let's give this another
try
scp-3449 is a Euclid class SPC kept in
the humanid containment cells of site
19. items affected by it are kept in
standard store eggs lockers for safe
class anomalous objects at the same site
the primary reason for the shift is that
scp-3449 has changed its object of
designation it is no longer the spiral
notebook it is now a 34 year old
Caucasian man known as Edward salzbro
formerly known as Person of Interest
4335 he is believed to be the creator of
the notebook as well as other objects
found in the storage looker in
Pittsburgh
Foundation Personnel are now trying to
locate and contain any other objects
created by Mr sellsberg though success
has been limited on this front that was
cute
scp-3449's analogous abilities manifest
onto both Edward himself and all the
objects created by Him ridding about him
or any of these objects will result in
synaptical errors arbitrary
capitalization and Rampart imp smellings
attempts to revise or correct the
writing will either fail to remove the
errors or create new errors it appears
that the anomaloninous effects of
scp-3449 proper are more severe than
that of the ones caused by his anomalous
objects MTF Epsilon 6 also known as The
Village idiots apprehended as cp3449 in
his apartment just outside of Pittsburgh
he appeared to be in an advanced state
of disorientation and dehydration
records collected by the mobile task
force found that Mr selberg had not left
his apartment in over 10 days which
would account for his dire health
conditions Salzburg did not communicate
with mambas of the mobile task force but
did not reset arrest and subsequent
containment either okay okay these
spellings are rough but I'm going to try
and power through I am a professional
and we're almost there the following is
the full lug of items obtained from
scp-3449 Storage look car that also
exhibit his anomalous effects The
Notebook as already discussed the pages
are either blank torn or illegible
salzberg's computer files saved on this
device include spreadsheets dealing
personal finances ideals for products
and an unfinished horror novel that is
almost unratable due to the poor quality
of its writing grocery list had only two
written items Booter was spelled with
only one t and medication which was
spelled medication a planner last entry
was dated two weeks before containment
and believed to contain reminders to
perform various chores however a mixture
of poor or handwriting and word choice
allows for other interpretations and
finally Mr salzberg's cell phone
Foundation researchers were also able to
collect the call logs in hopes of
further tracking salzburg's
pre-containment activities the last
three calls which were all made on the
same day two weeks before contentment
dialed different numbers only one of
which was in use the foundation made
contact with the receiver of said call
who had no knowledge of
scp-3449 and claimed that they did not
answer the call lead researcher Nick
Lowe gerdinell conduced the first in
interview with
scp-3449 shortly after his capture when
he entered the interview chambri he
found that
scp-3449 was just sitting in the corner
which with his had in his hands rocking
back and forth in what appeared to be
apparent distress he then begun looking
down into his lap in twiddling his
thumbs like a child Nick Lowe engaged
him in a calm and polite tone addressing
him as
scp-3449 the autumnly made eye contact
with Dr gerdinell but he didn't respond
and instead continues starring at him as
guernanell axed further Quest Tunes
Salzburg simply didn't answer or would
at the very most acknowledge the
questions with simple gestures girdnell
asked whether Salzburg was making
products for his business to which he
smiled and shuck his head gurnell then
asked Salzburg whether he could speak or
not or if it was merely a choose on his
part unsurprisingly Salzburg offered no
explanation and the interview came to a
close shortly afterwards tests are still
ongoing to find out if salzburg's
inability to spack or communicate come
as a result of his anomalous traits or
if this is simply a result of epiphonia
a uncommon but non-anomalous condition
that renders its victims unable to Spike
tests have confirmed that sellsberg does
have all the organs required for
vocalization but s appears to not use
them for the tests are required alright
there we have it that was a complete
nightmare to read thanks to
scp-3449's anomalous effects but at
least it's over now
go check out wait there's more
another update to the file good okay
all right let's go take a look oh I see
this is a lot more dangerous than I
thought I suppose I better read on
scp-3449 Hayes Ben upgraded to ketter
class anomal
scp-3449-a the new designation for
Edward salzburger is to be kept in a
high security Hazmat containment in site
19. the inanimate anomalous possessions
of Edward Salzburg are to be keeped in
standard object containment any reports
written on scp-3449 must be rotten by
Popple who have been exposed to it for
less than seven days in order to keep
the files raidable to prevent this
infectious info hasmart from spread
further the number of people allowed to
interact with this anomaly is kept
relatively small and consists of those
that have already been exposed at some
point or another this includes 05-8 MTF
Epsilon 6. Dr teller's research team
some additional Personnel selected for
xpc-3449 research and Personnel chosen
to update
scp-3449 documentation some additional
Personnel selected for xpc 3449 research
and Personnel chosen to update
scp-3449 documentation while Edward
sellsberg and his personal effects are
crudily locked up
scp-3449 is not currently considered
contained Research into the sprod of
scp-3449's effects the vectors for
transmission and any potential
recremities for its degenerative effects
are now taupe priority for all in Loved
Before this whole thing gets out of hand
further research has taught the
foundation that not only are Salzburg
and his items powerful info hazards
their enemalis effects appear to be able
to infect these who experience them
permanently initially it will a prayer
that writing quality only degrades when
the subject is actually writing about
scp-3449 itself but over time they'll
come to the frightening realization that
it actually affects their riffing as a
whole the effect also progresses in its
similarity over time eventually
rendering the victim's ability to write
legible sentences completely displayed
the initial anomalous effects of
scp-3449 were discovered when MTF
Epsilon 6 writes their field reports on
the Mater and found it littered with
synaptical error random capitalization
and rampant in plillings similar errors
appearing in the initial fail about
scp-3449 only serve to reaffirm this
observation however researcher only
began to notice true extent of
scp-3449 effects when the village idiots
field reports concerning other
solomonies came in with equally
atrocious writing attempts to correct
this writing simply led to more
mustaches and frustration on part of
Team soon after a Reese stretcher named
Dr Teller who'd since track and ove were
the
scp-3449 case and his team found that
they were experienced to timbler issues
they couldn't just make the blurreds
happen no matter how hard they
constraint traded they forgot spellings
they couldn't make hand move in the
manner they waited to in order to form
the wards even the most intelligent and
articulate members of the team came
across as extremely young children on
page but didn't stop there wasn't long
before researchers who'd never worked on
the
scp-3449k started to exhibit these same
suspicious errors in own writing the
foundation didn't know how but this
through likeness was starting to spread
with people's abilities to write
degrading across the entire Foundation
that's when a foundation web trawler
picked up same thing even more
distrobbing Global literacies seemed to
be taking a dive The Telltale synaptical
error random to capitalization and
rampant illing misspellings tickling up
everywhere and for everyone and the end
of writing would be one thing but
scp-3449 doesn't stop there now that's
just the beginning Morse code go next
then pictograms not long for sign
language become hopeless scrambled
communication
breaks down little by little people
can't draw anymore can't move right
hands Gall goes calls codes
Lasko his voice talking gets her
remember favorite
word
think about it say it loud when
scp-3449 done when everyone infected
you'll never say again nobody will ever
say again yeah
imagine for a moment that you are a
teenager according to our viewership
analytics some of you watching this
won't have to imagine very hard but some
of you will have to really stretch your
mind to remember what that time was like
either way put yourself in the shoes of
an adolescent for a little while you're
anxious and uncomfortable in your body
desperately trying to juggle your
responsibilities at school your
burgeoning sense of young adulthood your
social life the looming Specter of the
future and a dozen other things that
might make you stress sweat through your
hoodie somehow in between the classes
and extracurriculars the standardized
tests and missed party invites you found
someone who wants to go out with you
you're not sure what they see in you but
they must see something several months
into the relationship you decide to try
and take things to the next level you
wait for your parents to leave town you
pick out the perfect Netflix and chill
material dim the lights and cozy up
together on the couch you go in for the
kiss and shockingly it it goes over well
then just when things are starting to
heat up something doesn't feel quite
right you feel an overwhelming pain wash
over your body there's a flash of
blinding bright light that burns into
your retinas and everything goes black
when you finally wake up your partner is
gone only a grisly smear of dark blood
remaining staining the couch where they
sat like some kind of gory Chalk Outline
somehow you know they're gone they're
never coming back and it is all your
fault it sounds like the opening scene
of a horror film but for one unfortunate
young man known as scp-213 it was all
too real
scp-213 was recovered by the SCP
Foundation in Palo Alto California after
his arrest the local police department
brought him in on charges of homicide
after he accidentally vaporized his
girlfriend they were undercover
Foundation agents in the Palo Alto
Police Department who recognizing this
case as evidence of an anomaly made a
report and were ordered to bring the boy
in for containment during the initial
attempts to apprehend 213 he vaporized
the agents as soon as they made physical
contact with him four agents were lost
before 213 could be successfully brought
into a foundation facility whereas
anomalous properties could be better
studied scp-213 is able to sever the
bonds between atoms in any solid matter
he comes into physical contact with
during this process there is a bright
flash of light and scp-213 experiences
extreme pain often to the point of
passing out like most sentient beings in
containment he is considered a
euclid-class SCP
scp-213 was initially contained within a
high security cell in site-77 the cell
is surrounded by a 10 meter wide Zone
pumped full of gases that are corrosive
to humans skin
scp-213 was informed of the nature of
his containment outside of the
containment unit two armed guards were
stationed with high pressured hoses
pepper spray and polymer web grenades in
case of any Escape however over
containment of 213 soon proved difficult
thanks to the nature of his seemingly
uncontrollable ability 213 made Seven
Escape attempts before one was
eventually successful he requested an
interview with the researcher assigned
to his case knowing that when she
entered his containment facility the
containment procedures would be
temporarily disengaged he vaporized the
remaining containment measures and
escaped from his holding cell the head
researcher attempted to grab him by the
arm but was promptly vaporized
dissolving into a pile of Blood and
Tissue two more agents who try to block
213's path without touching him met
similar Fates after making his way into
the Hall 213 quickly became disoriented
his mind muddled from a mixture of pain
panic and lack of familiarity with the
layout of the facility he was unable to
find an exit and was cornered in the
staff break room the door barricaded
with a chair where he was attempting to
vaporize a portion of the floor at this
point he was too exhausted to
disintegrate any more matter and
collapse from exhaust question just as a
group of Agents broke down the door he
was with a great deal of care and the
use of a gurney to avoid any unnecessary
physical contact returned to his
original containment cell several weeks
later scp-213 breached containment again
however this time it was completely
unintentional security camera footage
from 3 15 am on the day in question
showed 213's bed and a portion of the
floor vaporized in a flash of light
after which he fell through the opening
in the floor and landed in the basement
this incident made it clear that 213 had
far less control over his ability than
previously believed rather than a
purposely destructive entity he was
simply a kid who destroyed what he
touched and could not do anything about
it if it could happen accidentally this
time when else could it happen could he
potentially someday vaporize himself
without meaning to following this
Containment Breach and some time to
recuperate from the injuries he
sustained from his fall 213 offered to
be more Cooperative with the research
into his condition Mission he agreed to
comply with a series of experiments as
well as routine physical examinations
and whatever else it might take to
unlock the secrets of the vaporization
effect just like the foundation he
wanted to know why he caused this
destruction and how he could stop it
from happening during one of the
agreed-upon physical examinations the
research team discovered something
concerning there were smooth nodules
growths of abnormal tissue on 213's back
placed in the shape of a perfect square
with exactly 15 centimeters between each
one the nodules were determined not to
be tumors or cancerous in any way they
did not seem to cause the subject any
pain and he could not remember how long
they had been there perhaps they had
been there his entire life nothing
resembling the nodules or their precise
placement could be found in any public
medical records or research journals it
became clear that the strange spots on
213's back were likely somehow related
to his anomalous ability medical
personnel were assigned to monitor 213
in his containment and watch for any
changes and follow-up examinations were
scheduled to keep an eye on the nodules
and any other potential physical
symptoms a week after the discovery of
the first four nodules 213 was brought
back into the examination room for a
follow-up inspection there was nothing
new found on the subject's back the
original nodules remaining in their
place and exhibiting no change in size
or shape however upon inspection of his
hands the research team discovered two
more nodules when asked if he was
experiencing any pain or discomfort as a
result of these nodules 213 insisted
that he only felt some mild itching and
irritation on the skin around them a
doctor pressed gently on one of the
nodules with his fingertips and it did
not budge with the appearance of these
additional lumps on 213's hands the
research team opted to perform a biopsy
on one of them and extract a sample a
local anesthetic was administered to
213's left hand and the doctor attempted
to slice into the surface of the nodule
with a scalpel as soon as the scalpel's
blade came into contact with his skin
there was a sizzling sound a blinding
Flash and when the attending researchers
had regained Clear Vision of the room
the scalpel had disappeared scp-213
insisted that he had not deliberately
vaporized the scalpel and offered to try
again the second scalpel met the same
fate as the first as did the third and
then a fourth scalpel after the fifth
scalpel disappeared the testing was
suspended for the day and 213 was sent
back to his containment chamber to rest
for the next day's testing from that day
on 213's demeanor changed he was less
enthusiastic about continuing to
research his condition complaining of a
pervasive sense of exhaustion no matter
how much he slept ate or hydrated he
complained of extreme pain in his back
and stomach which did not respond to
treatment with physical therapy or
painkillers in spite of 213's Newfound
apathy the research team was determined
to persist they had come this far in
their quest to uncover the mysteries of
scp-213 and they were not about to let
their subjects discomfort comfort and a
few lost scalpels stop them now the plan
for another follow-up exam and a new
attempt to perform a biopsy were cut
short when 213 was spotted via security
camera having a seizure in his
containment cell he was moved to
intensive care and kept there for
further observation over the course of
the previous 48 Hours 10 more nodules
had appeared on his back each separated
by a distance of five centimeters the
nodules form no discernible pattern one
stabilized 213 was returned to a cell
where more medical personnel were
stationed alongside the guards in order
to monitor his condition and watch for
any further seizures or other adverse
effects one week later everything would
change and the true nature of scp-213
would finally be revealed 213 requested
his next physical exam claiming that he
had noticed something wrong with him
while taking a shower while washing his
back he was shocked to find the skin
suddenly smoothed and unblemished the
nodules had disappeared seemingly
overnight however he was more concerned
than relieved he could not shake the
feeling that even though he could not
see it something worse had replaced them
a cursory examination could not identify
anything in place of the nodules however
a closer inspection revealed that there
was indeed something there where there
had one spin lumps of tissue there were
now thin Cuts Like surgical incisions
less than one millimeter in width guards
rushed to the examination room where the
sound of a terrified scream echoed
through the Halls they found the medical
examiner white as a sheet and trembling
while she had been examining the
incisions on 213 skin the one on his
left palm had opened to reveal an eye
though she could not explain how she
knew that the eye was watching her that
it could see what she was doing and
wanted to understand it 213 was
permanently transferred to a medical
wing of the facility and placed under
constant observation the appearance of
this eye sparked a new hypothesis among
the research team
scp-213's anomalous properties are not
his own indeed his body is not his own
either some sort of parasite is residing
within him watching his surroundings
through eyes buried beneath the skin it
is vaporizing matter in an attempt to
protect itself from harm and possibly as
a means of feeding itself when the eye
first appeared and the Parasite
Hypothesis was introduced
scp-213 began to panic he begged the
research team to remove the parasite
from his body to cut him open and
extract it by any means necessary they
refused and 213 had to be sedated in
order to keep him from attacking any of
the medical staff whatever is living
inside of 213 it does not show up on
medical scans it cannot or will not
communicate with the research team about
its nature or what it might want the
more the medical team tests on it the
larger it seems to grow with more and
more tiny incisions appearing on 213's
body through which the entity can look
scp-213 had been placed in a medically
induced coma until the parasitic entity
can be better understood and perhaps
even removed from his body in the
meantime Perhaps it is better for him
and every living thing around him if he
just stays asleep ever since we took
those first steps out of the primordial
soup mankind has long since looked to
the night sky and dreamed of setting Out
Among the Stars space is as it has been
said the final frontier the vast Inky
void that for all its perils still holds
a sense of wonder and calls us to
venture out and explore the cosmos the
earliest missions of the Space Race
during the 50s and 60s showed the people
of Earth that while it wasn't easy the
dream of achieving space travel was
possible and that dream the willingness
to chase it is all you really need to
get there well that plus a couple of
friends and a Volkswagen Microbus for
William that dream of travel away from
Earth and up to the starry Skies was
inescapable at 21 he was a guy like many
others growing up in the 50s his friends
and family all thought of him as a bit
of a beatnik who was in deep with a lot
of hip counterculture types William had
even dabbled in a few alternative
religious groups as well most notably
practices like the action of
Transcendental Meditation as well as the
teachings of meher Baba an Indian
spiritual leader who claimed to be God
in human form in other words William
would have been a full-blown hippie in
the 60s if he'd only lived long enough
to see them even now the idea of taking
a summer road trip with a small group of
close friends is an unheard of and
that's almost exactly what William had
in mind during the summer of 1958 but
with a few key differences for one this
was said to be a one-way road trip with
zero plans for a return journey and why
you guessed it it was because William
and his Pals wanted to go to outer space
more specifically they wanted to drive
to space to Leave the World Behind and
cruise all the way out into the shining
lights of the solar system in March
William bought a brand new Microbus a
Volkswagen Type 2 Samba bus after
pulling money for a down payment with
his three friends Jerry Sam and Susan
ask anyone nowadays to picture an old
school Minivan and they'd probably end
up describing the exact same type of bus
what had spurred them to buy a bus in
the hopes of traveling off world in it
while the three had recently been
excommunicated from the fifth Church a
highly secretive New Age religion
members of the church or fithists are
all about Conformity and control you may
remember these eccentric folks from our
video on
scp-3512 the more you know but William's
intention of traveling to space seemed
to conflict with the fifth Church's
beliefs most likely on account of his
free Spirit defying a group whose two
Main Hobbies were obsessing over
patterns and mind control the young man
believed there was magic up there among
the stars and refused to work a boring
nine to five waiting for that magic to
come down to earth so with the help of
Jerry he began to work on modifying the
bus heaven was up there and according to
William it was waiting for its Angels it
took about two months but Jerry came
through the engine compartment and cabin
of the Microbus were now airtight with
the section near the rear doors
transformed into an airlock the windows
were replaced with shatterproof acrylic
the outer surface treated to withstand
any space debris the gas tank had been
replaced with technology decades ahead
of its time but the steering wheel gear
shift handbrake and pedals all
functioned exactly the same one look at
the outer panels of the Microbus would
have told you what it was and where it
was heading the word Starmobile was
spray painted on one side side and the
other Alpha Centauri or Bust the 4th of
July rolled around and their Starmobile
took flight William keeping a diary of
their Journey referred to himself and
his friends as the only four people in
the universe who were truly free
careening upwards at 82 miles per hour
without any police to stop them no
longer restricted by mundane life on
Earth the group traveled higher and
higher in their Microbus their plan was
to travel straight to Alpha Centauri the
closest star and planetary system to our
own solar system thinking their Journey
would only last a few short weeks
William and his friends waved farewell
to Earth the bus had everything on board
that these Intergalactic Travelers could
possibly need from bedrolls and pillows
to sleep on to enough dehydrated food to
feed the four of them for three whole
months in space there was even room
aboard the Microbus for Susan's cat
Millie as well as all the Comforts of
Home William and his friends packed
Bongos a guitar and countless books but
this road trip wasn't just an aimless
Joyride out into the cosmos the Intrepid
group had enough supplies with them and
enough ambition to set up the first
off-world human Colony they'd practice
seed bank containing hundreds if not
thousands of varying seeds from a number
of common domestic plants from Earth on
top of that there were even Frozen egg
cells of domestic animals like cats and
dogs and livestocks such as cows and
pigs these embryos were all ready to be
unfrozen and allowed to grow once the
gang reached their destination however
it didn't take long for problems to
start arising for one the group quickly
ran out of Libations within the first
five days of leaving Earth Spirits were
naturally dampened by the absence of
spirits but William tried to remain
optimistic hoping to grow barley and
concoct some homemade Brew once they
arrived at Alpha Centauri but while the
lack of Ale and lager was an
inconvenience there was worse on the
horizon during a group sing-along
something collided with the Starmobile
naturally All Aboard were rattled and it
was Jerry who stepped up to calm
everyone stating it was likely just
space dust or debris he opted to take a
look outside and see if there had been
any damage to the Microbus donning a
homemade spacesuit Jerry left via the
airlock at the rear of the bus and
examined finding no significant harm had
been done but as he was about to make
his way back inside something struck the
Starmobile again the force of it caused
Jerry to lose his grip sending him
drifting out into space William was the
only one at the wheel of the bus but had
never learned to drive eventually he was
able to turn the samba bus around but it
was too late Jerry was dead adrift in
the cold vacuum the loss overwhelmed the
group but hit Susan worst of all she and
Jerry had wanted to get married the
moment they arrived at Alpha Centauri
William had even obtained a Minister's
license so he could officiate his
friend's wedding that would now never
happen three days later Sam and William
awoke to find Susan dead on the floor of
the bus the grief and sorrow had gotten
too much for her according to William's
diary she died of a broken heart drawing
up his guitar and strumming Amazing
Grace for his second dead friend William
watched as Sam let Susan's body drift
out of the airlock he wrote In This
Journal that he hoped she would find
Jerry out there in space and at least
they would be together by now it had
been well over 50 days since the
Starmobile had left the safe confines of
planet Earth the group had suffered two
tragic heartbreaking casualties already
one by accident and one as a result of
the first and yet William and Sam the
survivors were still traveling even
deeper into the Dark Void above plotting
their chorus to Alpha Centauri as best
they could with the hand-drawn Star
Charts they had brought with Femme so
far their journey into space had begun
with promise and optimism and was now
fraught with dangers and obstacles and
these were far from over slowly William
began to realize that it was taking much
longer to reach their destination than
he and Jerry had first anticipated Alpha
centauri's roughly four and a half light
years from Earth bear in mind that a
single light year is equivalent to
roughly 6 trillion miles William was
unsure if the Microbus had been
traveling in the right direction or if
it had even managed to miss the Terminus
of the journey the charts Jerry had
drawn were of little help he had been
the expert the one who planned the trip
and modified the Volkswagen Type 2 Samba
bus for space travel William was out of
his steps hurtling through the Galaxy
with Little Help from his passenger to
make matters worse both William and Sam
had started feeling unwell not just
travel sick as you might expect after
spending a long ride in the Microbus
trundling through space their illness
wasn't even caused by being trapped in
the cramped space for such a long
duration of time blotches had begun to
appear all over their skin and Sam had
been having trouble eating at random
even a tooth spontaneously fell out of
his mouth these aren't symptoms typical
of space travel though due to a severe
lack of vitamin C in the food they had
packed the pair of them had developed
scurvy just as it seemed like a trip to
Alpha Centauri couldn't have been a
bigger disaster William awoke to see
something out of the Microbus window
something he had probably seen hundreds
of times in his lifetime but seeing it
now filled him with dread it was the
moon as in Earth's Moon they were barely
close to Alpha Centauri quickly
realizing that they would never reach
their destination on their current
course due to their Grievous errors in
calculation William did the only thing
he could he closed the curtains so that
Sam couldn't see how big of a mistake
they had made eventually Millie crawled
behind the sofa and died meanwhile Sam
stopped being able to keep his food down
towards the end he could barely so much
as see or even sit every time he asked
his friend if they had arrived yet
William would tell him that they would
be there tomorrow he couldn't bring
himself to tell Sam the truth finally
Sam asked William to read to him a poem
by Dylan Thomas called and Death Shall
Have No Dominion he was dead before
William finished reading saddened and
filled with remorse William pushed the
last of his friends out of the airlock
realizing that no one would be left to
push him out whenever he eventually died
the final thought he recorded in his
diary came after two whole months spent
isolated and alone in space before
William's death the last thing he wrote
was that the Stars looked so beautiful
against the dark backdrop of the
universe in spite of the tragedy of his
situation so few others especially from
his time would ever truly see them like
this today the bus is still drifting
quietly through space now known as
scp-1958 it rests in the orbit of Mars
the withered remains of its driver still
sitting at the wheel William and his
friends never made it to Alpha Centauri
in fact it would have taken them almost
40 million years to reach it they never
saw their dream come to the ending that
they had planned instead William Jerry
Sam Susan and Millie the cat all died
Among the Stars driving their magic bus
their Starmobile out into the unknown
for them space that final frontier had a
lot more finality to it water the
Wellspring of Life we've dealt with a
number of anomalous water sources on
this channel like
scp-006 the much sought after Fountain
of Youth or the terrifying scp-3280
where murderous water threatens to
destroy the entire world but we've never
seen anomalous water that behaves quite
like this before in many of the legends
of King Arthur the sword of Excalibur is
presented to him by the mystical Lady of
the Lake this lady emerges from the
depths of the water gifting Arthur with
the enchanted sword it's an incredible
if impossible image a woman appearing
from within the lake rising up from the
bottom and breaking through the surface
it's safe to say that none of us have
ever seen anything quite like it well at
least most of us haven't in a small
unnamed English Village there was a
young woman who set out on a
particularly lovely warm spring day to
take a swim in a nearby lake while
waiting in the water enjoying the
sunlight and the gentle breeze on her
skin she saw a strange Ripple ghost
across the surface she stopped her
swimming staring at the motion she
expected to spot a fish or some other
aquatic creature instead the water
itself began to rise up Gathering and
forming into a shape before her eyes it
was impossible and yet here it was
happening she pinched herself and found
that she was definitely awake as the
water transformed into the shape of a
human woman it turned to look at her
shimmering eyes finding hers and liquid
lips forming into a warm inviting smile
though this being was shocking to see it
clearly meant her no harm it raised a
translucent arm and gave her a small
wave as if to welcome her to its home
the young woman approached this Lady of
the Lake reaching out her own hand of
Flesh and bone to touch this Impossible
Creature just as her fingertips reached
the water woman's own the figure
dissolved back into the lake with a
splash the young woman ran home telling
anyone who would listen about the
incredible thing she had seen that day
of course no one believed her that is
until word of her sighting reached the
only people who might take her claim
seriously the SCP Foundation they sent
operatives to the lake where they
managed to capture the shape-shifting
entity dwelling there
scp-054 also known as the water nymph is
a being made up entirely of water with
an average volume of 90 liters when it
is out of a body of water the being
tends to adopt the appearance of a
humanoid woman though it is capable of
taking on a variety of other shapes
including other humanoids animals and
various inanimate objects The Entity is
also capable of shedding its form and
effectively disappearing into a given
body of water in order to avoid
shrinking or possibly disappearing
entirely from evaporation
scp-054 is required to return to a
larger body of water studies of samples
taken from the entity's body or its
version of a body revealed that it is
made up of ordinary water there is no
apparent reason for its ability to move
and no thermal electromagnetic
biological or Supernatural anomalies
where were detected the research team
could not determine what might make this
water alive and sentient and the nature
of its unusual properties is uncertain
to this day when scp-054 was first
brought into containment at site-08 it
displayed surprisingly congenial and
curious Behavior often walking around
outside of the water and taking turns
mimicking the shapes of various staff
and scientists that spoke to it its
demeanor began to shift towards
suspicion and aggression however
following a series of experiments and an
incident involving the research staff
the first experiment conducted on
scp-054 sought to determine what would
happen if the entity was denied access
to any fresh water water was drained
from the fountain holding it leaving
only enough water for it to form a
humanoid shape but no additional water
in the base and to compensate for the
effects of evaporation over time
scp-054 became visibly frustrated as the
water was being drained out of its
enclosure for the next few days it
enthusiastically greeted anyone who
entered its contain attainment facility
attempting to use a report and sense of
familiarity to convince the person to
provide it with more water after it
realized that this approach had no
impact on the amount of water in its
Fountain it became distant and even cold
to anyone who attempted to speak to it
054 only became friendly again once the
water in its Fountain was restored to a
pre-experiment level next the research
team opted to test
scp-054's reaction to extreme
temperatures particularly extreme cold
the temperature of the containment
facility was slowly dropped until the
room fell below the freezing point of
water as the temperature dropped 054
became sluggish and exhausted it lost
its ability to shift between forms
remaining locked in its preferred
humanoid female shape its movement
slowed more and more as the room grew
colder until the entity was completely
frozen solid portions of the ice were
chipped off and studied revealing the
crystals were identical to those of
ordinary ice after the Sub-Zero testing
the re research team decided to take
things to the other end of the spectrum
and test the effects of heat on scp-054
the subject was placed in a tank
outfitted with heating equipment and its
temperature was slowly raised over the
course of several minutes when the water
reached a temperature of 95 degrees the
entity's behavior became frenetic and
aggressive it pounded on the glass walls
of the tank and attempted to break
through the lid in a desperate bid for
escape until the temperature was
returned to a comfortable level after
the extreme temperature experiments the
previous column and Cooperative nature
of scp-054 was nowhere to be found this
subject displayed increased suspicion of
the research team and would fight back
whenever it was removed from its
Fountain and taken to a lab for
experimentation in spite of this
newfound resistance the team decided to
continue their experiments as planned
hoping that the entity would return to
its formerly docile self over time next
Dr seskel the acting head of the
research team conducted a study
involving scp-054's memory and ability
to be conditioned The Entity was
presented with a series of increasingly
complex mazes and puzzles when it failed
to comply with the experiment or solved
a puzzle incorrectly The Entity was
punished with an electrical shock or the
release of silica gel into its body both
of these options seem to cause it a
great deal of pain and distress and it
was eager to avoid further exposure to
them
scp-054 displayed impressive learning
and problem-solving capabilities
revealing it is likely much more
intelligent than it was first presumed
to be Dr seskel observing the
experiments and with the effectiveness
of his somewhat unsavory motivational
techniques quipped to his research
assistant that they would have it
trained to fetch in no time after
several days of these experiments and
repeated use of both the silica gel and
electrical shocks the entity's progress
slowed down considerably and it became
visibly exhausted it was removed from
the lab for a 48-hour rest period before
experimentation was resumed yet again
this Time Dr seskel planned to expose
scp-054's water source to various levels
of acids and bases in order to test its
homeostatic capabilities beginning with
a 0.5 M solution of hydrochloric acid
prior to conducting the experiment Dr
seskel noted I have no idea what will
happen but if this thing incorporates
homeostatic mechanisms like I suspect
then we should get some insight into how
it maintains its form he also noted that
scp-054's behavior was becoming
increasingly erratic but made the
decision to continue with the experiment
as planned
scp-054 displayed a now familiar
reluctance when it was removed from its
containment chamber and taken to the lab
it thrashed around in the fountain
splashing researchers with water and
retreated from them as they approached
in spite of its efforts however it was
removed from its Fountain and placed in
the experimental tank the solution of
hydrochloric acid was then dripped into
the tank and then all hell broke loose
as soon as the acid touched the surface
of its water
scp-054 became incredibly distressed it
Formed into the shape of a human face
eyes wide mouth open in a Silent Scream
Of Rage and pain the water churned so
aggressively that the lid of the tank
was shaken loose allowing it to escape
the boundaries of its containment the
water formed into two large hands which
shot out of the tank and grabbed the two
nearest researchers pulling them into
the water and exposing their skin to the
acid now present there as the men
scrambled to drag themselves back out of
the tank and their colleagues were busy
helping them
scp-054 took on its usual humanoid form
and ran for the door it then collapsed
into a puddle slipped under the crack in
the bottom of the door and made its way
down the hall it was apprehended roughly
10 minutes after its Escape by a team of
guards who froze it using canisters of
liquid nitrogen and then carried its icy
body back to the containment facility
the two researchers who had been pulled
into the tank experienced chemical burns
on their skin as well as significant
mental distress they were given
immediate medical attention and placed
on a leave of absence and all
experimentation on scp-054 was suspended
until further notice at the
recommendation of Dr Siskel 054's object
class was changed to Euclid
scp-054 is currently contained in a
watertight isolation room fitted with
climate control equipment a beautiful
intricately designed Fountain has been
placed in the center of the containment
room filled with fresh spring water in
order to accommodate the entity's
environmental needs all maintenance
workers assigned to the area must wear
NBC suits while inside and must spend 10
minutes isolated in a drying room After
exiting before they are permitted to
return to the rest of the facility if
054 breaches containment the area must
be evacuated and the containment chamber
will be filled with liquid nitrogen in
order to freeze its water solid as the
entity is highly sensitive to the
conditions of the water that houses it
chemical levels and volume of the water
in the fountain must be monitored on a
regular basis a and kept at optimal
levels for the health of scp-054 during
the course of its containment following
the incident around the acid-base
incorporation experiment 054 has
developed a distrust of men as the
researchers handling that experiment
were primarily male in order to prevent
future incidents and keep scp-054 calm
no male staff are to be assigned to the
team monitoring its containment unit
because five years have passed since the
last incident involving scp-054 its
object class has been changed from
Euclid to safe on the recommendation of
the lead researcher assigned to its case
of course caution should still be
exercised while interacting with the
entity this is the SCP Foundation after
all and just because a moderate amount
of water is good for you doesn't mean
you can't still drown experimentation on
scp-054 has resumed though this time its
boundaries are being honored and it is
allowed adequate time to rest and
recuperate between experiments all use
of punishment in order to motivate the
in entity has been suspended as it has
shown itself to be more than willing to
cooperate if it is treated with respect
like all of us it responds far better to
kindness than it does to fear and
intimidation it doesn't just take on the
appearance of a person it has thoughts
feelings and the urge to defend itself
when threatened so think twice next time
you find yourself swimming in a random
body of water you should be mindful of
what might be living in there not just
of the fish the algae and the tiny water
bugs but of the invisible intelligent
impossible creatures that might be
swimming in there with you or even make
up the very water itself what is it that
makes a person a hero is it a trait that
you're born with something that you can
inherit passed down from generation to
generation is someone still a hero if
they never save a life but improve the
lives of the people that matter to them
do you really need a magic hammer an
enchanted suit of armor or a tragic
origin story in order to become a hero
or can you still be heroic as an
ordinary everyday person through the
simplest of kind Deeds maybe it only
takes a few moments in a lifetime to be
a hero moments when you are given the
chance to overcome adversity or conquer
a personal flaw perhaps learning how to
deal with defeat and get back up after
rather than learning how to never be
defeated is the essence of heroism we
can all be heroes every single one of us
and in a way we already are everyone is
the hero of Their Own Story and if you
want any further proof of that then
maybe you should take a look inside
scp-1230 an unassuming book is presented
to you its hardcover is dark green but
other than that there is absolutely
nothing remarkable about it that you can
notice but little do you know this book
that you hold in your hands is none
other than scp-1230 so what's inside
surely it must be an important anomalous
artifact if the SCP Foundation has an
interest in it perhaps it's filled with
ancient spells or a mathematical formula
to calculate the exact mass of the
fabric of reality now if you're
expecting every page to be full you'd be
disappointed in fact only the first page
you open in the book will have anything
written on it the rest will appear blank
and this can change depending on which
page you open first resetting every time
the book is closed again however the
phrase you will find written on that
page will always stay the same when
opening scp-1230 you will see the words
a hero is born what happens after you
read these words well not much at least
not right away in fact you won't notice
any active effects after reading
scp-1230 for quite some time until that
is you fall asleep and as you sleep you
begin to dream now most streams are
pretty disjointed sometimes fragments of
memories or your deepest most random
thoughts of course other times it's a
fear a long-held and deep-rooted phobia
or manifestation of anxiety brought to
the surface for a while in the form of a
nightmare only to be forgotten by the
time you've woken off perhaps that's why
so many people look for the deeper
meaning to their dreams to get a better
understanding of themselves but this
dream is different far more Vivid and
memorable with a meaning that is a lot
easier to discern in this stream you
find yourself as the hero of your own
story the protagonist of a Fantastical
Adventure it's more than an ordinary
dream it looks sounds smells feels as
real as the Ordinary World you know you
will find yourself at the center of a
fantasy world where you are the hero
destined to Aid this troubled land to
bring peace and save the world the
fantasy you find yourself in is
different depending on who you are it's
a Dreamscape that has been tailor-made
for your enjoyment and your Epic Quest
awaits on the path laid out in front of
you but where do these bespoke fantasy
Adventures come from does the scp-1230
book itself bestow these dreams on a
reader or is there some other Force at
play that creates worlds where the
dreamer is the hero well actually yes
there is and his name is the bookkeeper
or
scp-1230-1 he looks exactly as you would
imagine him too an old man adorned in a
dark green cloak with a long beard
sometimes appearing to dreamers in order
to guide them picture Gandalf from The
Lord of the Rings books but instead of
the gray or the white the bookkeeper is
Gandalf the Green in every dream caused
by scp-1230 the bookkeeper appears as
the personification of the book itself
often aiding dreamers willingly offering
them counsel guidance and help on their
Fantastical quests in an experiment to
test the range of scp-1230s anomalous
properties an SCP Foundation researcher
opened the book token and boarded a
domestic flight spending the night in a
hotel in his hometown even miles away
from the book The researchers still
experienced a Fantastical dream and
during this dream he was approached by
scp-1230-1 the bookkeeper was happy to
explain the workings of the book
describing how scp-1230 implanted a
dream in the reader's subconscious mind
from the moment they saw the phrase a
hero is born on the page he claimed that
he was the sole being with the ability
to manipulate what he described as
fantasy Scapes and that he enjoyed doing
this aiming to sculpt these Fantastical
dreams in such a way that the dreamer
experiencing them would get the most
enjoyment out of being the hero of Their
Own Story thanks to the bookkeeper the
length of the dreams vary they could be
quick only lasting 45 seconds or seemed
to last as long as 200 years from the
dreamer's point of view however in the
real world the person experiencing the
bookkeeper's fantasy Escape would only
actually be asleep for an average
duration of time
scp-1230 only takes effect on living
beings with the capacity for imagination
in other words only human beings are
affected by the book and are able to
enter their own bespoke fantasy when the
SCP Foundation attempted to use a
mechanical arm to open scp-1230 the
pages remain blank leading the
bookkeeper to explain to a subsequent
dreamer that only beings who can dream
may find the phrase a hero is born
within most animals or any machines that
view the book will not experience its
effects at all so what can a person do
within the fantasy escapes of these
dreams is it an open sandbox to do
anything and everything you can think of
or do these Fantastical Realms have
their own rules well for a start they do
seem to be completely safe spaces during
testing the foundation conducted a
number of experiments that involve
getting members of d-class personnel to
read scp-1230 and test the limitation
nations of the dream Worlds the
bookkeeper created for them why use
d-class Personnel to test out something
seemingly as harmless as scp-1230
because the foundation wanted to know if
a person could die in one of these
streams one test involved ordering a
d-class to immediately find a way to
terminate himself once he found himself
inside the dream world he awakened after
only 45 seconds of being asleep and
described being at the peak of a volcano
called the Ashen Spire apparently within
the dream the test subject had been sent
on a quest to recover a sword known as
caledus The Blessed blade he said these
names had come to him as if he had known
them all along following the
foundation's orders the d-class
attempted to throw himself into the
volcano before him only to wake up
moments later after feeling intense heat
but suffering no adverse effects in the
real world during the following
experiment another d-class was told to
try and injure himself in the fantasy
Escape but not a fatal injury the
subject to Wellcare after six hours of
sleep feeling a numbed pain in the same
place he had attempted to harm himself
but this sensation was never intense in
fact it was barely noticeable in his
dream the d-class said that he had
conversed with the bookkeeper who had
shown concern that the man was trying to
cause himself injury but thanked him for
not terminating himself immediately like
the other rude fellow that had preceded
him so all of this sounds pretty great
right a book that lets someone live out
a fantasy Adventure in which they are
the hero of Their Own bespoke Story what
could possibly be the downside well the
downside is this what if someone
preferred their fantasy to the real
world now comes the unfortunate story of
a professor working for the SCP
Foundation a lifelong fan of tabletop
role-playing games like Dungeons and
Dragons the professor filled the request
for access to scp-1230 and it was
granted he was apparently shaking with
pure excitement after reading a hero is
born in the book he didn't even wait
until later to go to sleep instead
opting to doze off right then and there
at the desk where he had read it after
the professor had spent 15 entire hours
of sleep concern had begun to spread
among the other researchers he remained
sleeping living out his own fantasy
adventure for a further nine hours
spending a total of 24 hours in the
dream world that the bookkeeper had made
for him when the professor awoke he
appeared to look around the room
confused unsure of where he was when
approached by the foundation's security
Personnel medical staff examined him and
explained where he was after which the
professor seemed to regain his memory
after being reminded who he was the
professor excused himself to the
restroom he didn't emerge and 15 minutes
later a member of the medical team went
to check on him sadly the professor was
dead scribbled on the nearby bathroom
wall was one simple phrase his last
words I can't go back to this attempting
to immediately use scp-1230 in May make
contact with the bookkeeper another
doctor tried to find the a hero is born
phrase within the pages of the book
however instead the pages were soaking
wet and on every single page the same
message I am so sorry I never intended
for this to happen I just wanted to make
people happy for three weeks the book
stayed like this until the same doctor
placed a sticky note inside
scp-1230 that said I'd like to talk to
you if that's all right that night the
doctor fell asleep and dreamed of being
in a Dark Void there was only one source
of light in the endless Darkness a
Street Lamp under which he found the
bookkeeper sat in a puddle the old
bearded man was sobbing uncontrollably
his cloak soaking wet with his tears he
explained through his overwhelming
sadness what had happened to the
professor he had such an active
imagination I was able to create a vast
and beautiful Universe for him and it
was obvious that he wanted a life like
that for so long he God could foul
beasts and rescued princesses he built
kingdoms and even raised a family but he
never wanted to leave he delved so far
into his fantasy world and I soon
realized he preferred his dream over the
real world I reminded him that this was
all merely an illusion but he wouldn't
listen to me he stated that if he was
ever forced to leave he would
immediately end his life I tried to keep
him happy for as long as I could the
bookkeeper revealed that from the
professor's point of view the fantasy
life he had lived lasted 200 years as
much as the old man had tried to hold on
and keep the professor happy for as long
as possible eventually he had to release
him from the fantasy escape and as a
result the professor had ended his own
life rather than return to reality
scp-1230 resumed its normal function a
few days later after the doctor left
another note between the pages offering
some friendly advice to the bookkeeper
now it sits quietly on a bookshelf in
the site-12 library surrounded by
fictional novels the perfect material to
inspire more fantasy Scapes in the
future we all like to dream that we're
the heroes of our own stories but to
quote the bookkeeper himself how sweet
his dreams may be eventually we all have
to wake up drip drip drip if you see The
Telltale black mucus dripping from the
wall behind you splattering down from
the ceiling then it is already too late
for you the plaster will start to split
the wood will warp and rot metal will
Rust you should try to run attempt to
hide but know that he is coming for you
the old man limping along relentlessly
never stopping to rest to eat to catch
his breath he has no need for such human
things anymore you can't fight him you
can't reason with
and you can't kill what might as well
already be dead just when you think
you've found a safe place to hide you'll
hear a creaking from the floor below you
a blinding pain is something sharp
slashes through your Achilles tendon is
the last thing you will feel before the
decrepit nightmare Vision drags you to
his lair never to return even if you
could Escape now the sickness is already
in you skin already slackening and
muscles beginning to liquefy he is rot
he is death he is the disintegration of
all hope and light and he has made you
his prey we've covered
scp-106 or the old man before we've
talked about his abilities his hunting
patterns an incident in which he escaped
and a variety of theories regarding his
origin it is unknown for sure where
exactly the old man came from there are
three major theories as to his true
origin which created one of the most
fearsome anomalies the SCP Foundation
has ever come across perhaps he was a
deeply Disturbed World War one soldier
who gazed too long into something better
left untouched perhaps he was never
human at all but instead a Divergent
humanoid species that preyed on early
prehistoric mankind today we're focusing
on the third possibility and arguably
the most tragic of the three it begins
with another man we've covered on the
channel before named Dr Robert Scranton
and his wife Dr Anna Lang you probably
know them for two things the Scranton
reality anchor and The Accidental
discovery of scp-3001 or the red reality
in case you haven't seen our video on
the subject here's a brief recap of the
whole unfortunate affair on January 2nd
2000 at site 120 Robert and Anna were
hard at work as the head researchers
developing an experimental device known
as The Lang Scranton stabilizer the LSS
was intended to work as a reality anchor
but it was in its early stages and still
unstable a seismic event rocked the
research site damaging several LSS units
and creating a wormhole that transported
Dr Scranton to the pocket Dimension
Hereafter referred to as
scp-3001 this little pocket of space
this impossible world just adjacent to
ours has some unusual properties it
causes matter within it to deteriorate
as its Hume level approaches that of the
environment Humes being the measurement
unit for reality stability Robert
Scranton was trapped there in the red
reality alive for a terrifyingly long
time five years 11 months and 21 days
before the logs he kept ended there he
struggled to hold on to himself he
grasped desperately at shreds of his
Humanity his memories even as the world
around him slowly ate them away finally
only one thing remained Anna wife he
could just barely remember her name
remember that he wanted to get back to
her there was a brief moment of Hope on
December 23 2005 when the LSS control
panel reappeared in a Testing Lab at
site 120. Dr Anna Lang arrived to
monitor the situation a massive bloody
organic matter appeared alongside it and
as Anna called out for her lost love
something clattered to the floor and
broke her heart her husband's wedding
ring stained with unidentified organic
matter smelling of black blood and
spoiled meat she collapsed under the
weight of the possibility that her
husband was no longer lost in a physical
sense but in another sense entirely that
this mass of Flesh unrecognizable as
human might be the man she once loved
tying his favorite tie for him on date
nights dancing drunkenly to Living on a
Prayer collapsing on the couch together
breathless with laughter and the sheer
Joy of one another that he could be both
here here at last but Gone Forever Dr
Anna Lang was taken to the medical Bay
and treated for shock years passed after
Ana's last encounter with her husband
she carried the ring with her in her
pocket every day for the first few after
five years she threaded the chain
through it wearing it around her neck
under her clothes after 10 more years
she stopped noticing it was even on
anymore it had become a part of her
engraved on her heart with the memories
of the man she had loved lost and
grieved with nothing to go home to at
the end of the day no one to share her
time off with Anna began to pour herself
deeper into her work she would never
remarry she knew that Robert had been
the only man for her now there was only
her commitment to the foundation and the
research she did there and the silent
promise she made to herself that she
would never let anything like the events
of January 2nd 2000 happen again but
will they with no reason to go home
honest nights at the lab grew later and
later her colleagues often joke that she
might as well sleep there since that was
the only thing she went home to do the
sadness behind her eyes tended to cut
their jokes short soon after making them
though Anna liked the late night work
the lab was still almost Serene she
could disappear into the research the
calculations let them take over and
quiet the noise in her mind the lights
were dimmed no one was asking her a name
questions or bustling around while she'd
tried to focus there was nothing but her
notes and textbooks the light of her
lone desk lamp glowing softly in the
dark and the work it was one of these
late nights buried in a mountain of
paperwork that Anna began to hear a
strange sound she didn't notice it at
first absorbed as she was in a sea of
calculations but soon it began to
permeate the room breaking through her
focus a rustling sound a crackling of
sorts quietly murmuring into her ears
though she was vaguely aware of it the
way you might be aware of the wind
rustling through the trees outside your
bedroom window she didn't truly hear it
until she smelled something faint but
foul it was no matter how muted the
unmistakable scent of rot she stepped
down from her lab stool her joints
creaking with effort as she worked out
the stiffness in her muscles she
adjusted her glasses peering into the
shadows for the source of the sound but
saw nothing of note she took a step
forward into the dark then another and
then another behind her the desk lamp
flickered then cut out entirely she
stopped blinking in the sudden complete
darkness and sudden silence the noise
had stopped the only sound was her
breathing quickened with fear she pulled
the phone from her pocket and turned on
its flashlight using its weak beam to
light her way she turned back to her
desk looking for the issue that caused
the light to cut out perhaps a short in
the wire or a bulb that needed changing
before she could take a look at the lamp
however something else caught her eye
there was something slick and red on her
stack of papers dripping onto the clean
white surface and staining it with Gore
a closer look revealed what it was and a
shiver ran down her spine a kidney fresh
and human she couldn't bring herself to
touch it but somehow knew that if she
did it would be warm her heart pounding
and her suddenly tightening chest as the
noise resumed behind her wet slapping
louder than before her feet moved on
their own accord as she walked toward
the sound holding the flashlight in
front of her in a shaking hand the black
wall of the lab illuminated by the light
was smeared with something dark and
strange slick like oil but with a rotten
smell a closer look revealed that the
wall itself was beginning to change
drooping limply like wet cardboard she
froze watching helplessly as the wall
bubbled crumbling to Pieces suddenly a
hand emerged from the wall gray skin
slick with black fluid its fingers
surprisingly strong gripped her arm she
tore it away scrambling back and saw
that pieces of her lab coat had come off
melting into the gray skin of the alien
hand as the arm reached for her again
she stumbled and dropped her phone on
the floor casting its light against the
wall and the figure warming its way out
there it was an old man naked and gray
with slimy decaying skin coming off in
pieces its throat was shredded an open
wound and it grinned at her with stiff
shriveled lips stretched over blackened
teeth its eyes were the worst part even
admits the rest of the Walking Corpse
they were almost like a man's they were
correct in shape and placement but they
were wrong they were empty clouded over
and void of any warmth or Mercy as he
stood there the ground beneath him began
to dissipate melting into an oily puddle
that enveloped her phone and stuffed out
its light there was only one thing left
for Anna to do and so she ran she turned
and made a break for the lab doors lungs
burn learning from the effort she cried
out for the guard on night Duty Frank
her voice was shrill and pleading he
appeared from around the corner gun
already drawn eyes wide and alert at the
Panic he must have heard in her voice as
Frank tried to calm her down and she
tried desperately to explain what she
had seen the old man forced his way
through the lab doors leaving a trail of
corrosive black slime in his wake Frank
fired his gun hitting the old man in the
chest twice he collapsed sinking into
the floor as his excretion broke away
the tiles beneath him as Anna and Frank
debated what to do next a drip of black
mucus landed on Frank's radio from above
another drop fell Landing directly in
his eye he screamed in agony the mucus
dissolving his eyeball on contact next
the empty grin appeared through the
ceiling and the old man fell on top of
Frank tearing out his throat with its
bare hands Anna knew that she had to
escape but where could she go she
couldn't think couldn't plan she just
knew she had to run she ran until her
feet suddenly stopped obeying she was
stuck she was sinking into the ground
and then she was falling down down into
a moldy Dusty hallway dark except for a
nauseating greenish gray glow she had
been pulled into some new nightmarish
world she ran through a nearby door and
found herself shockingly in her old
apartment how had she gotten here how
did the old man know this place there
was her bed her desk her closet she
flung open the closet door to find a
pile of rotten corpses that poured out
and slopped onto the floor she covered
her mouth to choke back a scream turned
and fled then she was back in the hall
this time she recognized it it was a
twisted warped version of sight 120. in
front of her there he was the old man
had found her again and now she was in
his territory he stared at her with
those Hollow eyes and for the first time
spoke
he growled she stopped in her tracks
Frozen to the spot what he said next
turned her stomach and brought tears to
her eyes
he knew her name again he repeated
he reached out to her with a hand that
had a tan line where a wedding ring had
one spin the same ring burning against
her skin under her shirt he cupped her
cheek and she felt the skin sting and
blister he kissed her her teeth melting
infusing tongue turning to Mush but
dribbled down her throat and choked her
her last thought through the fear and
despair was the Egg of love her husband
was not lost he was found and he had
found her too now they would be together
forever not all heroes wear capes some
of them wear Pokemon t-shirts and a
baseball cap you might think you've
heard of every superhero out there with
Marvel and DC dominating the box office
and the incredible cactus man fighting
crime on the Mean Streets of Edinburgh
but there is one tiny aspiring hero
you'd likely never heard of in a world
filled with danger and evildoers one
young boy armed with a a pure heart and
some telekinetic Powers dared to step up
and save the day a woman was being
abducted at gunpoint when seven-year-old
Cameron spotted the struggle he saw the
weapon in the man's hand the fear in the
woman's eyes as she looked for a way out
and he knew that he had to act he
concentrated with all his might reaching
out with his mind and threw the gun out
of the man's grasp and into some nearby
bushes the woman ran as fast as she
could from there but not before catching
a glimpse of the child that had saved
her life somehow she knew that he had
been her hero unfortunately for Cameron
but fortunately for the SCP Foundation
the woman reported what had happened to
a nearby police officer who just so
happened to be an undercover agent for
the foundation before Cameron could
leave the scene he was being approached
by a team of armed guards and brought to
a strange new place filled with men in
lab coats who kept calling him as
scp-2241 Cameron sat for a very long
time in a white room wondering whether
he was in trouble when a new man in a
lab coat entered he introduced himself
as researcher Valdez and told Cameron he
was going to ask him some questions he
asked why Cameron had helped the woman
instead of running away and getting an
adult to help he said Superheroes have
to help people I can move things without
touching them and other people can't so
I should have used that to help them he
went on to explain that he had practiced
his ability in the woods and kept it a
secret from everyone Valdez asked what
sort of things Cameron could do and he
explained I can move stuff without
touching it but not if it's too far away
or if it's too big only like a cup
across the room or a person's arm or
something sometimes I it can sort of
change as well when prompted he
elaborated sometimes when I'm moving
something it changes to something I want
like one time when I was moving a stone
it changed to look like a toy I lost but
it changed back after a while before I
even got home Cameron became distressed
during the interview but Valdez promised
him that he would be okay here he asked
Cameron what his superhero name would be
and he told him Cameron the Crusader
Valdez explained that Cameron would be
staying at the SCP Foundation for a
while so they could learn more about his
powers and help him become a better
superhero researcher Valdez concluded
his interview with this closing
statement
scp-2241 appears to trust me and
believes that the foundation is
attempting to help him as much as
possible
scp-2241's account is consistent with
the early stages of humanoid developing
a reality bending ability
scp-2241 may have experienced abuse at
the hands of its parents leading to
early development of set ability in the
event that a more developed ability is
required for research similar emotional
stress can be applied by Foundation
staff
scp-2241 is kept in a standard humanoid
containment chamber he is given access
to television vision and comic books
though this access can be cut off as
punishment for bad behavior he has fed
three balanced meals a day with
additional treats such as chocolate or
ice cream provided after testing
especially if the testing goes on for a
particularly long time or is
exceptionally stressful all Personnel
that interact with scp-2241 are to call
him by his name Cameron when interacting
with him only Cameron's assigned
psychologist and specifically designated
Personnel such as Valdez are allowed to
develop a friendly relationship with him
if he becomes attached to an unapproved
person they are required to discourage
this however they can after containment
procedures were established Valdez and
his team set to work putting together
tests that would use Cameron's emotions
and desires to save people in order to
develop and strengthen his abilities for
the first test they deliberately exposed
Cameron to a d-class that believed him
to be a valuable hostage one that he
could use to escape from the foundation
the d-class abducted Cameron at knife
point but Cameron quickly used his
reality bending ability to turn the
knife into chocolate and escape the
knife remained chocolate and did not
turn back to metal indicating his powers
had grown stronger details of events
that followed this test have been
redacted from the official file but a
note from a member of the OverWatch
Council provides a peek into what might
have happened
scp-2241 has stated that it intends to
grow stronger to stop more people from
dying and this will help both it and Us
in this aim killing a man with a
teleported bullet was a stroke of
tactical genius from the SCP object MTF
Theta 17 will be ready to respond during
all further rounds of testing as a
precaution following a series of tests
Each of which included heightened
emotional Stakes such as threatening the
lives of innocent bystanders or
treasured items belonging to scp-2241
his abilities developed even further in
one test a series of armed drones were
made to artificially malfunction posing
an apparent threat to Foundation
Personnel around the boy he responded by
using his telekinesis to turn the drones
on each other crashing them into one
another while only one drone remained he
teleported its Weaponry to a nearby
Field leaving a harmless shell behind in
another test a bomb was detonated near a
member of d-class personnel the boy
somehow absorbed the energy of the bomb
as it exploded transforming its kinetic
energy and saving the man's life another
bomb related test featured man with a
bomb strapped to him attacking a d-class
in this test it was ordered that the
bomber be taken alive Cameron responded
by teleporting the bomb vest into an
explosion-proof containment chamber and
knocking the bomber unconscious with a
single punch though his tiny fish should
not have been capable of delivering such
a strong blow in another test a third
bomb was placed in
scp-2241's chamber among his personal
belongings including some stuffed
animals and comic books he was very
upset at this discovery and teleported
the bomb high up into the sky where it
detonated harmlessly he remained upset
for a while after repeating no one can
take my things it's not fair I'm strong
I'm the Crusader moving on from bombs
the research team tasked the boy with
stealing a box from a foundation bank
vault which had been modified for extra
security he teleported himself into the
Vault picked up the box and then made a
mistake he tripped the sensors inside
however he somehow slowed the sensors
down and was able to teleport himself
back out of the Vault before the alarm
could sound this was the first task
given to Cameron that could be perceived
as morally gray or even villainous but
he performed it without question and
this was recorded as a notable
development next a surprised long-range
attack was performed on the foundation
Side by a foundation-owned robotic
mortar 2241 became angry catching the
bomb and throwing it toward the launcher
at a speed that appeared to be
approximately 1.4 times the speed of
sound it was noted that his abilities
were less focused and his demeanor more
violent when he was angry he turned to
an observing researcher and said I hate
them I'm a foundation Avenger and I hate
the bad guys and I'm gonna fight them
all for the final test in this series 2D
classes were described to 2241 as
civilians were held at gunpoint in rooms
with bulletproof glass windows he was
told that the guns could not be affected
by his powers the hostages needed
physical contact to be teleported to
safety and he needed to rescue them both
before they were killed shocking the
research team he split into two versions
of himself each teleporting a hostage to
safety before returning to the crime
scene to subdue the bad guys he reported
feeling a bit sick afterwards but had no
other adverse effects from splitting
himself into two people by the time this
series of tests were completed he was
able to teleport objects as well as his
own body duplicate himself see a few
seconds into the future and move or
transform objects within a distance of
12 meters he was excited about these
improvements referring to them as
leveling up following these tests Valdez
planned to pause the psychiatric
treatment of scp-2241 in favor of a more
Hands-On approach the plan was to begin
neurological testing using a surgically
implanted chip that would monitor the
boy's brain activity during combat the
Ethics Committee caught wind of this and
immediately intervened they temporarily
revoked valdez's security clearance and
placed him under investigation they
submitted an official report on this
decision which read implanting a
monitoring chip into a child this young
cannot be done without significant
developmental damage in later years this
will cause catastrophic problems for
both the child and long-term containment
given his well-developed capabilities
additionally deploying a child in combat
even under testing conditions violates
all moral Norms Personnel involved in
sweeping the previous rapid fire our
tests under the rug are under review the
testing and research surrounding
scp-2241 did not only draw the attention
of the Ethics Committee but it also
caused Discord within the OverWatch
Council itself following the Ethics
Committee intervention 05-3 ordered that
testing be resumed writing these tests
are more important than one SCP
regardless of essay it looks like
ankinda long-term containment and
observation is no longer a priority
given the utility of data we have
collected via intensive testing in the
short term the risk of the SCP breaching
containment is minimal given its loyalty
we now know which parts of the brain
deal with certain anomalous abilities
with small detail we can see how we may
even learn how to induce these abilities
and we will definitely learn how to
neutralize them two other members of the
council were horrified by this statement
believing that it won against decency
and morality in a way that could not be
justified o5-4 submitted a statement
this is too far we cannot let this stand
as president this is but one step
removed from Child soldiers and even
less removed from militarizing an SCP
level object an emergency council
meeting was called to address this
internal disagreement and the majority
voted in favor of reinstating testing
and exonerating Valdez of all ethics
violations I believe the results will
Justify both the risks and the means
we're closer than ever to understanding
the mechanism by which human brains
interact with extra normal phenomena the
emotional and eventual neurological
damage to scp-2241 is unfortunate but it
is also necessary for the advancement of
our understanding in addition due to the
new modification of the monitoring
Hardware 2241 can be neutralized quickly
should it become a threat at any time
after the surgery and so the protests of
the Ethics Committee were ignored the
concerned members of the OverWatch
Council overruled and Valdez was allowed
to resume his plan for test testing and
preparing to craft a super powered child
into a weapon and all the while a little
boy named Cameron remained the test
subject of the SCP Foundation still
dreaming of the day when he might have a
chance to save the world the SCP
Foundation is responsible for containing
some of the most dangerous forces in the
world without them we'd be at the mercy
of the plague doctor walking through the
world and killing with a touch anyone
could be snapped up by scp-106 and
dragged to a painful death in his pocket
Dimension Lair there would be no one to
stop as cp682 from devouring all living
things in sight and no one to hold back
the dreaded Scarlet King from breaching
our world and destroying Life as we know
it we owe them a lot for sure and
they've earned at least a thank you card
and an Edible Arrangement but containing
the anomalies of the world comes at a
pretty steep cost they're essentially
fighting a war against a whole host of
world-ending entities and when you're at
War there are bound to be casualties for
some people and creatures out there the
most terrifying monster isn't 096 just
trying to swallow them whole for looking
at its face or 173 just waiting for them
to turn their backs so it can snap their
neck for the unfortunates that find
themselves in the wrong place at the
wrong time the scariest monster in the
world is the SCP Foundation itself a
decade ago the SCP Foundation was
attempting to recapture
scp-682 which had breached containment
and was tearing its way through the
southern Congo region unable to contain
the monster by other means and desperate
to stop it from killing any more
civilians the foundation decided to
implement some rather Extreme Measures
they deployed a variety of chemical
agents and poisonous gases in an attempt
to slow the creature down but they had
no effect as the enormous reptile
stomped its way toward a nearby River
with a highly populated Village waiting
on the other side the foundation made
the decision to take things up a notch
they launched an aerial strike deploying
several aircrafts to drop explosives on
the area around the river they destroyed
large portions of the riverbank but the
environmental impact was considered to
be a necessary evil When the Smoke
finally cleared and the deafening Roars
of the Beast had gone quiet they stopped
their bombing campaign and dispatched
Foundation operatives to the scene there
they found the bones of scp-682 which
were quickly brought into custody before
the creature could begin to heal itself
the mission was considered a success and
they were ready to pull out all of their
staff and head back to the nearest
Foundation site when one officer spotted
something floating in the nearby River
it looked like a group of human corpses
face down in the water their bodies
badly burned concerned that civilians
from a nearby Village had been
inadvertently present for the bombing
campaign a team of officers was sent to
investigate the river closely what they
found was not a group of dead humans but
something else entirely they were all
along the riverbank and floating in the
water approximately 212 specimens of a
previously unknown humanoid species the
bodies were clustered in groups of three
to five appearing to belong to the same
family unit or social group many of them
were frozen in positions of fear or
attempt to defend themselves with some
observing Personnel comparing them to
the victims of the Pompeii eruption
stuck in their final terrified moments
what appeared to be parents and children
held on to each other some covered their
faces others lay in a fetal position it
seemed that they had known something was
coming to kill them but they did not
have the time or the understanding
necessary to escape it several of the
bodies were removed from the river for
autopsy and examination in order to
understand more about this new possibly
already extinct species they were
humanoid organisms with an
indeterminable genus and species they
resume humbled tall thin humans with
absolutely no body hair and elongated
limbs the most unusual aspect of the
creatures was in their mouths their
teeth were serrated and sharp resembling
those of a crocodile in spite of these
monstrous teeth an autopsy revealed that
there was no human flesh present in any
of the creature's stomachs instead
suggesting a diet of fish livestock and
whatever else they could peacefully
scavenge every last corpse was removed
from the area and incinerated to prevent
any civilians from coming across them
and asking questions just when the
foundation Personnel were finally
packing up and getting ready to leave
the river once and for all they heard
something it was a mournful sound
something between a man bellowing and a
wild animal yelping in pain something
nearby was still very much alive and it
was screaming the officers followed the
sound and spotted one surviving specimen
of the crocodile people lying along the
bank the River it was holding its face
in its hands curled up into a ball near
the water and it was wailing in agony
there were no visible injuries on the
creature's body but it was clearly
extremely distressed one officer
attempted to approach the creature
calling out to it that he meant no harm
and wanted to get it some medical
attention and looked up at the officer
with wide eyes and its cries went quiet
the officer grabbed his weapon afraid
that the creature might suddenly Rush
him but instead it ran into the river he
jumped into the water plunging beneath
the surface and began thrashing around
after a moment of watching its struggle
the officer realized what was happening
the creature was trying to drown itself
the abandoned protocol completely at
that moment diving into the water and
pulling the struggling creature back to
shore it coughed up water for several
minutes all the while trying to crawl
back into the water when the creature
had finally calmed down it was brought
into Foundation custody with no further
resistance it appeared to be the last
Living member of whatever strange human
crocodile hybrid species was living in
that River and it was designated
scp-6415 since it was brought into
Foundation custody
scp-6415's Behavior has been largely
very consistent some scps are constantly
attempting to escape from their
containment or killing an endless
revolving door of d-class personnel but
6415 is not one of those anomalies it is
not aggressive in spite of its
crocodilian characteristics and it's
content to eat the food provided by the
foundation it is fed a diet of raw meat
mostly beef and goat which is provided
fresh daily the foundation was curious
to see if the creature could be pushed
to be aggressive if its circumstances
were made a little less comfortable they
deprived it of food for several days but
it did not seem to notice or even care
much aside from occasionally looking at
the door to see if new food had come
they tried sleep deprivation next
blaring a loud siren sound over for the
speakers in the containment chamber
anytime the creature was observed lying
down or closing its eyes it became
listless and visibly exhausted but did
not act out violently at this either
after this testing its ordinary feeding
and sleep schedule was resumed for the
most part all that
scp-6415 does is eat and sleep there is
however one notable exception at random
intervals
scp-6415 will begin to cry sobbing
intensely and appearing to be in a state
of overwhelming distress its cries are
so loud that they can be heard from
several Halls away and have caused
hearing damage and Personnel in the room
with it there is no way to stop the
Creature From Crying once it has started
though providing it with a hot cup of
tea a soft blanket or a hug from a
particularly Brave and eager d-class has
caused it to cry a bit more quietly once
it is finished crying after several
hours of non-stop weeping it'll lie down
on the ground and not cry anymore for
weeks at a time for a time
scp-6415 was considered to be lacking
human intelligence and its containment
procedures were changed to reflect that
it was held in the standard humanoid
containment chamber in the light
containment wing of site 619 with
soundproof walls because it displayed no
threatening behavior it was considered
unnecessary to have any guards placed
outside 6415s chamber however after
incident
6415-01 the foundation's understanding
of the creature changed dramatically the
incident occurred when several d-class
Personnel were sent into 6415's
containment chamber to feed it and they
found a harrowing sight on the wall of
the chamber The Entity had scratched a
message with its fingernails its
fingertips were bloodied and torn its
hands noticeably wounded from what must
have been a great deal of effort it did
not acknowledge the Personnel that
entered the room instead it just sat on
the floor
staring at its work on the wall cradling
its injured hands and crying its
shoulders shook with the force of its
sobs and its tears fell to the ground
pooling around it the d-class Personnel
were later unable to report what they
had seen without beginning to cry
themselves but eventually calmed down
enough to report what the creature had
written please bring them back it was a
desperate plea for the foundation to
somehow reunite it with its lost family
they had previously thought the creature
to be a simple animal incapable of
understanding its own reality or
communicating through clear language
this proved that the creature understood
very well what had happened to it and
was feeling the loss of its loved ones
fully one d-class officer noticed a
scrap of paper likely a piece of butcher
paper from one of the creature's
previous meals with a picture drawn on
it it was a crude sketch but its subject
was easily recognizable it was the
southern Congo River where 6415 was
first discovered with three features
splashing in the water the largest one
resembled as cp6415 and it was swimming
alongside a slightly smaller adult of
its species and a much smaller creature
that appeared to be a juvenile of the
same species context clues indicated
that this was a drawing of
scp-6415's family its partner and their
child at first the foundation
researchers were uncertain who exactly
the creature was referring to in its
initial message but this drawing made it
perfectly clear it wanted its family
back it is uncertain whether or not the
creature is aware that its family is
dead but it clearly feels their absence
just the same and believes the
foundation might have the power to end
its suffering Foundation Personnel who
were exposed to the details of the
incident became inconsolable falling
into a deep bout of depression brought
on by a sense of Shame and
responsibility when counseling sessions
proved ineffective the emotionally
affected staff were given amnestics to
wipe their memory of the incident and of
6415 altogether one employee research
assistant Cheryl Cruz attempted to
release the creature from its
containment insisting that it deserved
to roam free however when she opened the
door to its containment facility the
creature made no move to leave it just
stared at her tears in its eyes as if it
knew that it had nowhere else to go
research assistant Cruz was given a
powerful amnestic and relieved of her
position at the foundation her current
whereabouts are unknown in order to
prevent any more Reckless Behavior from
sympathetic staff the message scratched
into the wall was painted over and the
sketch recovered from its chamber was
destroyed but even if the memories and
evidence of the creature's pain are gone
anyone walking by its chamber can still
hear it weeping it is uncertain what the
containment procedures for
scp-6415 will become it is not simply an
animal and clearly understands language
though it appears to be incapable of
speech if it could talk whatever it said
would surely be heartbreaking for now
the entity remains in itself serving as
a grim reminder of the guilt that weighs
on the foundation's conscience no matter
what they do with 6415 they cannot take
back what they did they cannot lift the
weight of the creature's grief or bring
back its lost family it is the Lone
Survivor sitting in its foundation's
cell weeping for its broken heart and
begging the foundation for the one thing
it can never do bring them back the SCP
Foundation is no stranger to containing
dangerous entities capable of Taking
Lives without discretion but some of
those entities aren't just Mindless
monsters they're people with feelings
and desires stuck in an unfortunate
circumstance granted unnatural abilities
by fate or chance for a lot of human
anomalies contained by the foundation
it's not a stretch to say that they most
likely wish they were ordinary like
anyone else that they didn't have to be
locked up in a containment cell for the
rest of their lives as the years have
gone by the foundation much like any
organization has changed a lot more
facilities have pushed for ethical and
Humane treatment of anomalies some going
so far as to integrate safe anomalies
into the command structure of the
organization itself with groups such as
the Ethics Committee keeping the
foundation's most Hardline normalcy
supremacists from mistreating or
mishandling the objects that are
supposed to contain it's hard to imagine
that anything would slip by the ever
watchful eye of the foundation's
surveillance network but in an
organization this large incidents are
still bound to happen while anomalies
can be dangerous the foundation as a
whole backs the ideal then they should
be given ethical treatment at least as
much as they can afford for safer less
dangerous anomalies this is a lot easier
to enforce to suggest Rehabilitation
efforts and recreational privileges to
be given to an anomaly capable of ending
human life at a moment's notice raises a
lot more eyebrows even in the most
Progressive sex of the foundation that
line becomes blurred when dealing with
intelligent entities what defines
intelligence sapiens what distinguishes
as cp682 the indestructible lizard with
a massive disgust for all life from
scp-239 and ultimately innocent little
girl with world breaking reality bending
Powers this is the sort of argument that
divides the upper ranks of the
foundation is the integration of these
anomalies the answer or should they be
sealed away forever should they be
uniformly treated as monsters and freaks
unfit to ever leave their cells aside
from being used in testing fortunately
for the anomaly rights activists in the
crowd the modern Foundation is much more
lenient than it had been in decades past
as research has proven that even
dangerous anomalies when given friendly
treatment and basic right are more
compliant happy and feel less Strife
about their situation they can even be
useful in some situations take
scp-5595 a sentient sarcastic gumball
machine located at site 322 whose
affinity for mathematics and harmless
nature earned it a position at the
site's accounting department as part of
a larger Foundation initiative called
the integration program which focused on
integrating harmless anomalies into the
site itself in fact
scp-5595's accounting skills were so
great that it reduced site 322 spending
costs overall and opened the higher-ups
to the idea of integrating more
anomalies across the organization if you
need another example as cp999 the
adorable orange blob lovingly nicknamed
the Tickle Monster has been used as a
therapy object at site 19 for years but
there is one side of the debate that
Spurs more controversy than any other
using anomalies as Living Weapons the
foundation is long abided by the
directive that its objects are to be
contained and studied instead of used in
the field as an uncontrollable object is
more dangerous outside of a cell than in
but the directive has changed especially
in recent times the chaos Insurgency one
of the foundation's greatest foes
utilizes anomalies As Weapons to achieve
their goals as do many other groups of
interest when trained human soldiers
just aren't enough to contend with all
the enemies the foundation deals with
it's no wonder they begin to explore
other options and that's what brings us
to the subject of today's video The Tale
of
scp-4793 an anomaly trained as a
brutalizing soldier who never really
wanted to fight this is the story of
Andrew Cleese a warrior with a blazing
Savage Fury in his body but with a
gentle tender longing in his heart it
all started during a foundation raid on
a chaos Insurgency operation located in
a mount cave in the southern region of
Greece the deadly Insurgency always on
the prowl for more anomalous weapons to
use in its unending battle against the
foundation had hired a team of
mercenaries to scour the region for
potential anomalous activity they came
across something buried in the mountains
they were certain was anomalous and
after communicating with their superiors
decided to dig it up and see what it was
about naturally word of such a discovery
travels fast and with how many
Undercover operatives the foundation
keeps embedded inside the Insurgency in
order to keep tabs on what their enemies
are doing it's no surprise that the
foundation mobilized its forces to get
the drop on whatever this anomalous
excavation site was the mission was
simple enough MTF Upsilon 11 nicknamed
Avalon's wake a team of combat
Specialists led by the skilled Captain
Holly Shore would infiltrate their camp
and seize any anomalous objects in The
mercenary's Possession getting past the
relatively unguarded entrance was a
cakewalk the task force took out a
single guard and were able to slip
deeper into the cave undetected inside
they found a massive pit surrounded by
colorful stalagmites and flowing
waterfalls at the center of the pit next
to a smattering of camping supplies and
bright floodlights was a large Stone
Steely a type of pillar most often used
in ancient times that would be carved
with important messages or Stories the
details were grainy from a distance but
the team could make out an engraved
image of a Spartan hoplite soldier on
the pillar surrounding the Steely were
five mercenaries armed and in the
process of digging out the pillar from
Beneath The Rock Captain Shore knew that
this was most likely the big object the
chaos Insurgency were after she and her
team took cover waiting for the
opportune moment to strike but their
weight wasn't long one of the
mercenaries shoveling the ground near
the Steely let out a scream they had cut
themselves splattering a small amount of
Blood on the stone monument The
Mercenaries panicked readying their
they weren't sure what was going to
happen next but with enough experience
in the field they knew that introducing
an anomaly to human blood often had
severe consequences and their suspicions
were proven correct a flash of light
surrounded the cave and from the Steely
emerged a warrior clad in the same armor
as the Spartan soldier engraved on The
Monuments carving The Entity was clearly
confused and asked in English if the
mercenary spoke Greek instead they
thrust their guns forward screaming at
the soldier to not move the soldier was
compliant but one of the mercenaries
feeling it to be a cruel way to
establish dominance over their new
anomalous toy shot at the soldiers
exposed leg what happened next was a
whirlwind of swearing blood and combat
The Mercenaries opened fire on the
soldier who retaliated back by using
powerful hand-to-hand combat for
whatever reason bullets just couldn't
seem to harm the soldier he tanked
dozens of open shots across his body the
rounds deflecting off his armor as the
soldier picked up a mercenary by the
throat the Kevlar vest he was wearing
suddenly flung itself from the man's
body and integrated itself onto the
Soldier's armor the mercenary
immediately recognized this as one of
the soldiers anomalous abilities but was
powerless to stop it as it was slammed
against the stone wall falling to the
ground the foundation task force watched
in awe as the soldier took out each of
the mercenaries one by one Captain Shore
seeing that the soldier was continually
begging The Mercenaries to stop shooting
at it the entire time sense that there
was a peaceful Humane side to the entity
a stark contrast to the acts of
brutality it used to dispatch The
Mercenaries Shore told her men to move
forward but with their weapons lowered
the soldier holding on to a knife it
grabbed earlier stood on guard but
surrendered without question when he
realized the foundation operatives were
not there to fight him Captain Shore
introduced herself and her men as part
of the foundation and the soldier
clearly upset and distraught over the
Carnage he caused introduced himself as
Andrew glis the team promised Andrew
Cleese they would take him somewhere
safe and he complied little would he
know that his journey with the
foundation was just beginning Andrew
Cleese was given the designation as CP
4793 an initial assessment found him to
be anomalously strong with the ability
to integrate any solid material into a
weapon either as a piece of armor like
it did with the mercenaries Kevlar vest
or as a weapon itself such as turning
the steel leg of a chair into a
sharpened sword though this ability did
have its limits as Ender Clay's had
difficulty incorporating firearms and
complex Electronics As Weapons or armor
on top of that
scp-4793 was extremely durable and able
to heal any wounds on its body almost
instantaneously coupled with its highly
trained fighting skills and raging Fury
Andrew Cleese was a true warrior capable
of great power and might but his Wild
Side seemed to disappear when the heat
of battle died down one of site 20's
senior researchers Dr Fitzpatrick was
tasked with interviewing
scp-4793 weekly and she discovered that
scp-4793 had a completely different
element to his personality he was
intelligent kind gentle and hated
fighting he couldn't remember much of
his life from thousands of years ago but
he knew that he was a great warrior who
caused mass destruction with his power
alone Andrew Cleese didn't want to be
someone like that he had an interest in
history in books and learning why he
woke up what the world was like now and
why it had changed Andrew Cleese wanted
to know why there were metal birds in
the sky and Horseless chariots on the
ground Dr Fitzpatrick found him to be a
remarkable person and commended
scp-4793's Behavior with access to
various literature and history books so
he could learn about the things he
desperately wanted to know but most of
all she was taken back by how averse he
was to be becoming his past self a
heartless Warrior who killed
indiscriminately it seemed as if Andrew
Cleese was so traumatized by his past
actions that he sealed away those
memories to forget about them as best he
could but site 20's director Jack
Hargrave saw Andrew Cleese as a mere
tool something he could use to achieve a
nefarious goal he had been planning for
a long long time Hargraves wanted to use
scp-4793's raw power to benefit the
foundation from his office he sat back
Imagining the Unstoppable force that a
trained Ender Cleese would be if he
could force him to fight and he knew he
could then the foundation would have a
deadly weapon in their hands something
that would surely even the odds between
the chaos Insurgency and those other
pesky groups of Interest director
Hargraves forced scp-4793 to train his
combat abilities in a variety of
sparring sessions with Captain Shore the
task force Captain who discovered him in
the mountains Hargraves regimen was
brutal and he often threatened to blow
up the explosive colors on
scp-4793's neck and wrists if he held
back against Shore or disobeyed his
orders Andrew Cleese could take the
explosion but Shore would surely be
caught in the blast killing her
andracles hated hard rays but cared
about Shore who showed him kindness and
understood his difficult position over
the next two years enderclees would
train weekly with Shore sparring with
each other using a variety of weapons
from swords to Firearms
scp-4793 still held back not wanting to
fight and wanting even less to
accidentally injure Holly Shore who he
was growing to see as a friend in the
meantime Dr Fitzpatrick continued to
interview
scp-4793 weekly also growing a
friendship with the entity but for as
much as she cared about Ender Cleese she
couldn't help him the way she wanted to
Hargraves was set on making
scp-4793 a functional weapon
and he was growing impatient waiting for
results Hargraves was pushing Andrew
Cleese Beyond his comfort zone switching
up his sparring partners from Shore we
trusted deeply to other individuals or
changing what weapons he had to use
Andrew Cleese hated this not because he
was scared to fight but because he was
anxious about what he could become if he
let loose he never wanted to be the
monster that he knew he was capable of
being he never wanted to hurt someone in
the meantime Hargraves began to have
doubts about Andrew Cleese his humanity
and reluctance would slow him down in
the field keep him from being the
perfect super soldier Hargraves wanted
him to be so he began development on
another project codenamed x06 this
mysterious weapons program was kept
Under Wraps Limited in knowledge to only
Hargraves and his most trusted men if he
couldn't have Andrew Cleaves he would
simply have to do better and he knew he
would while Hargraves worked in the
shadow
the scp-4793 research team uncovered a
section of Andrew clee's past that he
had forgotten the Steely he was trapped
inside had an inscription on its front
written in ancient Greek when it was
translated and sent to Dr Fitzpatrick
this is what it read gather around me
children I will tell you the story of
sweet and replace Fierce as a pride of
lions and as cunning as a pack of wolves
he lived for nothing but battle he was
beloved by his countrymen and feared by
his enemies so much so that Ares himself
strolled down from Olympus to challenge
him to single combat for 10 days they
fought a terrible duel their blades
cutting Earth into islands and the
Sparks turning mountains into forges for
Hephaestus impressed he granted Andrew
Cleese a boon so long as he fought he
would never know defeat or age and by
mixing his Igor with Andrew Clay's blood
aerys declared him kin to the gods
themselves as he came to bear on the
world he met his match in a woman from a
distant land with skin of white as sand
covered in Blues from the ocean she
blazed in his eyes like helios's Chariot
together the mountains bowed before them
but even as eros's Arrow brought them
together an arrow split them apart for
jealous Aries saw his favored love
something other than himself with his
guiding star gone and turkeys tore the
bones of the Earth itself with his rage
and lust for battle extinguished he
turned the battlefield into twin
mountains with his purpose lost he was
in Thunder forevermore Andrew Cleese was
shaken by the revelations of his Warrior
past and in the present he couldn't
shake the feelings that Captain Shore
reminded him of his past lover the
feeling was so strong that during a
sparring session Andrew Cleese passed
out overwhelmed by how much she reminded
him of her the woman who he remembered
to be his wife Arabelle Andrew Cleese
continued to confide in Dr Fitzpatrick
about his feelings about Captain Shore
and especially about fighting for the
foundation he didn't understand this
strange new world or what exactly he
would be fighting for and the stories he
heard about previous attempts to utilize
anomalous soldiers in battle terrified
him the story of scp-076 Abel killing
his entire Task Force Team after losing
control haunted him at night he never
wanted to become that but hargraves's
secret project reached its completion
before Andrew Cleese could be molded
into the perfect Warrior little did
Hargraves know however that Fitzpatrick
was keeping tabs on all of his Shady
behavior in hopes of one day exposing
him for the monster that he was to the
Ethics Committee or maybe even the
overseer Council still she took the job
wanting to see what monstrosity
Hargraves had created as a result of his
experiments Fitzpatrick was shocked to
see it hargrave's secret experiment was
a black winged clawed creature with way
too many teeth from behind its
containment cylinder it grinned and
chuckled an inhuman life Hargraves was
truly creating monsters as Hargraves
explained the creature had near human
intelligence and could reproduce
asexually meaning all it took was one of
them for it to multiply with this new
anomaly he could revolutionize the
foundation's ways of Waging War a
perfect Soldier one that wouldn't be
held back by human emotion Fitzpatrick
voiced her concern but was cut short by
Hargraves suddenly panicking he noticed
that there was only one x06 entity in
the cylinder when he was sure there were
two and suddenly from the ceiling one of
the entities fell to the ground flapping
its wings and screaming in the
researchers faces the worst had happened
the x06 entities had broken free and if
they weren't stopped soon they would run
rampant to oversight 20. the two fled
for safety but the horrifying creature
chased after them Andrew Cleese and
Captain Shore soon learned of the
Containment Breach as well after their
sparring session was cut short by a
creature breaking into the room Andrew
Cleese made short work of it but it was
too late site-20 was overrun with
Hargraves as beasts there were hundreds
of them and those numbers would continue
to grow they infiltrated the entire
facility leaving Andrew Cleese and
Captain Shore with one option to fight
Andrew Cleese didn't want to do it but
this was different he needed to be a
hero and save the people still trapped
in site-20s facilities it would have to
use Force but if he was helping others
then it was justified he reluctantly
told himself still he hated it as
Captain Shore and her task force as well
as
scp-4793 moved through site-20 taking
out one entity after another Andrew
Cleese realized how hopeless the
situation was looking there were simply
too many of them they needed to focus
their efforts on getting people out of
the site rather than hoping to fight
While most Personnel were slaughtered in
the Carnage at the site's d-class block
the team found a holdout of guards and
d-class who were conveniently relocated
to an above ground elevator that could
escort them safely out of the site
Andrew Cleese made the decision there to
let Captain Shore and her men as well as
the survivors get to the surface where
he would stay below and fight he didn't
want to do it but Andrew Cleese had a
plan Shore didn't want to leave him
behind but she had no choice after
parting In the Heat of an x06 ambush on
the Block Andrew Cleese was alone while
the survivors were on the surface
fighting without holding back andracles
tore through hundreds of x06 entities
going deeper and deeper into the sight
his plan was dangerous but it would save
everyone at the expense of his own life
hendrickley's knew how dangerous those
x06 entities could be if they were let
loose into the world and that was why he
decided he would blow up sight 20's
reactor destroying both himself
the site and every single creature as he
was about to do just that Andrew Cleese
found director Hargraves in the rubble
of the reactor room Hargrave was heavily
wounded and Andrew Cleese felt such rage
and anger towards the man especially
when he revealed that the x06 creatures
were genetically engineered from
androgly's own blood but he didn't hurt
him he was better than the monster
Hargrave saw him as instead
hendrickley's set hard Graves up on the
elevator to the surface knowing that the
overseer Council would serve a far worse
punishment than he ever could before
blowing up the reactor Andrew Cleese
recorded one last message he addressed
it to Holly Shore the captain who had
shown him so much kindness I was born to
a farmer and grew into a warrior I
battled Aries to a standstill I won War
single-handedly then I met my wife we
were set to claim the world to Immortals
who wanted to bring a chaotic World some
semblance of peace and then Aries killed
her and I lost everything and now I'm
here alone adrift a stranger surrounded
by even stranger things but within you I
see the spark I saw in her a burning
desire to make the world better it makes
me want to be better and I don't know if
you feel the same or whether I'll get
out of here but I will fight for you die
if I have to I love you and with that
Andrew Cleese one of the greatest
warriors the foundation had ever known
sacrificed his life to blow up site 20's
nuclear reactor destroying the facility
and saving the world from hargraves's
deadly creatures to those who knew him
especially Captain Shore he will never
be forgotten because true heroes never
really die the perfect childhood school
is out shoes are off you're sprinting
across the hot sandy beach smiling for
no apparent reason because back then you
didn't even need one did I mention
there's an orange cone on your head
where did it come from why is it there
what is the point do not think too
deeply about it there's no room for
symbolism in the summer there is no use
over analyzing the antics of teenage
youth it's just a cone and you're just a
kid doing things for no other reason
than that you want to you're busy living
doing your thing responsibility is still
years away such a pretty picture where
painting isn't it but this is SCP
explained so of course by now you
figured out this is all a misdirection
didn't you well here it comes watch
closely look at you run moving towards
nothing as if it means everything look
at that smile the wind whipping through
the Gap in your teeth soak it in into 20
years your face muscles will have
forgotten the movement look at you live
yes go on soak it in you will be chasing
this feeling your whole life while
moving further and further away from it
depressing isn't it we think so too but
here is the Silver Lining something
you'd be wise to celebrate at least you
have this moment to look back on the
memory is with you forever not everyone
is so lucky not everyone had a good
childhood furthermore not everyone even
has a childhood at all some live beyond
the expectations of age Imagine a 14
year old forced to be 40 that's not to
say they have to pay taxes or can run
for Senate no this level of force
maturity that I'm speaking of transcends
the scope of average adulthood so let's
not imagine a kid going through the
mundane life of a cubicle junkie filing
papers pretending to work and answering
phone calls instead let's do this
imagine a kid going to war imagine a kid
carrying out stealth assassination
missions imagine a kid being locked in
containment living with little human
interaction and freedom is all to say
imagine a kid not being a kid at all now
this is more like an SCP explained this
is the sad story of someone who had to
say goodbye to the joys of adolescents
earlier than anyone ever should have to
in fact they didn't even get to say
goodbye at all this is the story of
scp-105 now to be clear
scp-105 is not a bloodthirsty demon
living in the shadows it is not an
unsquishable spider dancing across your
hardwood floor mocking the soles of your
shoes as they stomp down with no success
it is not a grand piano in a hotel lobby
absorbing the DNA of all who touches its
keys and it is not a freezer that tempts
late night snackers to reach deeper and
deeper towards an Ever elusive hot fudge
sundae until they are sucked in frozen
solid sold for millions and displayed as
decorative ice sculptures atop the
center of punch bowls at parties for
Rich politicians no we'll just have to
get to those later on on a different day
because
scp-105 is just how do I put this a girl
yes a small unremarkable looking girl at
the time of acquisition she was just 1.5
meters tall and weighed 50 kilograms
even those of you listening with little
to no instinctual senses for converting
meters and kilograms to feet and pounds
can still understand this is no
frightful giant we're talking about
lining up a class by height she'd blend
in somewhere toward the middle and if
you look even closer beyond the shallow
surface of measurements and toward the
details of her face even still you won't
find a single Freckle to fear
scp-105 has blue eyes and blonde hair
nothing Coastal Californians haven't
seen a million times over just this
Monday formerly known as Iris Thompson
scp-105 has no discernible Oddities if
you saw her jumping rope you wouldn't
point and stare if you saw her at the
park playing with your children you
wouldn't pull them away and squeeze them
tight if you saw her walking toward you
on a sidewalk you wouldn't turn around
and run away in the other direction by
herself scp-105 is not too different
from anyone else no matter how close we
zoom in on her appearance personality or
her Tendencies there is nothing to see
that triggers alarms if you ask her to
spit fire she won't if you conduct a lab
experiment where she has to find the
exit of a maze using only her sense of
smell she will get lost and fail this is
all to say if you look too closely
through the microscope at scp-105 you
might miss her anomalous abilities
instead you'd be better off taking a
step back and just watching her live her
life and that is all that she wanted to
do live her life is that so much to ask
the first thing you will notice is that
she isn't alone and like in any good
buddy buddy film her counterpart reveals
more to her character so who is standing
by her side who is the co co-star of
this film that pushes our protagonist
into the foundation Spotlight well it's
no person at all it's a camera her
camera
scp-105-b is a Polaroid one-step Express
manufactured in 1982. it does not appear
to have any out of the ordinary physical
characteristics and appears to be for
all intents and purposes a normal
Polaroid camera operating as expected
for all persons aside from
scp-105 when you point it at a subject
they don't get sucked into the lens The
Flash can't blind an army of soldiers
when you say cheese it doesn't shoot out
a brick of cheddar the camera is nothing
more than a camera that is until it's in
the hands of Iris Thompson what's more
unique than the camera itself are the
photographs it produces when scp-105
holds a photograph taken by
scp-105-b the picture changes from a
still shot to that of a real-time image
of the person location or object
photographed regardless of the subject
of the photograph the image will convert
itself into what appears to be a
handheld live stream of whatever was
pictured imagine a photograph of a
waterfall if held by a cp105 you do not
just see the image of a waterfall but
you will physically see the water
falling splashing down onto the Rocks
below it is similar to holding your cell
phone and watching a gif however instead
of just watching iris is able to
interact with it in a way Beyond any
technology has ever allowed
scp-105 is then able to move her arm
through and into the photograph and
manipulate objects Within Reach of the
original point at which the photograph
was first taken Yes you heard me right
scp-105-2 doesn't just offer Iris quick
prints of memories it gives her much
more granting her access to a new
dimension although this is clearly a
unique situation for Iris it doesn't
mean that iris is the only one affected
by this anomaly when she engages with
the photographs it actually affects the
world attached to them that is to say
there are consequences to her actions
every photograph she has ever taken is
essentially a portal to a world of
problems Witnesses who have been on the
other side of the photograph while
scp-105 was manipulating it reported
seeing her hand reaching out from an
invisible portal and carrying on
whatever actions she pleases once her
arm is inside the photograph she has the
freedom to control the image as she
wishes this ability has obvious benefits
for anyone imagine being able to carry
around with you a photograph of your
oven then whenever you get that paranoid
feeling that you forgot to turn it off
you can reach into the Polaroid and turn
the dial how you please but the peace of
mind is just a small benefit of this
power and it's easy to assume that
anyone would be tempted to use their
abilities from far more than just
controlling at home appliances while on
vacation the foundation specifically
concerns itself with bigger more
ambitious uses of anomalous power and
the power in this case wasn't just in
the camera while 105-b helps Iris use
her powers most efficiently she is still
able to manipulate objects through
photographs taken by other cameras
though not quite as well as when she's
using her favorite camera noting that
105-b and the photographs taken by said
camera have no unusual properties when
used by any other person except for
scp-105 it was clear to the foundation
who the greater anomaly in the situation
really was the tool wasn't of their
interest but rather the person wielding
it but how did this all come to their
attention is the foundation really
investigating the life of a girl playing
with a camera in her bedroom while some
moments are just too big to be bound by
privacy
scp-105 was brought to the Forefront of
the foundation's attention shortly after
the murder of her boyfriend promptly
after his death the police investigated
the scene and looked for answers and
when looking for answers they started
Conjuring up questions one of which put
Iris at the center of their search where
were you her response wasn't so
straightforward she wasn't there but
then she was the police pressed further
not understanding
scp-105 explained that she was at home
but once she learned of his death she
hurried over to him this left the police
even more suspicious as there was no way
she could have been informed of the
Murder By an outside Source she must
have been there all along seeing the
skepticism in their faces
scp-105 scrambled for an explanation she
took a deep breath and got her story
straight she claimed to have been on the
phone with her boyfriend at the time of
the violent attack and once she heard
the commotion it prompted her to hurry
over to his location where she saw him
dead this excuse made logical sense and
so the police dropped their suspicion
after all Iris was just a small innocent
teenager however just as quickly as the
police move on from Iris they returned
to her this time with tangible proof of
their doubts the telephone records did
not correspond to her story she was
never on the phone with her boyfriend
that night it was then that scp-105 had
to confess she informed her lawyer that
she had in fact been there for the
murder well not there but kind of there
she explained how she witnessed the
murder through a photograph she had
taken with her boyfriend several days
prior the attorney in question
disregarded the story and recommended
that the subject plead guilty Iris
however refused to do so she was
sticking to her truth no matter how
crazy it made her seem she went forward
and told her story in court it was met
with derision the judge and the jury
didn't even entertain the possibility of
any of it being true Iris was flustered
she was a young teenage girl fighting
for her Freedom her only weapon being
the truth but the room wasn't
participating in her reality they
dismissed her as crazy and so when Iris
offered to demonstrate her ability it
was the last straw the judge wouldn't
allow Iris to waste any more of anyone's
time she was she was sentenced to a
psychiatric ward Iris was determined to
get out of there she knew she didn't
belong luckily someone else Knew Too
that she didn't belong and because of
this in a matter of days she was out of
there but home wasn't where she was
heading no it wasn't mom and dad picking
her up from the psychiatric ward but
rather the foundation breaking her out
stealing her for themselves and bringing
her to site 17. there at site 17
Foundation Personnel began their mission
which started with trying to convince
scp-105 that they were on her side they
began by retrieving
scp-105-b from scp-105's home and
replacing it with an identical model
only then to give it to her under the
lie that it was the original the lies
wouldn't stop just there they'd continue
to pour over her reality until it was
impossible for her to recognize one from
the other
scp-105's parents was informed that she
was killed during the botched Escape of
another patient while both were in the
custody of a psychiatric care facility
in truth though the foundation wants
nothing more than to keep scp-105 alive
however they are not concerned about the
quality of her living Iris was a tool
for the foundation she was an asset she
was a secret weapon she had powers they
could have only dreamed of only now they
existed but before shooting their shiny
new weapon they needed to learn how to
use it properly but with what manual how
do you learn how to use another human
well having seen enough Marvel movies
they knew they would be better equipped
with knowledge if they understood her
origin story so they began questioning
Iris trying to get to the root cause of
her anomalous attitude she was either 10
or 11. she remembers because she was
looking at a picture of the ocean and
she noticed that the waves began moving
her parents said that she just had an
overactive imagination when she first
was able to move objects in the photos
she was 11 12 maybe her family took a
trip to the Grand Canyon she looked
through the photo album after they got
home and she brushed her hand up against
one by accident when she did she pushed
a rock over the edge falling into the
canyon she could actually hear it
clatter on the way down she became
fascinated with photography after that
most of the time it didn't work with
photographs she took but her parents got
her a Polaroid one-step Express camera
that she'd been begging them for since
Christmas after she got the camera the
photos got easier to interact with after
hearing her story the researchers made
her an offer she'd be allowed certain
freedoms if she agreed to use her powers
to do them a few favors she could at
least in some capacity act her age
socialize and do things a girl her grade
would normally do but in exchange she
had to First do things that nobody any
age should ever have to do Iris agreed
and it was in this agreement that we see
just how desperate she was during her
childhood she was willing to risk
everything for something as small as a
quick conversation with a guard five
minutes of jump rope or simply a few
minutes spent under the sun she was
assigned to be part of Mobile task force
omega-7 to carry out a wide range of
missions and if the fate of the first
humanoid SCP recruited to mobile task
force omega-7 was any indication how
this might play out Iris was in a lot of
trouble the Pandora's Box initiative had
a history of failure their previous
efforts under team able ended in the
death of absolutely everyone however
team Iris began on a more hopeful note
They carried out different missions than
team able instead of violent attacks
their primary missions were
reconnaissance and intelligence
gathering however just because there
were no swords and blood drawn the
missions were not so harmless despite
team Iris carrying out over 20 jobs in
cooperation with the bow commission
swiftly and without incident their
streak eventually had to come to an end
the first disciplinary incident for
scp-105 involved the escalation of Team
Iris missions from reconnaissance to
assassinations yes this teenage girl
with not a violent bone in her body was
tasked to kill to kill not that her only
Power is that of manipulating photos in
her mind this is nothing more than a
party trick it was a gift she was born
with and she was always aware that it
was unique but never did she expect it
to be a curse she liked being able to
straighten books and photographs of
libraries she liked being able to read
into photos and hug her teddy bear that
she no longer has she liked being able
to help heal and embrace history not
alter it
scp-105 violently opposed the use of her
abilities to carry out assassinations
they wanted her to murder people and
like any girl of her nature would she
resisted but they kept pressing while
some teenage girls are pressured by
parents to play sports they don't
particularly care for this one was
pressured to kill during these events
scp-105 became emotionally distressed
and attempted to deceive Foundation
Personnel into believing that her
anomalous traits had disappeared she
claimed that she couldn't carry out the
missions anymore her doctor after
submitted a report recommending that
scp-105 be reclassified as neutralized
undergo amnestic treatment and be
released to the public with regular
monitoring after further investigation
the foundation realized the doctor was
prioritizing as cp105's emotional state
over the goals of the foundation they
had built a friendship he was the one
telling her to pretend not to have
powers anymore this was all found out
thus his recommendation to release Iris
was denied with nothing to lose at that
point the doctor even helped Iris try to
escape the foundation's custody but this
failed she was captured and the doctor
was promptly discharged at that point
Iris had to start over again to regain
the trust of the foundation and yet
another compromise she re-demonstrated
that her anomalous abilities in exchange
for the restoration of limited
privileges nothing more than
occasionally being allowed to jump rope
getting a lollipop every Thursday and
being informed of the recent Trends on
Tick Tock and so this is where
her to be continuously making sacrifices
in exchange for tiny teaspoons of
Teenage life all the while she is
growing older and older unfulfilled by
the years she passes and so while it is
easy to look back on our childhood with
lust and longing at least it was there
and is still there now safely stored in
our memory stored in the protection of
the past for Iris this is not so her
childhood is both behind her and in
front of her it is something she moved
on from too quickly and it is a future
she fights for every day even when she
is 97 gray decrepit and on her deathbed
she will be sacrificing her freedoms to
feel 15. and so we have to wonder is
scp-105 a danger to anyone at all I
leave you with a question are we more
likely to be attacked by a dog or the
master holding its leash it has been
often said that dog is man's best friend
and Avi obviously that isn't just
exclusive to men ask any pet owner
whether they own a dog cat rabbit
hamster or soul-sucking interdimensional
parasitic monster with too many
tentacles and they'll all tell you the
same your pet can be your best friend
they can give you the most unconditional
affectionate form of love possible and
as long as you treat your little buddy
right they'll be loyal to you for the
rest of your life and theirs it's not
uncommon for a pet to outlive their
owner especially if they belong to
someone who's elderly and that might be
a sad thing to think about for some
although it is important to remember the
positives like how much happiness and
companionship that animal would have
brought an aging owner in their last
years of life even someone younger who
dies unexpectedly might have had their
quality of life infinitely improved by
owning a loving pet to make them smile
but on the other hand there's the
negative downside that now some pets
have to live on after a tragic death not
fully understanding where their beloved
owner went so often we hear stories of
dogs that waited for their Master to
come home only for them to never walk
through the front door again and it's
equally hard when things pan out the
opposite way and an owner loses their
pet the one silver lining is that we as
human beings have a far greater
understanding of death and the grief it
causes we know that eventually despite
how hard it can be to adjust to that
initial heartbreaking loss it is
possible to move on and for things to
one day get better but what happens when
someone can't accept the death of their
beloved animal companion when the
unconditional love of their pet is
suddenly missing from their life how far
will a person go to recapture that
feeling how long does it take for grief
born out of love to become an unhealthy
fixation and what is the true price of
obsession well the answer involves
scp-589 both what it can give and just
as easily take away for as long as she
could remember and even further back
than that Aaron and her dog Pancho had
been Inseparable ever since her mom had
first adopted that scrappy little Jack
Russell Terrier Aaron had fallen head
over heels in love with that little
rascal loving a pet is different from
loving another person because they just
can't help showing how much they love
you back humans for all their good
qualities are so nuanced and not
everyone is honest with each other all
of the time but a pet especially a dog
even though they can't speak a bark or a
whimper or excited wagging of a tail can
easily tell you how they're feeling and
Poncho was no exception Aaron and her
mom Cleo lived alone who was just the
two of them for quite a long time and
while Cleo had little problem with that
she couldn't help but notice how
isolating it was for her daughter from a
young age Aaron had always been quiet
kept to herself at School her mom kept
expecting her to make some friends asked
to invite them over or vice versa but it
didn't seem to be happening it didn't
seem to be bothering her daughter but
Cleo was worried that it was giving her
the wrong idea and being on her own was
somehow better so in an effort to give
Aaron at least one source of
companionship Pancho joined the family
brown patches dotted over his white fur
he was the perfect pet an excitable and
loving little puppy that Aaron was
immediately smitten with when Cleo told
her he was hers to keep being only seven
years old Aaron broke down crying with
tears of joy her mom had let her pick
out a name for him and she'd quickly
settled on Poncho at first Aaron had men
to say it differently in order to name
the pup after a friendly character from
her favorite animated movie but had
mispronounced it in her excitement at
meeting the energetic dog for the first
time the name quickly stuck though and
as the years went on and Pancho got
bigger her Aaron bought her four-legged
best friend a little Poncho of his own
to wear when it started raining over the
following years Pancho became Aaron's
most constant and loving companion even
as she grew up moving through her
childhood and found making friends a
little easier with every passing year
there never came a time when she didn't
need her best friend when Aaron had her
first breakup in high school and came
home with floods of Tears In Her Eyes
Pancho could sense she was upset and
came wandering up to her sitting in her
lap to make her feel just a little bit
better then a few years later when her
mom got sick Aaron had to take care of
her a task that would have been much
harder without Pancho there to alleviate
that stress and lift her and Cleo's
spirits and when Cleo eventually passed
the little white and brown dog sat
quietly with his owner as she said
goodbye to her mom now that it was just
the two of them Aaron and Pancho were
living in a tiny apartment it was
crammed for one person and a dog but
Aaron was just grateful to have a place
to live and the company of her favorite
pop besides Pancho wasn't a puppy
anymore in fact he hadn't raced around
the park or chased a ball for quite a
long time with the numerous stresses of
her everyday life least of all holding
down two jobs in her desperate attempts
to make enough money to pay rent Aaron
had hardly noticed the signs Pancho was
showing his age it had been happening
gradually in the background over the
years he wouldn't chase the ball or
really move around much and when he did
it was little more than a lethargic plot
around the apartment perhaps it was
because of such a measured slower Pace
change that Aaron was unable to
acknowledge it she could see her old
friend was getting more tired sleeping
longer his tail really wagging as much
as it used to but by now that felt like
Pancho's normal behavior then again
given how important her dog was to her
it's just as likely she didn't want to
accept the truth that unfortunately
nothing lasts forever he was almost 15
in human years which by all accounts is
an impressive age for a dog especially
one of Pancho's size and breed it was on
a day that Aaron was out working her
morning job when it happened the
faithful adoring Jack Russell Terrier
who had spent his years being nothing
but loved and giving back only more love
in return curled up on Aaron's bed the
apartment was still Silent not a sound
to be heard save for those last tired
few breaths laying there maybe the dog
wondered if he'd ever get to see his
friend again if she would make it back
from work in time he closed his little
brown eyes and peacefully drifted off
for one last sleep during the break
between her shifts after the end of the
one at her first job and before starting
her second Aaron had just enough time to
get home usually she had just had enough
time to eat and get herself ready for
the changeover then quickly check on
Pancho before having to dash back out
poking her head into the bedroom she saw
her dog laying right there on her bed
there was a Stillness to him that
instantly made her stomach drop his ears
didn't move when she called his name he
didn't react when she stroked his fur he
was gone and the moment she realized it
Aaron felt like her whole world had come
crashing down the loss of her oldest and
closest friend heard almost as much as
losing her mom Aaron always felt that
the problem with funerals wasn't just
how sad they were or how it always
seemed to rain when she went to one
instead it was more that they could
never properly sum up just how much
someone truly meant nobody could ever
condense the year's worth of love and
memories into a burial and it was worse
when losing a pet there was no
procession no wake nobody else there
just her and Poncho saying goodbye a
final time eventually things got to be
too much the Heartbreak of Pancho's
death was another struggle in the
lifetime of lows that had all left their
lasting wounds on Aaron that coupled
with this stress of trying to carry on
with a busy life barely able to keep
herself afloat in either of her jobs had
pushed her to the edge of a breakdown
maybe that's what summoned it perhaps
something had sensed all of Aaron's
mental anguish and had come to seek her
out it might have been that her wishes
for something some little alleviation to
all the pain and stress were finally
being granted or maybe it was just a
gift left by her neighbor the sun had
long since set when Aaron arrived back
at her apartment stepping over the
envelopes that littered her doormat a
few with words like overdue and Urgent
notice printed on them in red ink
passing through the hallway Aaron paused
as she always did hoping to hear the
gentle patterning of Paws against the
floor her therapist had dissuaded her
from doing that saying it would only
make moving on from losing Poncho worse
she didn't care she wanted her dog back
and opening the door to her bedroom it
seemed like someone had been listening
sat on her bed was a stuffed animal
right in the spot where she had found
her little friend on that horrible day
it had been made to look like a dog
specifically resembling a Jack Russell
Terrier with brown patches over its
white fur the plushie was even wearing a
little rain poncho the side of it was
enough to cause Aaron to break down in
tears weeping in heavy sobs as she
dashed across the bedroom to hold it in
her arms hugging it tightly her tears
seeped into the soft fur as she felt it
against her face she didn't even think
to question where it had even come from
all she wanted to do in that moment was
hold the stuffed animal close for the
first time in what felt like years a
feeling of relief washed over Aaron it
was as if everything was melting away
the stress of work and the toll of her
tiring shifts gone all the pain from
losing Cleo and Pancho dissipated too in
fact it felt like she now had her
beloved dog back now it was better than
that it was almost as though everything
about Poncho his energy his spirit the
way he made her feel so calm and loved
was all distilled into this stuffed
animal and now it would never grow old
never age and die causing her more pain
Aaron gripped the soft toy tightly the
longer she held the hug for the more her
stress and sadness faded her face was
still wet with tears although her
sobbing had gradually become low gentle
Chuckles soon giving way to appeal of
uncontrollable laughter rising in volume
it was as though she had taken something
and the Very chemistry of her brain was
being altered but after so much hardship
it felt good to the point where she was
almost lightheaded laying down on the
floor of her bedroom arms locked around
the plushie that reminded her so much of
Poncho Aaron continued softly giggling
to herself her entire body relaxed so
much so that every part of her felt like
warm butter as if she was about to start
melting through the floorboards although
she didn't know it or probably wouldn't
have even cared her dopamine levels were
spiking flooding her with the bodily
hormone that relieves stress and makes a
person feel good in fact right now she
was feeling better than she ever had
every day that followed Aaron would come
home to our stuffed animal her Poncho
too as she'd like to think of it it
didn't bother her how childlike anyone
else might find it for a grown woman to
rely so heavily on a plushie for Comfort
at any rate it wasn't something she was
advertising to anyone else after every
shift at both of her jobs she'd race
back to her apartment right to Pancho
too and just sit there just basking in
the way it made her feel it was the most
all-encompassing sense of euphoria and
relief reducing her stress so much that
she felt like she was floating her body
lighter than air that feeling was all
that mattered to her some days she
wouldn't even eat Poncho 2 was more
important to her than food gradually she
started to become addicted to that
feeling having to wait until the end of
her work shifts to feel that Rush of
happy chemicals flood her brain was too
long of a delay she started to Crave it
while working unable to focus feeling
erratic and Restless without Poncho 2.
of course she couldn't risk bringing it
to work with her what if someone took it
or she dropped it her boss might see her
with a stuffed animal at her desk and
fire her on the spot or think that she
was absolutely crazy the only safe place
for her source of relief was at home but
Aaron knew she needed something to
bridge the gap while she was working the
only substitute that worked was taking a
photo of Pancho 2 on her phone then
blowing it up and printing off a copy
Aaron could carry it around portably
keeping it in her pocket and taking it
out to look at it every few minutes
while she worked the head of positive
chemicals it gave her wasn't quite as
strong as getting to hold her stuffed
animal after all it was just a grainy
photo from her phone essentially acting
like a patch to tighter over until she
could get back home to the real thing
however it didn't take long for Aaron to
start taking Pancho with her anywhere
that wasn't work to the grocery store to
visit her mom and her dog and of course
to therapy I'm rather concerned about
this pattern of behavior Aaron's
psychotherapist Dr Lee stated when her
patient explained what had been
happening sitting across on the opposite
side of her office on a leather couch
Aaron had Poncho too pressed tightly
against her I don't care she sighed her
brain already Awash with hormones that
kept her calm I like how it makes me
feel so I don't care Aaron look at
yourself Dr Lee urged you aren't
properly dealing with your grief it
seems to me you're channeling all your
desire for positive emotion into this
stuffed animal Poncho two Aaron
corrected her without taking her eyes
off the soft brown and white dog in its
little cloak listen to me the therapist
insisted trying desperately to get
through to her Poncho your dog your real
dog is gone you lost him six months ago
and her mom Cleo she passed away 2 2 you
have to process and come to terms with
those things as sad as they might make
you feel that's how we move on but what
you're doing right now isn't healthy
Aaron it's becoming an obsession Turning
Away Aaron press Poncho 2 up against her
face I don't care she repeated by now
Aaron had become fully dependent on
Poncho II showing up late for both jobs
just so she could spend longer feeling
those endorphins and hormones that
hugging the stuffed animals seem to
bring it didn't take long for her to
start skipping entire shifts for days at
a time and canceling any and all other
plans just to sit at home basking in the
relief brought on by her apparent
Obsession her apartment became a mess
untidy piles of mail by the front door
the walls plastered with hundreds of
photos of her stuffed animal fueling her
Obsession her evening job was the first
to fire Aaron citing her recent absences
as the grounds for her dismissal even
then she still didn't seem to care the
fact she might not be able to make rent
barely registered returning home after
her other job called her in to tell
Aaron she would no longer be working
there either she instantly looked around
for Poncho too but it was nowhere to be
found all the photos on the walls having
faded Aaron checked her phone all the
original copies of the pictures were
gone too instantly racked with fear so
addicted to the plushie that she could
barely function without it she began
tearing her apartment to shreds looking
for it she wrenched cupboards off their
hinges and tipped over her refrigerator
flipping her mattress Aaron sliced the
fabric open with a kitchen knife
searching high and low for Poncho too
but I'm able to find it anywhere she
became frantic erratic pulling her hair
out in a fit of uncontrollable despair
where had it gone had someone stolen it
Dr Lee the paranoia had already set in
convincing Aaron that her therapist must
have taken Pancho too she was the only
other person who knew about it and had
been so critical of her using it to to
make herself feel better marching into
Dr Lee's office utterly enraged Beyond
Reason all Aaron could think about was
getting her stuffed animal back no
matter what she had to do the effect it
had on her was so powerful so potent and
addictive that living without it was
worth anything even another person's
life
little did Aaron realize as her hands
grew wetter coated with more of Dr Lee's
blood after every bludgeoning strike her
therapist had no idea where Pancho 2 was
in fact she had nothing to do with it
Vanishing in the first place it had
disappeared all on its own along with
all the photograph copies Aaron had
printed arriving somewhere miles away
scp-589 was ready to begin the whole
cycle again on its next victim it would
take on whatever shape it needed to
appease the desires of the very next
person to find it preying on their
vulnerability and making them totally
dependent on it that was what it did
everywhere it went leeching off people
that it could easily manipulate its
presence and interaction would calm
scp-589's victims helping to alleviate
their stress or make them feel better
about their deepest insecurities before
long these helpless victims would be
able to think of nothing else feeling as
if they were unable to live without
their ups session doll and every time
that was when scp-589 would make its
cruelest move it would vanish leaving
its prey in a state of intense
withdrawal with a calming influence of
scp-589 absent from their lives all of a
sudden the infected people would suffer
from a variety of potential
psychological symptoms manic depression
psychosis uncontrollable despair
Dementia or an Aaron's case paranoia and
a heightened sense of aggression that
caused her to murder Dr Lee that was one
of the earliest in a Spate of similar
incidents that had been reported as
scp-589 traveled from town to town its
influence spread leaving entire
populations dead in its wake all the
while the stuffed animal fed on the
mental anguish that it caused its
victims making them pay the ultimate
price for their Obsession Dr Jack Bright
is a man known by many names and whether
that name is oh God no or just Jack if
you've spent any amount of time here on
SCP explained you've surely at least
heard of the good doctor once or twice
he's a high-ranking senior staff member
at site 19. one of the foundation's most
notable facilities and has served as a
director and important member of the
foundation's upper ranks for decades of
course you wouldn't be able to tell that
by looking at him because depending on
the current circumstances Dr bright
might not look a day over 13 or 80 or 90
or he might just be a chimpanzee this is
because Dr bright in his younger days
came into contact with scp-963 a metal
amulet that gives its wearers
Consciousness immortality when the
amulet is moved from one body to another
Dr Bright's Consciousness moves with it
allowing him to occupy a variety of
bodies from animals to old ladies Dr
bright has been them all act Bright's
body swapping abilities have even proven
themselves to be incredibly useful for
the foundation so the guys able to get
some actual work done when he's not
goofing off in undercover operations Dr
bright has been used to infiltrate areas
that the foundation would typically have
trouble reaching or when clandestine
operations are the best course of action
in the 2000 United States election Dr
bright briefly occupied the body of
George Bush in order for the foundation
to investigate political opponent Al
Gore's activities without suspicion but
that mess is a story for another day
today we're going to be taking a look at
a different side of Dr Jack Bright one
that isn't so overt one that's lurking
behind the joking facade and silly
antics so commonly associated with
Bright's identity this is SCP explained
and we'd like to welcome you into the
complicated dramatic and ultimately
tragic world of the bright family
specifically the story of
scp-590 your Consciousness being
Immortal certainly has its perks for one
UK can't die on the other hand you can't
die we all know the old cliche about
immortality how your friends and loved
ones will grow old and die off while
you'll stay the same age how centuries
will start to feel like months how your
mind will eventually crumble under the
weight of countless years and
experiences because no man was made to
live this long but while it is cliche
for us it's reality for Dr bright he's
painfully aware of how futile his
situation is and behind closed doors it
scares him Dr bright struggles intensely
with existential depression and for good
reason too right now he might be fine
but in the relatively near future he'll
start experiencing that cycle of death
and Rebirth of those around him and
himself and over time that cycle will
just keep repeating body after body
friend after friend tragedy after
tragedy in the long term Dr bright knows
that his life cannot have
happy ending it's most likely because of
this biting inevitable future that
bright makes the most of his time with
those around him in the foundation
making himself known as a Charming goofy
personality brimming with quirks and
xaniness the part of bright that makes
others laugh does so because deep down
bright needs something to take his mind
off his situation he wants the same type
of familiarity and comfort that he
brings to other people but Bright's
public-facing Persona is often torn to
shreds in private on top of being an
undying Soul bright has to contend with
an even more stressful experience his
family the bright family is a colorful
assortment of old blood that has run the
inner circle of the anomalous world for
Generations there are members of the
bright family that were there when the
first administrators signed the policy
that created the SCP Foundation members
who serve time on the overseer Council
and even those who operate outside of
the parameters of the foundation Dr
bright is just one among many other
individuals of major anomalous
significance in his bloodline and it's
only fitting that every family has its
issues for the brights all strong
personalities who hold positions of
power in various places across the
anomalous World Unity isn't exactly a
strong point in fact most of the family
isn't anywhere near each other each
member existing in their own bubble
working towards their own individual
goals that often do not align with the
rest of their kin but there are
occasions when the bright family all
come together to sneer at one another
from across the table and enjoy a nice
loving reunion though these meetings are
often called out of necessity and are
far and few between this Gathering of
anomalous individuals is deemed
important enough by the foundation to
have its own designated security term
nicknamed Code Brown when a Code Brown
is issued it can only mean that the
brights are locked away in a room
convening arguing and scheme aiming over
something of great importance to them
and the rest of the world should stay
out of their family business and when
Jack Bright got his latest call for a
family meeting from one of the family
members he was on speaking terms with he
could only think of just how bad of an
idea that was it had been quite some
time since bright saw the rest of his
family and he didn't particularly look
forward to when they would meet again in
the time since then Wright had been
taking care of TJ his younger brother
whose story is nearly as tragic as Jax
don't worry we'll get back to the events
of the family reunion soon enough for
now let's have a look at TJ bright TJ
was a product of the cruel brutal
attitude the early Foundation took out
on the objects it contained needlessly
cold containment procedures that denied
basic needs for human anomalies
pointless tests that often resulted in
death or worse and a general lack of
regard for decency or ethics this
archaic era would come to an end upon
the form nation of the Ethics Committee
a board formed in the upper ranks of the
foundation that would enforce a better
treatment of the objects contained by
the organization with severe
consequences for those that disobeyed
the new more human Doctrine but in the
case of TJ bright there was nothing the
committee could do TJ who had been given
the designation of scp-590 long ago was
an ordinary person who happened to have
anomalous abilities like countless
others that the foundation had dealt
with before he appeared to be
permanently 16 years old never aging or
changing an appearance once during his
time in containment the abilities in
question that had caught the attention
of the foundation were TJ's inherent
power to cure illness physical mental
injuries and wounds TJ could cure them
all with just a touch of his hand but at
an unfortunate cost whatever injury TJ
would cure it would be mirrored onto his
own body a giant gaping wound could be
healed by TJ but the after effects of
such such as scar tissue and any lasting
side effects would later appear on his
own body leaving the boy to feel the
pain of everyone he touched and healed
the early Foundation needlessly
exploited to scp-590s abilities and
tests and procedures testing the limits
of TJ's body and its abilities this of
course was carried out without the
knowledge of his brother Dr bright who
at the time did not have enough polar
power within the organization to save
his brother he could only watch and hope
that one day
scp-590 could live a better life outside
of his cell as TJ bright and not a
number on a placard to be experimented
with so casually the foundations
experiments with TJ sometimes involve
the use of scp-500 and all curing
Panacea that would fully heal as cp590
and bring him back to full health a
state that would later be reverted when
the foundation started their EXP
tournaments with the boy once again TJ
had endured immeasurable pain and as a
result had suffered a broken mental
state over the years as time went by and
things within the foundation had started
to change including Jack Bright's
prominence he worked as hard as he could
to push through bureaucratic red tape
and work out a solution that would leave
TJ in a less torturous position and when
the time came it was Jack Bright who
made the call to have scp-590 cure a
variety of specific mental conditions
that would leave the boy in a dulled
State unable to fully comprehend the
pain he endures should the foundation
ever have to utilize TJ's abilities
again Bryant's decision to do this to
his brother was questionable and a part
of the doctor regrets it to this day but
at the time it seemed like a more
preferable option than having scp-590 be
fully aware of what was happening to him
unfortunately the idea that TJ's reduced
mental capacities would prevent him from
standing what was occurring to him was a
misunderstanding and TJ was still more
than capable of perceiving what was
happening to him and that was pain he
knew he was being hurt he knew he wasn't
loved and even though his mind was
unlike rights or those who experimented
with him he felt the same things they
did by the time of the reunion TJ was
fully in the care of Dr bright
eventually the modern Foundation worked
out that it was doing the poor boy more
harm than good to keep him locked up in
a Cell all day and bright who was now
one of the most notable and important
individuals in the foundation was able
to pull enough strings to get TJ out of
confinement now he could truly rest
without worry that he would be exploited
and abused safe alongside his older
brother inside the meeting room all of
the famous figures of the bright family
while the ones that were alive at least
were there Dr bright sat alongside TJ
who occupied himself with a a coloring
book and a set of crayons from across
the table was mikhailbright better known
as overseer 05-6 a former Foundation
agent who operated under the name of
cowboy
05-6 was a hardened individual with a
heavy interest in firearms and a whole
lot of luck on his side Mikhail and Jack
almost at the same time both fired out
remarks about how bad of an idea they
felt this reunion was the one who called
The Reunion was their elder sister
Claire bright whose aged body felt
notably out of place among the
collection of Forever Young brights
whether it was Jack's body hopping TJ's
longevity or mikhail's use of scp-006
the overseer council's Fountain of Youth
to keep himself young for an extended
period of time also present was Yorick
Elroy Jack Bright's grandson as the
three of them discussed the state of
Claire Bright's apparent aging situation
Yorick remarked that he thought she was
involved with that incident at site-23
this Dr bright knew was referring to an
incident he'd rather forget where a
reality Bender contained by the
foundation attempted to give the bright
family himself Mikhail and TJ included a
happy ending where they would be cured
of their ailments and allowed to live
ordinary lives of course this was just
the product of a reality band and the
fantasy quickly fell apart when the
brights realized what was going on Jack
rather not dwelt on what could have been
across from York was Foundation agent
Sarah Argent one of the youngest members
of the bright family who worked as an
overseer council's hand Sinister a
special title granted to an assassin
used by the council to sort out messy
business for them the previous hand
Sinister was none other than
mikhailbright whose Pearl revolvers that
came with the position now belong to
Sarah Macau was growing impatient and
asking how long it would take for the
rest of the family to show up the rest
of the family being the brides that
weren't involved in the foundation
Nation the powerful individuals who had
worked their way into various groups of
interest and aspects of the anomalous
World while some directly opposed the
foundation and its Mission and others
were neutral they were all brights which
meant their presence was necessary while
the two sides sometimes worked together
there was always an air of Bad Blood and
poor trust between them Dr bright in
particular was not looking forward to
the rest of this meeting the first to
arrive was an individual named nobody
who the foundation had a difficult time
keeping up with nobody was a title
granted from one person to the next who
each worked towards a greater plan that
only nobody knew the specific details of
leaving the foundation completely
unaware of the group's larger interests
nobody's voice was impossible to source
and her appearance was even harder to
pin down but she was there nobody
circled around the table remarking that
the other side of the family had sent
her first to make sure the foundation
Brides were all abiding by the rules at
one point in time nobody did have
another name but in becoming the next
nobody she left her previous Life Behind
The Next To Arrive was Claire luminux II
a human with electromagnetic abilities
whose motives were largely unknown when
she pulled back the chair to sit down
Sparks flew in the air briefly startling
the rest of the room after that came
David blindman a Gruff sunglass wearing
member of the Serpent's hand a group of
anomalous individuals who worked to free
anomalies from the confinements of the
foundation who they called jailers Blind
Men was mikhail's son and possessed the
anomalous ability to see into the future
he was The Unofficial representative of
The unnumbered Brood a subsection of the
bright family consisting of mikhail's
illegitimate children from his Wilder
days as a free roaming Foundation agent
and a constant reminder to the overseer
of his past naturally Mikhail was less
than pleased to see his son arrive and
then there was Evelyn navon who
levitated into the room wearing a
traditional hijab and dress Evelyn was
one of the original 13 founding members
of the SCP Foundation and matriarch of
most of the bright family unfortunately
Evelyn was kicked off the council for
reasons unknown the rumor has it that it
had something to do with her terrible
experiments as a genius geneticist
creating Monsters by splicing the DNA of
the ordinary and the anomalous she sold
her work to groups of interests such as
Dr wondertainment or Prometheus Labs who
benefited from having such fine test
subjects to work with her current
activities are largely unknown but as
the rest of the family knew they
couldn't be anything good the final
member of the bright family to enter was
the only one who was trusted by all of
them and was a man of many many names
who was most commonly referred to as
Tamlin Tamlin was a mysterious
individual who existed for centuries far
longer than any other member of the
family he had something to do with time
but no one was quite sure of what it was
that he did but they all knew that he
was important and that he was the only
one who attempted to keep peace and
balance between the various factions of
the family Tamlin took a mental count of
the room realizing that everyone was
present and addressed them all ready to
explain why they were there collectively
the family came to realize that the one
who called the meeting Claire bright was
not there Tamlin solely explained that
she had passed away and he had called
the family together in her Steed to
present a videotape containing her dying
wish the tape was concocted through
Claire and tamlin's time Shenanigans and
featured a recording of Claire Hood
through tamlin's abilities to travel
through and control time was able to
respond and interact with the members of
the family in the room as morbid as Dr
brightfelt this was he would make sure
to treasure this final interaction with
his sister Claire's recording contained
her will and with tamlin's help she
distributed gifts to the other members
of the family final remembrances she had
collected from across the anomalous
world for them to cherish an egg with a
universe inside of it for Evelyn the
literal sword of democles to hang over
mikhail's head jack Bright's first ever
bottle of whiskey that he made so many
years before documents she entrusted to
her daughter Claire II when it came time
for TJ's gift however the boy suddenly
grew serious and declined it the
recording of Claire understood and
stated that if he didn't want it then
she would instead have Tamlin give it to
someone who needed it Dr bright could
only wonder what it was that she had
planned to give TJ but it seemed like
the boy's selfless nature had won again
and he was unable to accept it after the
gifts had been distributed the tape cut
out Tamlin stated that this was all that
Claire had recorded and that she wanted
her death to bring the family together
once again to remind them all that they
were family Claire's sincerity had
brought the room to silence each member
of the family engaged in deep thought as
Tamlin gave parting remarks one by one
each member left Mikhail was embarrassed
by the ordeal immediately trying to
revert back to his overseer mindset but
he couldn't Blair's loss was already
affecting him in the end there was only
Tamlin who left a single blue rose on
top of the VCR player that contained
Claire's recording in remembrance of
someone he felt almost understood him as
Dr bright left the meeting he still felt
conflicted about his family but at the
very least he felt there was progress
being made after all they had all been
in the same room for more than 10
minutes without trying to kill one
another he glanced at the boy at his
side wondering if he made the right
decision all those years ago well that
much and most of his job with the
foundation was uncertain he knew one
thing for a fact he had to protect TJ
you would think the smell would be the
worst part and don't get me wrong it was
far from Pleasant to say the least that
pungent odor a stomach turning scent
like raw sewage it wasn't just dirt and
Decay now it was far more disgusting
than that it had that awful metal Tang
to it that meant when that awful stench
crawled its way up your nose it lingered
hanging at the back of your throat
choking you on the sickening wreak that
lay thick in the air like a
foul-smelling fog and yet like I said
that was far from the worst part what
was well even the side of what had
happened to him wasn't what made me feel
unsettled hardly any of his body was
visible covered in that writhing
shifting cloak but I could see it move
each tiny piece of the mass moving on
its own it made me imagine what it must
have felt like to have all those little
scratchy legs and Pinchers Claws and
teeth hooking into skin and that the
idea of what it would feel like that was
the worst part about seeing the Vermin
God City life isn't really all it's
cracked up to be ask anyone who lives in
a big urban area and they'll likely tell
you the same those bright lights and
Tall spiers reaching up to the clouds
they offer the promise of prosperity
opportunity and even Fame and Fortune
for those who are extra naive but when
they uh sticks packed their bags and
moved here to start a new life they
realized that all along they had been
sold on a dream a false fantasy that is
just simply too good to be true of
course by the time they get here it's
already too late and before they know it
their knee deep in debt trying to keep
up with paying rent on an apartment
that's barely big enough for one person
if you aren't careful a big city can
swallow you up sometimes literally never
mind just desperately trying to make
ends meet and keep yourself afloat
there's also plenty of danger to be
found in the heart of the City it
doesn't take much for people to lose
themselves in the darker parts of this
Metropolitan hell pretending it's a
Haven and when they do that's usually
where my job starts I've been working as
a private investigator for coming up on
a decade my specific job title had gone
through a number of rebrands and
different combinations of terms over the
years Cassius Duke detective for hire
then private eye and freelance
investigator after that and don't fall
under the same as sort of assumptions
that most people do when they hear all
of those terms believe me just like the
city's promises it rarely lives up to
what you'd imagined it to be like my
life was never high speed chases and
gunfights solving murders and tracking
down Crooks that rob banks and clown
masks that was work for the real police
allegedly much higher above my pay grade
now that I had quit most of the time I
dealt with uncovering the various dirty
little secrets this grimy City had to
offer more often than not my job was
working as either a spy or enforcer that
any could hire I followed around the
rivals of wealthy businessmen snapping
photos of them with my camera to get any
dirt I could that my more unethical
clients would probably use for blackmail
or I'd be warning stalkers to keep away
from whoever they were causing trouble
for usually with a bit of gentle
encouragement in the form of some pretty
Stern words and a wrap on the knuckles
of sorts it was ugly work but that
suited just how ugly the underside of
this whole city was some of my clients
were often desperate people folks who
the ordinary system of Law and Order had
found when that happened when they had
been turned away by the cops on the
verge of losing any hope they had left
that was usually when they turned to me
for hell now I don't work for free of
course you get nothing for nothing
everything's got its price so on and so
forth but I wasn't looking to extort
people especially at their lowest
moments so firm but fair I charged them
a little bit for my time maybe a if I
happen to come across some dirt that was
really worth some extra cash it was rare
for me to take on a job pro bono as it
were without expecting any pay for my
services but when this case landed in my
lap I felt obligated to do the job for
free it was another gray day in a gray
City a knock on the door interrupted me
for my busy schedule of staring at the
paint flaking off my ceiling after I'd
called them through the person
responsible for that knock came stepping
cautiously into my office he told me his
name was Martin Jenkins but that his
friends called him Marty sorry I I don't
really know how all this works Martin
admitted making no attempt to mask how
nervous he was well why don't you take a
seat first I sighed that's a start oh
okay they replied awkwardly pulling up a
chair and sitting down opposite my desk
saw Mr Jenkins what can I Marty
interjected Mr Jenkins I repeated what
is it that brings you here well someone
said you might be able to help with my
problem Martin said sheepishly and what
sort of problem are you having Mr
Jenkins I push for him to give me a
straight answer I didn't really have a
lot of patience for anyone who wasted
time just getting to the point it's my
brother you see the other Mr Jenkins he
finally confessed he's been missing it's
actually been months now missing persons
case is a police matter I'm sorry but
you'll have to go to them as bad as it
felt turning the guy down at a time like
this I had my profession to protect if I
wasn't careful the cops would come down
on me like a ton of bricks I'd already
ruffled up some feathers in that area
not long before I'd taken a case where
and I'd accidentally photographed some
corrupt officers accepting bribes one of
those pictures wound up on the Evening
News there had been a Target on my back
ever since but detective Duke Martin
began to say Mr Duke I corrected him
I've already tried going to the police
they wouldn't even accepted a missing
person's case when I explained what
happened to my brother
I said reaching for my notebook and a
pen on the desk I left the city a while
ago after my brother and I Melvin his
name's Melvin Jenkins we we had an
argument and what was it that triggered
this argument I asked dragging my pen
across the page hey it was well a lot of
things Martin's side our father died
almost a year ago it wasn't unexpected
but Mel took it pretty hard then the
doctors told us the condition dad had
carried a chance of being hereditary so
we both went to get tested I didn't show
any signs of developing it but Alvin did
he took it as a death sentence got very
low and started wasting all of our
inheritance on every Vice he could get
his hands on drinking partying gambling
you name it he was doing it and this led
to the argument I broke it did I
confronted him before I left town I was
mad that he'd been using all our dad
left us for such frivolous and
irresponsible things Marvin continued
his story almost unable to stop now he's
started and he didn't want to hear any
of it said he was going to die
eventually anyway so what was the point
and I told him he was selfish and that
was the last time we spoke when did you
notice he was missing as soon as I came
back from out of town he answered I went
to the apartment dad had left us that
too along with all the payments still
due and I found that Mel was gone
apparently he had better in a card game
and lost badly I had no way of finding
him nobody else knew where he was let me
guess I stepped in when you went to the
police they said he's most likely living
on the street which would make him a lot
harder to find Martin nodded solemnly
clearly feeling guilty for what had
happened although from where I was
sitting it was his brother's own
misgivings that had created this
situation I went on to ask a few more
background questions before asking if Mr
Jenkins could provide me with a photo of
his missing brother be obliged handing
over a printed picture the moment I saw
it I offered to take the case for free
his brother Melvin I recognized him
almost instantly it was in his mid or
possibly late 30s average height and
build in the picture far better shape
and a lot cleaner than when I'd seen him
but it was that same guy that much I was
sure of no amount of unshaved stubble or
disheveled clothing could change that
I'd seen him seen Melvin outside my
building a few times sleeping rough on
the sidewalk every day that I showed up
to start another day of work I dropped
him a few dollars anything I had in my
wallet at first I told myself it was for
good luck so I didn't attract any bad
karma for myself but when I actually
paid attention to how he was living the
gesture became what it should have been
from the start it wasn't about me or
sparing myself bad luck it was just
about trying to help out someone who
needed it when I was in a position to do
him a small kindness at the very least
one night I just locked up my office and
I was about to head home as I stepped
off the curb Head Down Eyes on my phone
a truck came speeding down the street I
would have been killed instantly had a
hand not grab me and pulled me back onto
the sidewalk Melvin had hold me out of
Harm's Way he didn't say anything to me
and I failed to do anything more than
just thank him verbally before heading
home so I figured I owed him one well I
didn't tell his brother this it had been
a few months since I last seen Melvin
outside my building I'd always assume he
moved on or been asked to move by an
overzealous cop of course that meant
figuring out where he was going was
going to be tricky exactly the reason
the police had turned Martin away when
he'd asked them for help locating his
brother but I had a few connections that
even if they hadn't seen Melvin might
have at least heard something or could
know someone else that had seen him it
wasn't a lead yet but it was a star D
was the head of the city's biggest
homeless shelter and a good friend of
mine so she became my first Port of Call
I showed her the photo of Melvin and
asked if he come to stay at the shelter
recently doesn't ring a bell I'm afraid
she looks somberly at the picture sorry
Duke I wish I could be more help not on
you I replied taking the photo is she
handed it back to me you mind if I ask
around see if anyone here recognizes him
to be my guest decent I spent about an
hour Milling around asking a few down on
their luck folks if they recognize the
man in the photo a few of them mentioned
they'd seen him around here and there
sleeping rough in a number of different
parts of the city but none of them could
give me anything concrete no definite
location I'd be able to search next that
was until one of them spoke up he was an
older guy but dabbled clothes and
unwashed hair with a thick beard who had
been craning his neck to try and sneak a
look at the photo when I'd been showing
someone else I seen him the man Clarence
said matter of factly you recognize this
man I asked to verify said I seen him he
repeated looks different now though well
that's to be expected I replied I don't
mean he's gotten skinnier because he
ain't been eaten Clarence said in retort
I mean that he don't even look like he's
human no more but what does that mean I
questioned looking back at the bearded
man in confusion that Batman right there
stopped being a man no idea when or how
it happened but last time I saw him it
was already too late nowadays he's the
Vermin God I didn't really have much of
an idea of how to respond unsure if
Clarence was pulling my leg and
deliberately wasting my time if there
was some truth to this bizarre urban
legend at any rate it was the only real
lead I had so far albeit a tenuous one
at Best so I pressed the old man to tell
me where he'd seen Melvin of This Vermin
God as he kept calling him there's an
abandoned warehouse down on the
waterfront Clarence had explained I knew
the place he meant it used to be a go-to
for people who were sleeping rough lots
of us used to stay there but that's when
the pests got bad busts what kind of
pests all kinds rats roaches you name it
man just we were having to deal with
them the company that owned the building
sent cops down to clear us out told us
it was unsafe and we should move on it
was sitting there empty for ages so I
decided to chance it head down there and
see if we could stop use in the place
again but when I went to look he was
there waiting in the dark and he wasn't
alone he ain't ever alone they're always
with him all around him I chose to
ignore clarence's attempts at unnerving
me getting him to confirm once again
that it was in fact Melvin he had seen
my next call was following up on this
wild story so so I hopped on to the next
bus across town huddled together with
commuters holding on to ceiling rails
swaying with every turn of the bus like
we were meat hanging in the back of a
butcher's van I walked quite a bit from
the bus stop towards the docks most of
the area was restricted off limits to
members of the general public given how
hazardous it could be I wasn't concerned
in my line of work I usually had to get
into places I wasn't supposed to be
pulling a pair of wire cutters from my
jacket pocket I snipped through the
chain link fence that surrounded the
warehouse Clarence had directed me to
the place wasn't guarded after all it
was empty lifting up the wire mesh and
slipping underneath through the Gap I
grabbed my flashlight and headed in the
warehouse was well and truly deserted
previously used for storage but now just
an empty space that was being left
vacant wasted in its lack of use all
around was silence occasionally broken
by beads of water dripping from the
Skylight into a puddle on the ground
suddenly I heard a new noise a crunch of
something being squashed under the sole
of my shoe I lifted my foot and Shone my
Torchlight downwards looking to see what
I just stepped on it was a cockroach far
bigger and fatter than anyone I'd ever
seen smashed to Pieces underneath my
shoe I stamped the rest of it off a
little disgusted as how everyone gets
when they see a roach dead or alive
that's when I noticed another sound a
low dull buzzing my initial thought was
that it was electrical maybe a generator
that was still running I started
searching around for the source of the
sound thinking that if I could flip the
switch it might turn on some lights in
here that would make searching for
Melvin a little easier suddenly as I
turned a corner the buzzing sound got
louder it wasn't just closer it was
angrier more intense what was worse was
that I'd walk directly into a cloud of
something or lots of some things tiny
flies were whizzing past my ears the
noise of their wings so close it was
almost deafening meanwhile even more
were zipping around my face landing on
my skin and rubbing their little
germ-coated legs together waving my arms
wildly I tried my best to disperse the
Swarm clearing a few of them away as I
tumbled into the next room my flashlight
clattered to the floor as I crawled over
to pick it back up blindly swatting more
of the insects away in the dark that's
when I saw him the Vermin god with no
light in the room only the beam for my
flashlight I hadn't noticed it at first
the second the light fell over the
writhing Mass it shifted as a matter of
fact it didn't stop moving not once it
was a seething assortment of vermin
mostly black rats their fur wet with I
could only assume was water straight
from the sewer but there was more worms
huge spiders thick roaches dropping off
of the huge shape as it turned it stood
up a mass of animals and insects
standing like a man lumbering towards me
creatures were falling off with every
step only to crawl back in and join the
rest I pushed myself back on the floor
trying to get away from what I assumed
to be a horrific monster something
controlling all the rats and Vermin
making them form around it like a cloak
of pure filth and Decay the stench of it
as well that foul unclean smell hanging
in the air and lingering at the back of
my throat made me want to be sick it was
so repugnant that it kept me crawling
back until my back was pressed up
against the wall trapping me between it
and the Vermin God it leaned closer
reaching out an arm covered in Grime and
cockroaches all crawling over each other
I turned away and closed my eyes yelling
out into the dark for anyone to come and
help a voice said weekly I looked up at
it panting and shaking in fear with
trembling fingers I lifted my flashlight
higher right up to the head of the
Vermin God beneath the mass of rats
crawling over it and the bugs wriggling
about below them a pair of eyes glinted
in my flashlight's beam human eyes they
were eyes I'd seen before the same
hopelessness behind them is when he used
to ask for change outside my building it
was Melvin that's when I started to see
beneath the Vermin coating his body
catching brief glimpses of his arms and
chest just as one rat moved but before
another slipped in and took its place
his skin was pockmarked with bites and
scratches some fresh and still bleeding
others that had started to dry beneath
the shroud of crawling insects and
rodents his face had gotten gaunt coated
in the thick layer of dirt he wasn't
controlling these things if anything the
Vermin seemed to be using him as some
kind of host just as I edged a little
closer to him considering the idea of
reaching into the the mass and pulling
Melvin free one of the rats spit me I
dropped my torch at the pain of the tiny
needley teeth piercing my skin and
started to feel more of them crawling up
my ankles I turned heel and ran all the
way out of the warehouse by the time I
was far enough away the rats that had
left onto me had crawled back off
heading back inside into their Vermin
God now go and check out
scp-1025 Encyclopedia of common diseases
and scp-3760 like a doll's eye for more
sickening stories of other anomalous
illnesses that are guaranteed to make
your skin crawl or maybe that's just the
rats you're feeling